or football you're leading so much at
halftime that
the match is simply over I mean I'm
pretty sure I watched the Maverick Suns
game the other day and there was a big
halftime lead that did not stick so not
to you know rub salt in that wound over
there Jeffrey but big halftime leads
don't always win you the match
yeah but okay that that one
okay for in Wesley's case
it did it certainly did and sorry to do
that to you buddy but we do have to talk
about Group B because there are some
exciting names there as well we start in
the upper left of Matthias bluebaum the
strong German player he qualified in the
chess.com event as did Vladimir fedrosev
in the bottom right but I think all eyes
will be in the bottom left in the bottom
right here Hikaru Nakamura he is the
biggest chess streamer on the planet he
showed that he can play over the board
as well in the candidates and other
events and Magnus Carlson he has given
up his World Chess Championship title in
the future but he would like to get
another one here in Fisher random chess
yeah absolutely I mean I still believe
that Magnus he's a favorite in any
tournament that he sits down
the only thing is okay there might be
something that could potentially
distract him but if he's locked in I
think he's uh he's still the favorite
here and by the distraction you mean
that the fact that the king and queen
might not be next to each other right
that's what you're talking about
distraction over the board
another another distraction maybe Hikaru
might also be distracted a little bit
yeah
well that would give the other players a
chance in the field but Magnus Carlson
he was the runner-up in 2019 Jeffrey he
only lost to Wesley so but in 2018 he
won that head-to-head match against
Hikaru Nakamura so he does have
experience in this match format and that
can come in handy here in the 2022
version
yeah that's right he did beat a crow in
that match and I'm super looking forward
to their mini match I have a feeling
that they're going to play it safe but
we'll we'll get into that I guess a bit
later on yeah and what Jeffrey is sort
of highlighting is with two different
groups and two players going through
from each group you may not have to take
too many risks if you get out to a hot
start and well let's talk about the
matchups that we are about to see unfold
because each day brings two different
matches for the first three days then we
get into the semis and so on but today
our first matchups are greterson from
Iceland taking on Wesley so we have
Nordy back abusotara against John the
palmishi Matthias boubaum against Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson against
Vladimir ferrose of Jeffrey as you look
at these four match-ups which is your
favorite
I've got to say the abducator of nepo
looks like a mouth-watering matchup to
me I mean two Fierce competitors fire on
the board just
I I expect fireworks there
I extract fireworks everywhere I'm just
looking all across Magnus against
Federal Sav we know how strong Federal
save is you do not want to take him
lightly and with abduce a tariff against
the Palm mashia if I'm not mistaken
Jeffrey if I'm remembering correctly
that was the matchup that decided the
world rapid Championship where nordibec
beat him in the tiebreaker
that's right yeah very good memory and a
quick note about photo save I I saw the
big fish playing a lot of training on
chess.com uh prior to this event so he's
taking this seriously I hope all the
players are taking it seriously because
it's got you're gonna need your A game
yeah you certainly will because you
cannot take a single game off against
this caliber of opposition so Jeffrey
we've uh you know are getting into a
Fisher random format here the pieces
will be a bit scrambled at the start and
we can see the players in the playing
Hall here they're all getting set you
know getting ready for today's action
it's going to be a pretty grueling next
three days you play Four games of this
rapid format and it's the time Patrol
also is a bit odd right where you get 25
minutes to start the game with no
increment but then when you reach move
30 you finally get some increment in
extra five minutes so that is another
thing the players have to balance
oh yeah you make a really great point
about the time control we might have
actually glossed over that so
essentially I think it's more
traditional to have uh extra time after
40 moves all right there we can see it
uh so yeah like you said 25 minutes no
increment
and you only get in command for 30 moves
so yeah I I think we're going to see
severe time trouble uh is my guess
because it is a unique
format and also a big question can the
players do they have access to the move
counter
oh that's a very important question
because otherwise how do you know when
you're about to reach move 30. I imagine
the answer has to be yes because you're
not going to just be sitting there and
Counting one by one or uh but that's a
very good question that we will get the
answer to and I mean Jeffrey do you like
the format do you like this no increment
until you reach a certain move because I
kind of do
oh yeah I mean and for for us it's great
for the players I imagine it's it's
quite stressful because you're not
really used to playing without increment
I think um it's sort of a modern uh time
control I would say
um
but yeah I I don't know if I was playing
in this I think I would I would probably
play really fast in the beginning
fearing like the potential time travel
near the end
but isn't the issue with playing quickly
in a position that you're unfamiliar
with uh you know you may make a mistake
as early as move five which you wouldn't
if you were playing a traditional setup
yeah very true but at the end of the day
I think you just have to hope that that
it goes okay and you and you know what
you're doing somewhat
and soon we will learn the position to
start today's action the players they do
know the position so they will be
working with their seconds without
engine assistance this is actually quite
important that the players they can look
at positions analyze a bit but they are
not eligible to consult an engine before
the games obviously you cannot consult
an engine during the game that is the
rules of Chess but they're really on
their own so whoever comes up with the
better ideas Jeffrey is the player that
will be at an advantage so without
engine assistance with a random starting
position in a sense that should give
players who are not good theoreticians a
better shot
yeah and it really should and this is
sort of the game before the game because
I think this part should not be
underestimated of the preparation
leading up as you said nobody has
probably seen this Vision in their life
before
uh and I'm also curious who has a second
here do you have a scoop for us Robert
I do not have the scoop I imagine that
Magnus he typically travels with Peter
honey Nielsen so I'm you know guessing
he can just talk with him about it
um whether it's Hikaru with Chris
Littlejohn I don't have the uh the scoop
but I'm just assuming based on history
that there will be a bunch of these
players Consulting a friend and second
to help them work through the starting
position
yeah Chris Littlejohn um he's from
Dallas we're we're good friends so I can
say I can say this that Hikaru probably
shouldn't bring him to this exact event
um if there's no access to the engine
assistance
well we actually do have the starting
position so
um we now know what the players will be
looking at for their first two games of
today reminded everybody that there will
be two separate matches uh first for
example Matthias bluebound will play
against Nakamura in a two-game mini
match and then we'll play another
opponent in the second half of the day
but we have the starting position the uh
broadcast as well is on a five minute
delay we are being informed just to
ensure a fair play but Jeffrey without
further Ado here is our starting
position
yeah let's Dive Right In so first thing
I notice is
it kind of resembles this uh normal
starting position I see Rook A1 ip1
Bishop C1 King E1
um
I could really see this like transposing
to some
kind of Spanish potentially like I
imagine the Knight will go to G3 white
will Castle Queen E2
so we could really like I I think e45 is
very likely and we could see this sort
of Spanish or Italian maneuvering game
yeah I can see that I think what I like
to do when I see a Fisher random
position for the first time is look for
undefended pawns and right now we have
the H pawns without a Defender so not
that easy to Target it's not like
there's a bishop on B1 ready to open up
to that pawn we that blunder happens all
the time in Fisher random Jeffrey I know
I've made a mistake where someone plays
them with C4 and I play C5 and oops
there goes my Pawn over here uh but this
these pawns are loose but not easy to
attack and the other things I notice is
the knights are on separate sides of the
board because typically when nights are
together you kind of want to Castle
towards that side because they form good
defense so what else uh you know you
made a comment about how the setup looks
pretty normal with the queen and Bishop
in separate starting squares or
replacing each other but anything else
uh immediately cashing your attention
yeah good points I mean I myself have
also Fallen victim to this bishop takes
H7 stuff
um
right now I'm just trying to decide like
would I start with E4 D4 C4 for white
um I guess F4 is also possible if you
want to be adventurous
but right now the most principle to me
is 184 and and sort of just playing like
a very slow
um Italian Spanish as I said I I imagine
you know you'll play C3 you'll put the
bishop on B3 most probably
sort of go from there
yeah I like that you're already going
for the Royal Lopez structure without
playing Bishop B5 Bishop A4 and Bishop
back you play C3 and get your Bishop out
right away so uh sometimes in Fisher
random your Queens get caught offside
which is not good but as you point out
you can make a move like F4 or even if
you play E4 the queen already has access
on the diagonal so I'm not really
worried about the queen we're not
worried about the light Square Bishop
the dark Square Bishop is a normal spot
so the knights and the corner I think
they kind of have to jump out to G3 and
G6 nobody likes Knights on the rim they
often become dim but it seems like
they're very natural launching point so
yeah Jeffrey I agree with you nothing
too outside the norm from this starting
position
I have one interesting
inquiry already though like let's say if
white were to push 24
would you consider F5 for black as a
response oh something you would never do
in a traditional starting position but
here you can play F5 with the queen
trying to activate along the f file and
land on the F5 score that's actually a
very interesting opening decision and
there's no scandi so John Bartholomew is
going to be pretty upset about this but
there is no Scandinavian that's a bishop
not a queen so that's a really
interesting point that F5 is a viable
response from black on move one
hmm
yeah I mean
the thing is about like I don't see any
advantage for white if you start D4 D5 I
don't see like the 90 G3
I don't know it feels very solid there
for uh for black
C4 also doesn't feel right to me
so yeah I'm curious as to what these
players come up with
well you're selling me on e4 I'm I'm
definitely in agreement with you I could
see an argument for a London system
because this bishop in the London can go
out on this diagonal as well so I I
could see that right instead of D4 C3
with Bishop C2 instead of playing D4
Bishop F4 E3 and then Bishop D3 so it's
kind of similar in that regard I'm not
sure you're a big London player maybe
there is something a bit different about
this position and one other option and
you can laugh at me if you think a bad
choice the move G4 is often reasonable
in especially with the Rook behind it on
G1
yeah that's a funny idea uh normally
it's with the bishop on H1 though so you
can open the lawn diagonal
um but to your point about the London my
only concern is
you're gonna get hit with Knight G6
and then I think Bishop G3 Knight on H1
is stuck so I don't think we'll see a
London this time around but it does
appear in some other setups and I'm
pretty sure what's just appeared is a
featured chat saying the London system
is such a great opening at all times in
all variants I will disagree with that
statement but we see the first move is
played in greterson against Wesley so it
is E4 unless that's a ceremonial first
move in which case someone just put the
move on the board and maybe taken back
but the players we can see them on
camera here clapping must mean that
announcements are over look at Federal
sale by the way Jeffrey I know your
objective commentator and you focus on
the chest but that suit that is eye
popping
here's Diego he looks fresh looks spiffy
as as the young kids might say and yeah
we see okay we do see D for d5h3 yeah I
was wondering about this I think Magnus
wants a quick E4 break here
wow so if we look in the bottom right
Magnus played D4 and C5 is played by
fedo save okay things are already
getting electric early gretzerson plays
a king's Gambit but with a queen on F1
we see F5 as a response by Hikaru
Jeffrey maybe you should take down his
titles and then the top right abusot
he played D4 G5 Knight G3 so things on
all boards are already interesting with
only 25 minutes no increment for the
first 30 moves of the game you're gonna
have to make some quick decisions and is
that rapid type control and it may be
uncomfortable with your pieces a bit
scrim and look at that top right Jeffrey
D5 and F5
oh man I I think we're off to an
excellent start I love this we have four
fresh positions
um and photos if I mean he instantly
blitzed C5
I'm surprised he's thinking here though
because I I expected like you know this
is a typical benoni D5 seems a logical
uh response but he's a tank now
what a move that is you know and I'm
just looking across these games I
just don't even know which one to focus
my attention I just seeing blue bombs
night exit the corner go to G3 to attack
a car as Queen of the tempo gaining move
and
just just I'm I'm stuck Jeffrey I'm
going to be honest with you look at
magnus's face there he's already deep in
thought trying to figure out the
position uh as federusev has yet to
respond yeah I don't I don't know where
to start but I think we should just pick
one game and and feature it
okay so let's go to the game between
which one would you like to start with
actually I'm gonna be kind of like oh my
gosh oh God I mean they're all they're
all interesting like this is impossible
all right fine I'll choose I'll choose
let's go to the game between Nordic
Abdul sitarov and young nepomashi uh
because we have a game of Fisher random
Checkers going on where nepomsi putting
all of his pawns on light squares so
um if we bring up that board and we have
a chance we'll see that
um Jan putting these pawns on the light
squares controlling the center in a
stone wall type of way and abusive tar
of Jeffrey he's just playing like it's a
normal 1d4 in a classical game
indeed he is
um initial impression for me like
it's actually hard for me to say but I
kind of like this approach from from
John I think he wants a quick initiative
um against Abdus the tour of I know
personally you don't want to let him get
his attack going so I like the
aggressive approach
um I imagine maybe he wants to put the
Knight on D6
um like by F7
and his only price I think is the bishop
on C8 as in a typical Stonewall but
maybe he'll bring it out with uh B6
yeah no that's Bishop wants C8 will
remain behind a wall of Pawns and I
think it's important to note Jeffrey the
knights on G3 rather than F3 so
oftentimes when you see pawns two
squares away like this the square in
between is one that your opponent tries
to take but the knights on G3 and not in
a square that reaches E5 so uh Yan is
just relying on a stone wall a trusty
Stonewall structure and it's a bit
different and those nuances they can be
easy to overlook I know I have many
times Jeffrey
yeah and I really like that you
highlighted the Knight on G3 because as
I look at it I could see it becoming a
really bad piece um in the future so
this seems like a Crossroads here for
nordevik I see two potential ideas one
is an instant
break in the center with F3 and E4
I'm not sure if if this is a good moment
but it's something that I would have
definitely considered
yeah I like what you're saying there F3
and E4 is a viable uh strike in the
center and that would uh you know of
course need F3 first before you play E4
but then the position opens up and well
I think white will likely Castle Queen
side after the bishop and D1 moves out
the way and I don't like the look of
that King on E8 I'm not quite sure where
it's going but if the queen moves away
from f8 and Castle's King side is likely
yeah one annoying thing is I want to
play Knight F7 D6
but after Knight F7 nonobec might take
on D5 and force me to recap with the c
Pawn which feels a bit iffy
right see that's not what you want at
all so
hmm it's not going to be an easy choice
for
yawn because you poured out Knight F7 to
D6 looks like it's a very natural idea
but there are some drawbacks I'm
wondering if I go Knight B6 how will you
react
um
night to
B6 well I guess that forced you to some
of the C pawn and maybe C5 just to gain
more space
yeah and I I was gonna say like Knight
C4 there
get interesting
yeah you're just trying to jump into the
position I see that and well it looks
like Knight G6 and Bishop C2 was played
quite quickly but while this position
remains locked up we have four games
four matches going on at the same time
so let's go back hop back to our four
board scene if we can for a moment and
then we'll see maybe some other games
are looking particularly noteworthy we
have it oh look the camera view from the
playing Hall that's clearly Magnus
Carlson's game so why don't we head on
over to that game shortly I'm just gonna
quick Scout of the other positions
nothing too major closed positions
Jeffrey so Magnus against Federal
Savings Queen on D6 what in the world is
that I was about to say the exact same
thing this is so funky
um and I expect nothing less from
photosieve he's known for his unique
style of play
and um yeah what is this queen D6 like
it looks so suspicious
hmm
I'm trying to figure that out myself and
I'm saying sound like I'm thinking but
in reality I'm just questioning the
decision making of Vladimir fellow save
and that's not something I do lightly or
often because Vladimir is so strong but
this queen on D6 is you don't like
Queen's blockading Pawns
no it feels like uh
of typical benoni but with a queen on D6
and normally
any benoni is bad so I imagine that a
queen on D6 the Noni should be really
bad
yeah I mean this just looks wrong I I
just have to put it that way and the
pawn on H2 is tender we were mentioning
how the H pawns this is the bottom right
hand side of the screen
but um you know those H pawns are loose
in many positions but is it worth taking
it that's a different question
yeah I think it's it's clearly bait from
Magnus
um we can just show it really quick
Queen H2
Knight G3 was was the idea and actually
you would be forced to play Queen H4
because Rook H1 is threatening to trap
the queen
and uh Madness would just pick up H7
with with a dominating position
yeah no so F4 was just played by Magnus
he's shutting down that diagonal uh we
will pull up individual games shortly
but for now I guess we will stay on this
four board scene uh because all games
are looking interesting this early on
um but we have Magnus look at that he's
he's twiddling with a piece is that the
spare queen that is put next what is the
spare Queen yeah I so about you but
they're like
sometimes I'll
because I do this too like sometimes
I'll just intentionally capture
something so I have something to twirl
around but
yeah it helps when you have a sir Queen
I guess
look at the Audience by the way I
actually didn't quite realize there
would be a sizable live audience at the
venue in Reykjavik Iceland but Iceland
they love their chest there they
actually have so many Grandmasters a
surprising amount maybe the besides
um Israel maybe Iceland has the most
GM's uh you know per population
relatively speaking yeah I heard the
same I heard the same uh I think
obviously since the the big fish was
basket match there was a there was a
boom there
um and yeah I believe they do have the
most GM's per capita so
really nice to see a good turnout over
there
for sure and we have brought up the game
between uh Magnus and uh Federal Sav
here we just want to scroll back just
quickly to show you that this Pawn on H2
was hanging and that's what Jeffrey and
I were referring to Queen nature would
not have been a good idea Magnus was
sacrificing a pawn to play Knight G3
Rook H1 and trap the queen or at the
very least win this Pawn back on H7 so
this would have been a very bad decision
for federusev do not go upon grabbing
too early instead we saw Knight G6 F4
and Bishop A5 so Jeffrey as I look at
this position I still feel like Black's
pieces are quite a bit out of sorts but
there's already pressure on D5 with this
99 C3 pinned
man I mean if I had this position with
black I'd be absolutely terrified it
just looks too easy
for white like it's gonna start flowing
White's gonna play Bishop three he's
gonna Castle he's gonna go Knight G3 you
have to worry about E5 you have to worry
about F5
I I'm gonna actually I'm gonna make an
early call photo see if it's gonna get
blasted here
you think so
yeah
I normally don't do this but this is
just looks horrendous
it does and the reason why is the king
is still in the center I guess black can
just Castle kingside but if you go about
and do that I think white will just
continue with development right Bishop
to D2 could be played at any moment but
what is the downside of
being Pond hungry what if I just take
this part in D5 right now and say prove
to me that you have enough compensation
yeah I just assumed Magnus has something
good planned but now that you've played
this video on the board it's not so
trivial
do you think I I don't actually like Ed
for some reason but I'm trying to make
castling work like a double Pawn SEC
some sort oh so you're saying that if
Bishop takes Pawn takes take 24 black is
up two pawns but probably worse for the
wear I think white can even play Knight
G3 scoop this one and you're attacking
all sorts of pieces an F5 F6 is on the
docket as well
on dark squares long term could just
could I mean that that could just prove
to be your demise
yeah this looks really unpleasant for
black if you start grabbing all the
pawns and he has done step one he takes
D5 and Jeffrey you called it Magnus
castles and if you keep taking pawns you
are going to be in big trouble and we
see the evaluation of our Jeffrey
already above plus 1.3 so huge Advantage
for Magnus Carlson at the moment
and yeah it's 1.3 but I feel like in a
practical game it's it might be even
more because
look at your queen side for black
how do you have any time to develop you
have to react to what's going on in the
center you have to get castled
I I don't see any way out of this
oh it's not favorable at all for federal
save because he's lacking in development
he's only grabbing pawns and you could
say I'll play D4 close the center up but
white continues to press forward there
with like E5 eventually F5 and just
we're gonna see just this E5 looks very
strong Jeffrey
yeah now the tricky part though is you
might get into a sort of spot where so
many moves look attractive like to me
there's also a knight D5 with the
connected with Knight coming to G3 and
F5 like imagine having the knights there
oh my gosh you're just bullying black in
this position I mean the knights is
hopping right in Knight D5 looks
excellent and after Knight D5 Knight G3
to follow as you're pointing out I don't
really know how black is going to stop
that very easily so two great options
here for Magnuson to your point without
increment until you reach move 30 it's
only seven moves into this game 18
minutes it's a complicated position you
have to be careful about getting in time
travel
yeah this is the big difference between
regular chest and 50 random it's
possible to
immediately get into a losing position
after only seven moves obviously in a
real game I don't think Federal save
would be faced with uh such a task but
yeah I
I wanna okay maybe Knight D5 black goes
97.
which is kind of a Saving Grace
so I like your suggestion out a bit more
with E5 and 94 and try to hop into D6
although I'm not you know gonna let you
just leave your option because I still
think your idea of just giving away Pawn
to the center is perfectly fine because
if black takes the second Pawn there's a
check along the E file Bishop F3 and I
feel like White's play is quite obvious
yeah heart hearts argue with that but
yeah we'll see what Magnus wants to do I
think he'll spend a little bit time
figuring out what is the most uh precise
way here
for sure so I mean we see have magnets
on camera he's trying to figure out the
correct continuation and he is slightly
behind in the clock and it's gonna get
it's gonna get it's going to take
getting used to is what I'm trying to
say just playing in the flow of the
position knowing that you need to reach
move 30 you're not taking note right
there's no notation happening here so
all of those little individual elements
they really add up it can cause
discomfort for players
yeah shall we check in on a game that we
haven't yet seen
um we
maybe can go back first to our four
board view just to
and E5 is played by Magnus Carlson his
Advantage is up above plus two that's
bad news for federal save uh but maybe
we can get back to our four board scene
and that way we can check out all of the
action as it unfolds so
oh yeah I mean okay where do you even go
where do you even go with the queen here
I
I don't know
um Queen E I don't want to go Queen E7
because of Knight D5 I don't want to go
Queen E6 because there's going to be
some F5
Queen
C6 is Bishop F3
um there's nowhere to go you're gonna
get hit with Tempo basically regardless
I feel like you asked me a bit of a
rhetorical question here so
um yeah we um are seeing Federal save
trying to work this out right now and he
is
you know on the clock Magnus still
holding that Queen in his hands
so this is a situation for federal Sav
that I don't think he want to get into
heading into today
I think
yeah I'm trying to think what I would do
with black maybe maybe go like Queen E7
and again you give white like the choice
of three good options
we see there's a close-up I actually
love the fact that they're
that there are spectators uh because you
know it's really nice for the players to
be able to celebrate their chess with
fans and as you're talking earlier
Jeffrey Iceland is such a country that
loves chess so much of the rich history
50 years ago was that fisher spasky
match
and yeah to your point I just played in
an event without Spectators and it felt
it felt somewhat empty like not the same
amount of excitement uh in the US
Championship that is
right
and well while we uh speak of Iceland
and their love of Chess I mean you ever
regrets our son he is playing in this
event he is taking on Wesley so the
champion and we still do have Magnus and
federal Sav On Screen here but uh
greterson he is trying to make his
country proud uh he's taking on Wesley
so that's no easy competition for
anybody but I'm looking at this position
and we will pull it up here where
gretcherson with the white pieces
already looking worse for him Jeffrey
yeah he he's just got this isolated Pawn
um on e4 black on the other hand very
solid to pawn islands and I like the
queen on C5 like everything looks solid
he's gonna he has great control over the
E5 Square which
seems like an important point
yeah incredibly Pleasant position for
Wesley here
doesn't this look like a fantasy
variation of the caracon or something
like that where
um you know white gets this isolated E
Pawn hopefully some play around it but
here it just looks to me like black is
going to continue bringing pieces
towards the center and if you can
blockade and isolate a pawn you should
have a nice position
yeah it's funny that you mentioned the
fantasy I had this game against
Christopher my only win actually in this
U.S championship
um and it was it was basically this
exact same thing although seems like
Wesley has an even better version I'm
I'm honestly curious as to what happened
here because I think it was just an e45
let's see
if we can back up through it it was a
king's Gambit with a queen on F1 so
that's always helpful for that decision
and then just a slow approach by Wesley
taking advantage of what you pointed out
early on that the diagonal is good for
black
yeah this might have been overlooked
slightly although
can't you just go B3 what's the
pro okay yeah this seems reasonable too
so this all happened just some trades
and Wesley kept trading brings his night
out with Tempo it sounds like White's in
any danger over here but after oh wait
wait wait wait why to G3 why not E3 here
um Queen E3 was almost certainly better
because that prevents D5 if you play D5
I take and have discovered check uh
Queen G3 allowed D5 and I'm guessing
this is not something you see every day
in traditional chess but Queen before
check threatens to win the house and
that is what gretsarson overlooked and
by the way he might have forgotten that
he can Castle because he went C3 whereas
castling takes care of that threat on B4
oh yeah that is if he really didn't know
he could castle that's uh not a good
sign it's very important to know
castling rules I think in Fisher random
I get confused with this as well but
um hopefully yeah it seems like there
would be no reason to play see-through
over castles there no especially if
you're going to Castle now you've just
wasted some time and a lot of black to
coordinate his pieces in a way that
establishes the blockade so I believe
that gretcherson unfamiliar and maybe
that's one of the downsides of not
having to qualify your way through he is
the local envity we understand that
Iceland Reykjavik is putting up quite a
lot to host this event and we're very
appreciative but some players they were
allowed to just work you know without
even participating in a tournament get
to go right through to this event and
gretcher sends one of them so maybe he
lacks the experience that a player like
blue Baum or Hikaru has
yeah I'm really hopeful that he's put in
some training here because these sharks
that he's about to face are probably
gonna gonna try to come after him a bit
yes I mean that's what happens in these
fields right you look at the potential
opposition you're like yeah I don't take
anyone for granted but if I'm gonna have
to take a risk it's gonna be against
that player and gretsarson he is much
lower rated than the other players in
his group and right now he's on his back
foot so Wesley has a bishop stare down
to figure out I don't think you want to
take on B3 that seems like it could only
help white with a takes B3 as a response
and yeah so you know what would you do
here Jeffrey
yeah I don't really want to take on B3
like you said but I don't want to let
him take on e62 and and sort of give me
another Pawn Island so I consider
I don't really want to play this but
maybe Queen E7 just okay but he does go
ahead and take okay
I don't like that decision I mean of
course I still prefer Black's position
but I
think that after ab3 it gives white a
little bit of something that's semi-open
a file a mobile
Pawn structure on the queen side and so
I feel like that should be at least a
nice little plan for black uh for white
excuse me
yeah but certainly Wesley's still for
Choice
um was there one game I don't think
we've seen what's going on in hikaru's
game right
okay well we will head right on over to
hikaru's game I just love that the
camera is still zoomed in on federal
sale okay it just changed views as soon
as I said that but it was just locked in
on his suit and you can only see now the
sleeve of his suit but he's in big big
trouble against Magnus Carlson who's he
he knows that's a Magnus look like this
is interesting because I know I'm
winning
yeah I've unfortunately for me I've also
uh seen that look
um as you I mean the good news for photo
save though he's looking sharp that
that a suit it's sparkling unfortunately
his position maybe not so much but
but yeah it it's always nice to look
good
it is indeed and you know maybe we will
look at that position in a bit but first
let's stop with Hikaru Nakamura uh the
biggest chess streamer uh you know he is
one of the best players in the planet he
proved that over the board once again in
the candidates and he's particularly
Adept at Fisher random I think it suits
him quite nicely he's a player as we
know Jeffrey I mean you've played him so
many times during the rapid Chess
Championship and all these events he
likes playing B3 in sort of random
openings anyway this evens the opening
playing field
yeah I think Hikaru is very well suited
in the 960. he's always been the kind of
player who just wants to play chess just
wants to get a game
um not really that interested in proving
much in the opening and here I love what
he's done
um this was the E4 F5 game right if we
could just run it back and see how they
got here
yeah we'll just take it move by move
Knight G3 Queen goes back D4 let's
expand in the center and this looks
pretty normal for both sides but already
the advantage is nakara's favorite and
the semi-openf file gives him some
pressure
but you know what this reminds me of it
reminds me of a caracon advanced where
black plays F6 white takes an F6 you
take with Queen excuse me
and yeah this looks extremely attractive
I like where hikar is putting his pieces
I love E5
I think he's got a great game here yeah
it just looks fantastic for black the
only thing you have to watch out for is
is some potential hanging pawns but
after Knight C to E7 your Bishop looks a
bit silly for now but C6 and then this
bishop has a diagonal to work with so
that is quickly what happened
and hikar took on D4 that was a big
moment he didn't have to take this Pawn
but he chooses to and then sinks his
Knight into F4 and look at his pieces
Jeffrey he hasn't moved his Bishops but
you can just see that they're gonna jump
out in this position in various ways and
I'm liking the look of it for him but
white remains solid and bluebound is not
going to go down without a fight
yeah blue bomb he's an extremely solid
player um and ig2 I think he's trying to
simplify the situation which seems
correct like his time is also getting
low right is it nine minutes only for
um for 15 moves so we could see some
time pressure he'll he'll need to be
well aware of that
yes without increment until move 30 is
reaching an additional five minutes plus
that five second increment and with
knights staring down on your king side
that could be worrisome I do like that
move Knight E2 because of that let's
trade some pieces make me feel a little
safer and Jeffrey let's not forget that
not only can White Castle kingside like
black did but he could also cast a queen
side so if he feels like he can Parry
off hit cars the rats maybe play G3
Castle Queen sites are throwing pawns
forward over here maybe he can launch an
attack of his own I'm not sold on that
but it is a possibility
yeah it I'm also a bit specific uh I I
don't I don't think there's much of an
attack but there's almost no way you can
Castle kingside here for white as you
can see all the black's pieces are
pointing that direction so that's a sign
that you should probably go the other
way and on the queen side it's actually
relatively safe
yeah because there's no C5 that's very
important that typically black wants to
storm some pawns up here but the sea
Pawn is very very important defending
what would be a loose D5 Pawn so
um I think cast and queen said is next
and Hikaru on the clock he is ahead by a
few minutes here and it's a big decision
because he can just trade pieces Play
Bishop C7 that all looks good and fine
but that does give white the time needed
to Castle queenside and once White
Castle's Quita Jeffrey let me ask you
would you start even potentially
preferring White's position at some
point or do you still think black is in
charge
no white is never better here but if he
does get safe and we see a lot of Trades
then we could see like a very even
position so I'm trying to see
I'm going to also work out how to keep
the pressure on
um from Black's perspective
and I just got distracted not because
what you're saying wasn't great stuff
but I saw the prizes uh pop up on screen
right below our faces and Jeffrey 150
000 first place prize and then runner up
85 000 can you imagine if you're Wesley
or Hikaru and you you know we'll say win
first here get 150 000 fly to Toronto
right afterwards play in the global
chess.com Global Championship win
another 200 000 that'd be quite a couple
weeks for you
yeah that's that's the dream but I know
I mean I was joking a little bit with
Wesley at the end of U.S uh championship
and he was
um rightly so I think he was quite
worried like this is tons of travel he
just played U.S Championship he flew to
Iceland
definitely some jet lag he's gonna fly
back immediately after
so it's it's taxing too like the the
prizes he's gonna earn is well deserved
definitely and while Hikaru his Knight
in the center looking good here no
complaints about any of his pawns his
pieces will develop I agree with you I
do like a car's position so maybe
um you know we can check back in on the
still world champion Magnus Carlson he
is the focus of the live camera he is
taking on Vladimir photo save and
honestly every time I look at the camera
it seems to be focused on federal save
and not on Magnus because he looks very
worried and well he should be worried
here although Magnus is like you know
his face doesn't exactly seem to
indicate that he's winning and the
advantage at least according to the
engine Jeffrey is overwhelming
all right but a huge decision here by
photosafe to play F6 which looks
incredibly ugly you allow an immediate
win of an exchange if white once but I
don't think you want to trade your
knight on D6 for that Rook on f8
yeah just going through that sequence
the 957 check uh with a you know would
Fork the
the pieces so yeah that would just show
everybody what that looks like so after
F6 and feta save looking Dapper yes
indeed love our featured chat but
Jeffrey's point is Knight F7 check is a
fork and after Rook takes Bishop takes I
think you're indicating well I gained
material but it does give black time to
make moves like D6 and finally complete
the development along the back rank
right yeah I think this is a very
instructive moment that a lot of players
get over materialistic just like I try
to keep things simple and and think
about not necessarily the value pieces
like five is greater than three but I
feel my knight on D6 is worth more than
five so for a good way to sort of
it's actually not as easy as I thought
to like I'm trying to find an
alternative to that but haven't seen it
quite yet
and Magnus might play Bishop C4 I guess
the problem is you can't protect E5
enough times there are three pieces
staring right down E5 and I just was one
two three
wow that looks very creative I had I
haven't gotten the point yet but I
imagine it's something like fe5 F5
yes it must be let's just put that on
the board here F takes E5 give me that
pawn F5 says Jeffrey and Magnus will say
the same because this king is in danger
if you back this Knight up to E7 thank
you very much here comes Bishop H6 and
you're just getting checkmated your king
is wide open so you have to go forward
to block that Bishop but even so I will
take it I can even sack The Exchange but
yeah yeah I'm like I'm just considering
as well but this looks very painful and
the Knight will not be kicked out of D6
the only way it leaves D6 is if I give
you this kind of check so this is not
good at all for photo save
yeah and in this position you can start
setting up some mating configurations I
I'm envisioning Bishop C4 you bring the
Rook to H4 you can also bring
reinforcements like rookie one that's a
juicy open file for the taking
so this looks
probably a winning attack here well
that's why Federal save he trusts Magnus
did a little bit calculation himself and
was Queen to E7 and with this queen on
E7 now there's even more pressure on
this way wait on E5 yes wait wait wait
is there Bishop C4 kha Queen takes G6
almost not quite not quite oh God but I
have to show that Jeffrey's idea is
Queen G6 Pawn takes and Rook H3
Checkmate if I could play Rook H3 it's
mate so Rook F3 apparently there's a way
out and it has to be there's yeah yeah
it's Queen E6 yeah there's only one move
but
but it's uh quite sufficient
but you know what let's change our move
order instead of sacrificing the queen
just yet can we start with Rook F3 and
then play Queen yes absolutely
the only one ah no no look if Knight G5
you can play maybe either Fe or Knight
F5 Knight F5 is an idea here
just bring the Knight to F5 says Jeffrey
and even if this is captured you win the
queen yeah yeah and the queen you can't
stop the Checkmate because the bishop
covers F7 which is the only Square the
queen could go to to keep G7 safe this
is beautiful Harmony of the pieces for
Magnus Carlson and here it comes let's
see will he play the move Rook F3 he
only has seven half minutes remaining on
his clock and 14 moves to make to reach
move 30 before getting extra time but
Rook F3 is such a beautiful Checkmate
idea
I saw a Magnus he kind of just he gave
out like an exasperated Scyther but all
right he sees it yeah Rook F3 but it was
like this it was a side that's like I
don't like my position not like I'm
about to mate the gun
well Rook F3 is played he has found the
Checkmate we see him take that drink of
water you know that means he enjoys his
position and for Vladimir farosev the
big problem is if you look underneath
Jeffrey and myself The Rook on A8 the
bishop on C8 have not moved cannot move
they're stuck in place they're not
helping defend that King all to win the
other side of the board and more and
more of White's pieces are launching
this attack and we see the Arbiter in
the background I'm just making sure that
everything is uh Gone steady here and
better save he looks great he's dressed
great but his position is anything but
great
man I feel like these Arbiters are smart
like this Arbiter seems to anticipate
photos
is about to throw in the towel so he can
come in like in the U.S Championship
they were also like the anytime my game
was close to being a draw they were
lurking so they're definitely they're
monitoring I feel like they're
monitoring all the games and
anticipating when they'll end well maybe
if the Arbiters are listening to our
commenter hello how's it going no
they're not allowed to do that but we
see I mean
yeah well I I think we saw this coming
from a mile away like since that opening
perusev he chose the benoni he put his
Queen on D6 which I think I've never
seen before and yeah this is what you're
gonna get uh when you sort of play
overly
overly uh Adventures okay so Queen takes
G6 is legal now and in good after B5 so
Federal save is desperate he's like let
me develop these pieces let me distract
White's Pieces away from the attack but
Queen takes G6 you cannot take this
queen back because if Jeffrey's cool
checkmate with Rook H3 what's that
Checkmate called what's this pattern
called
that's a very good question I don't I
don't think I know
maybe somebody in the chat can inform us
Grandmasters what the name of the
Checkmate pattern is I know how to do it
I just don't know what it's called
here I think you're gonna actually play
Bishop d52 right
yes because what what what what did
Black exactly accomplish
Magna says nothing
you know as his name tag falls off the
table over there he's just like yeah
well you know this is just easy at this
point every one of White's active pieces
causing Black's King problems and
crazily this Knight can't move there's
no safe Square for this Knight there's
not a single piece that can protect the
Knight there's no Queen Y8 or queen F7
obviously the white pieces cover those
squares so Queen takes G6 is an
Unstoppable threat that's wild
truly is yeah no squares like you said
and the only move I see is night before
but I think you just pick up the Rook on
A8 and
you shouldn't be enough conversation no
yes I stopped you from checkmating me
and it's like well you're down a rook so
that's not exactly such a good thing
after all now this is I think a
completely lost position for federal
save we may see him play a couple moves
he takes on E5 with the pawn allowing
Queen takes G6 so what is his idea after
Queen takes G6 Magnus plays that yeah
Rook of six Knight but Knight F7
that is also Queen E8 should be
sufficient if you want yeah if you want
trading off Queens you're going to be up
with minor piece
but wait I go Knight F7 you have to take
on F7 right so
oh okay I see his idea he wants to get
E4 there at the end
wait Knight F7 you're saying wait I can
take back with the bishop still I can
really taunt you
oh you're a bully I thought you were a
nice guy but Jeffrey's point is you
still can't take this queen because it's
Checkmate along the H file so oh
goodness Jeffrey that's a that's nasty
yeah I think we'll probably see that on
the board shortly
and yeah just to show like King G8 I
have many good discoveries but Knight G5
by far the best one which would finish
you're just
mean mean man but Magnus says let's
trade Queens let's get a piece to the
other side of the board Queen E8 forcing
the Queens off the board and up a piece
it is sufficient
yeah I think this one's over let's see
what else is going on should we hold can
we pull up the four board screen so we
can choose which one
uh well we see the players it looks like
maybe we'll just get oh no I thought
fair to say I was going to resign
but he he has not resigned yet
yeah I'm enjoying this view though I'd
like to see the board from this angle
here and it is a clean extra piece for
Magnus Carlson I think if I save as what
maybe
one Pawn for now but with the C5 Pawn
dropping okay he pushes it just to avoid
it from falling but this is bad news for
Federal Saving by the way noribbeck
abusotave has defeated janapamshi in the
first game of their match we'll stay on
this scene as Magnus Carlson looks to
secure this point maybe we'll catch that
on camera but in order did defeat Beyond
the Palm machine
wow that is a big result
um
yeah it was I believe it was that
Stonewall game that ex I'm interested to
see but we will stay on this for now
I think
I mean I the Knights of Beth probably
gonna reappear on D6 so I don't expect
many more moves
oh look at FedEx I mean he doesn't want
to look at the board anymore uh he is
down substantial material so uh yeah
it's just a situation that he wants no
part of he's just playing them out just
to get a few more moves in but you can
see by the body language he's dejected
but he will get white in game two of
this match he will have a chance to
rebound
yeah he doesn't look at him he doesn't
want to move he's moving because he
feels like he should but not because he
wants to
I know that feeling
yeah it's like I sh I want to stop the
clock but maybe I should force Magnus to
calculate a couple more turns and in
reality there's nothing much to
calculate there it is a full extra piece
for Magnus Carlson a devastating
checkmating attack resulted in some
material one and so this one looks to be
pretty much over
yeah look at look at fenison he's he's
not looking at the board at all
wow what a start
yeah
fantastic game from Magnus Carlson he
looked like he was in control the whole
way through and Fredo Sav he really
didn't have a chance in this individual
game so they'll reset the board Magnus
gets the win why don't we head on over
to the game between Hikaru Nakamura and
Matthias bluebum because that one is
really up for grabs at this point
Jeffrey we see that white has castled
Queen side tucked the king over on B1
and all of a sudden I spy a little bit
of an attack for white Shore black
compare those threats but Jeffrey now
we're getting into a bit of a blitz
scramble seven more moves to get to move
30. I feel like blue bumps should be
happier about his chances
oh yeah this one is really heating up so
as we were talking about white did
Castle Queen side and
as
as of this moment I don't see a clear
attacking plan for either side like you
can't really go with your usual Pawn
storm
but black has to prove something because
if I'm white I feel like maybe I can
double on the E file maybe I can play uh
actually what what other plans do I have
I was gonna say Bishop too but
it's it's sharp though I think time will
be the biggest Factor
and this H2 Pawn just like in some of
the other games it's it's hanging uh
right now black should not take that
pawn you get checkmated but if black
throws in G6 then suddenly that pawn is
capturable so you just need to look out
for things like this G6 blocks the
diagonal but it also threatens Queen
takes H2 and Rook d8 by Hikaru quick
move in response by Blue bomb Bishop F2
the queen drops back to H6 so the
players they're scrambling to get to
move 30 Jeffrey
and to this point that I made earlier
does bluebum know what move number it is
that is a fantastic question
and how would he know that's what I
actually I feel like we have no idea you
can only get confirmation right like you
just look at the clock and hope to see
uh it go up at some point
I mean there must be somebody you know
keeping track of this stuff because
otherwise what are you supposed to rely
on just keeping count every single turn
that's not really no way
I imagine the game yeah I imagine there
is an Arbiter right nearby that you can
ask at any moment for the move number uh
so we see Rook E2 played Jeffrey your
idea doubling on the e-file still cannot
capture on H2 that allows Rook H1 and
the H7 Pawn will fall G6 is always
possible shutting down one diagonal but
creating problems on a second so not an
easy decision for Hikaru who is now
dropping to about four minutes
yeah G6 is it's sort of controversial
but my feeling is that it should be
correct because you're playing it's
actually kind of a math problem you're
playing against the queen on D3 Bishop
on C2 Knight on G3 but you're letting
maybe the bishop on F2 get more power
when it gets to D4 but shutting out
three pieces to to let one activate is
is okay
I will say the other downside of G6 is
H4 H5 I don't know if I can get away
with H4 right away because maybe you
could just take it but I would love to
throw my phone up to H5
yeah age for maybe you you even start
with move like Rook H1 so that there's
even more Firepower behind it oh wow I
mean it's a slow move but it does make
sense and I was only thinking in terms
of Chess principles when I see a Pawn on
G6 a theme Kettle structure I know a
great way to attack that is by throwing
my H Pawn forward so Rook H1 that would
be such a nasty move instead he goes to
the open file which makes sense and will
Hikaru can Hikaru take this Pawn on H2
can you get away with it I think it's
suicide because you're going to see Rook
H1
and then you have to take on G2 and I
feel like I should have some way to make
maybe it maybe I don't actually have
some way to make it work I was going to
say like some Brook H7 or some Bishop D4
Queen G6 ideas
it looks dangerous I don't know if you
could play this move with three minutes
in your clock and a car he's calculating
he looks like he's really invested in
this position because Queen takes H2 may
objectively be a good move maybe the
engine's approve of it and ikaru he
could find these types of decisions but
it's so risky as this Rook can slide
over and start attacking this black king
yeah I mean it's crazy I'm trying to
calculate it right now maybe since he's
thinking let's let's go ahead and uh
show it so Queen H2 Rook H1 Queen G2
Rook H7
um
Queen G6 Rook G7 Queen G7 we get some
sort of end game Bishop D4
how do you evaluate this
apparently the engine about it says
minus three oh there's a king moving
Rook G8 ah okay at the end of the line
but that's a very deep line and you have
to calculate it all the way through
together he played it he played it wow
cold I used to play Queen takes H2 yeah
no he says prove your attack because if
you don't have an attack I stole your
pawn my queen will backtrack and that's
good news for me with the black pieces
in game one and by the way bluebound
under two minutes it's that was the 26th
move by both players
four moves to make with a minute 45 that
is not a lot of time in this kind of
crazy position
and but here's the thing he might not
know there is a chance that he might not
know like this could be move 20 and he
he would have 10 moves to go
um um there's one there's another
important line here so if Rook H1 Queen
G2 Bishop D4
black needs to take on G3 to stop
a queen takes G6 from appearing it's
actually a nasty idea that it will show
very quickly the point everybody is if
it's a queen can't go anywhere but I'll
make a turn no you're gonna take on F3
you can take on F3 sure but I guess the
point is that this is the Checkmate that
Jeffrey is trying to throw on the board
is a nasty Bishop in Rook configuration
so the Knight on G3 would be captured in
that sequence which should also protect
the G6 square and now we see time is of
the essence for bluebound he I don't
think this was a sacrifice so much as it
was um hopeful chess you know he gives
away the pawn and now he's backtracking
which is a bad sign
yeah and I guess if hikar takes another
Pawn on G2 he wants Bishop B6
oh
opening up this and this bishop is loose
over here
yeah so probably a car should play a
conservatively here maybe like Queen F4
or queen somewhere else oh queen of four
Bishop G3 oh that would not be good so
Queen back to H6 Maybe
yeah he looks like he moved his Queen
back we'll see where it lands Queen H6
Knight to E3 so this went Knight went
from G3 to F1 to E3 and now if the
knights get traded on E3 white has given
up a pawn but open files are good for an
attack
yeah I think blue bomb he's reacted as
well as he could have
um
now for her car do you start trading
pieces here like takes in Bishop F4 and
maybe bishop F5 next
you would love to get that Bishop F5 for
sure
in a car he does have a little bit more
time so he's using it wisely reminder to
everybody that it moved 30 it is
currently now the 29th move for uh so
move 29 has just been played so it's the
30th move after this move to get five
more minutes and a five second increment
so then it becomes a blitz battle rather
than a bullet scramble and queen f8 what
would you do here Jeffrey you have your
Rooks on the E file you could slide a
rook to H1 at some point how are you
continuing this game for what I'm I'm
not even focusing on the position I'm
looking at the clock is it 20 seconds
for two moves if I'm not mistake no this
is the 30th move so he cha with Bishop
is it he's reach move 30 yes oh he's got
it okay okay okay so he should see five
minutes right
yeah he had enough time to drink water
so he finally will feel like uh a bit of
comfort and at the rookie ate by the way
I just saw the eval bar pop up in
White's favor so blue bomb is down a
pawn but all of a sudden the engine is
starting to like his position I think
it's because that Rook takes E8 then C4
Dynamite move opening up diagonals
against this king oh that's so easy to
miss I was not even looking at in that
direction
wow that would be a huge find if he
could
because I was looking at like some ideas
with takes and made Bishop H6 or queen
E3 and Bishop H6 but C4 did not catch my
eye
well I'm just trying to open this
position up because if this bishop at
long last can get on a good diagonal
it's a problem for black here so with
just a simple trade and C4 let's get
pieces off the board if you take and I
take back you already see it's I didn't
expect to be plus whatever this is plus
four but the problem is that diagonals
are open and the black King's in trouble
and the E file and everything working
together well yeah he has taken on EA
and now is thinking here this is a huge
moment if you find C4 I think he flips
the script completely
what a game this has been really one
where Hikaru has been in charge since
the very early stages and if not for C4
I do like Bishop H6 as an alternative
because you force Queen takes H6 Rook
takes E8 and the very least Jeffrey
opposite colored Bishops have tons of
drawers Tendencies especially with
limited material remaining
yeah but this is another great example
of sort of how to improve your worst
place piece most of the time you would
maneuver it to a good square but this
time you're basically just opening up
the position so that it can Excel and I
think he's played it wow what a fine oh
my goodness Matthias bluebound he is
demonstrating that he is here to fight
he clawed back you know with no time on
his clock now he gets five second income
with every move C4 is played and I would
love to see hikara's face yeah I was
about to say the same thing oh my gosh
I expect some yeah I expect some head
shakes and five
four
three two uh okay he's not he's not in
panic mode yet but if I were sitting on
his position I would really be starting
to get nervous here and that looks like
Photo chess Maria emilianova in the
background with that big lens there and
that's Matthias bluebellum on camera he
is as determined as ever and this is
what I love about qualifiers as he looks
up at a card Nakamura it gives players
like bluebound a very talented player
he's uh in his early 20s he's 2650 rated
in classical chess he's very strong his
own right but you don't get invitations
to the top tournaments unless you're
2700 plus here bluebound is showing that
once you're in the field he can fight
with the best of them and right now
Hikaru has a difficult choice
and uh just to confirm it's five second
increment now right that is absolutely
correct yes
so both players will rely on that Hikaru
he looked like he was going to move his
light Square Bishop I want to say if or
maybe it was dark scripture I'm not sure
but it looked like he was going to grab
a piece close to his side of the board
and then he withdrew his hand and he's
like I'm not so sure about that decision
so uh Jeffrey not an easy Choice here
for ikaro yeah I was looking at Bishop
D7 cd5 Bishop F5
this is what I'm calculating right now
and you move the queen and then I oh
let's say queen C3
all right let's bring up the board here
so we can just play through a couple of
moves and show everybody what Jeffrey
Zhang is thinking about because Bishop
D7 you're saying C takes D5 yes keep
going Bishop F5 Queen C3 and here's the
issue for black this e-file
is all whites so you're not able to
contest it and just to show a line let's
say like Bishop C2 Queen C2 cd5 you
would get the pawn back now I think
there's Queen C6 which could be
potentially very dangerous
uh-oh uh that's
hugely dangerous I don't even know how
black it's supposed to deal with that so
that's a problem the king G7 only move
but if that's your only move repeat no
but rookie oh oh you have Queen C5
because I was gonna say like rookie
eight Queen D6 Queen A8 would be
unstoppable mate that's I'm just going
for it for these checkmates I mean it is
stoppable apparently but only uh barely
you're just getting away with this but
that's not what you want to face in a
situation and now Hikaru Nakamura is
actually down on the clock Jeffrey he is
below three minutes and now 35 seconds
and he made the move Rook D7 and the
evaluation bar it's doing some uh
weightlifting it's going up and down
here
yeah I'm
trying to understand okay so maybe white
has something good here but I don't see
it right off
I don't see it either
what is the plan here I guess there's
always Bishop B3 in certain positions
trying to go after this King but the
king is not that weak and the bishop
will take back on D5
yeah I
like Queen C3 feels natural but
I don't see a follow-up to like fish
five there
right the bishop just is at home on that
square and then there's no Bishop B3
because Queen gets out to F5 with check
and your Bishop is loose over here to be
very careful not to blunder something
for either side
yeah this is this is very tricky man
Hikaru he does everything well to be
honestly this was a great sort of
defensive regrouping that he found here
with Rook D7 Bishop F7
what I mean what a decision just to
maneuver the piece in this way and what
is the plan for bluebound there has to
be something here I refuse to believe
that it's you know there are no obvious
ideas we could see the evaluation bar
off the side we don't have the move
telling us what they are and bluebound
he must also feel like he should have
something against his black king so
is it like an F4 F5 do you have time for
that probably not because Bishop D5
threatens Bishop A2
yeah F4 and queen H3 I get like F4
bishd5 Queen H3 oh it looks like but
that looks like computer chess I'm fine
yeah he gets
sort of he doubles on the e-file and
also Bishop H6 might be in the cards
oh that's very scary once a bishop lands
here there could be some back Rank
checkmates and some checkmates in G7 as
well so Hikaru can take on D5 in uh any
of three ways
not the easiest decision but I think
Bishop takes D5 is what he'll choose
and then after Bishop page six something
like Queen F7
I press Rook takes D5 okay
Hikaru keeping the queen on E3 tied so
it's very important that I think he
threatens Rook E5
and oh if he could relieve that e-file
pressure then the pawn is going to start
to mean something
so I was thinking Bishop B3 was like the
obvious move but you're right Rook E5
allows the trade of light score Bishops
but there are no more pieces for white
to attack with so I do not want a lot of
rookie five which made me Bishop H's no
I like this better yeah because
we I mean you highlighted this long time
ago back when black first played G6 but
when you access this diagonal
there could really be some issues
okay so Bishop F6 played you would love
to play Bishop takes A2 check you know
some kind of Discovery and get this
bishop here and that wouldn't even work
uh but the point is this bishop on F6 is
safe and sound for now and the bishop
can always slide back to C3 Jeffrey
that's a long-term issue for black to
deal with
yeah absolutely in a practical game it
might be easier for white if if he's
able to keep the bishop uh on that
diagonal G3
kicking this Rook away I guess Rook E2
let me create some background problems
then white will have to deal with
actually that already does have an issue
here is Queen D6 I think the game's over
so if the Rook slides up to E2 Queen D6
turns Rook D1 with a mate on the back
rank oh that's actually really cool so
maybe
can I go like wreckage one instead
I mean D6 anyway
but at least you're not getting the
bishop can go back to C3 there's no
check me back there whereas just to show
everybody quickly rookie two queen D6
your Bishop's under attack and if you
protect your Bishop Rook D1 is winning
because after Queen C1 I could take your
rook and be up a bishop or I could take
your Pawn distracting you uh your king
from your queen so I'm up a queen for a
rook either way black is up too much
material for
white to play on yeah
only 45 seconds for bluebonn Brook H1 is
played
okay and he finds the best move
and Hikaru should try to play a bit on
bluebound's clock and what I mean by
that is not just to play bullet chess
because that's how you blunder away
positions that are not just defensive
maybe even slightly better for black
with this extra Pawn but you should play
relatively quickly and icaro knows
better than anybody how to play in
someone else's time trouble
yep Queen D6 and Bishop C3 does he want
okay Queen H6 is a big threat though
let's he's got to be careful monster
threat
absolutely monstrous threat
that's why Bishop F4
no Queen H6 for you so probably Queen
F2 and then try to get to H4
makes sense hey Carl might want to get
rid of that Bishop on C3 somehow like
either Bishop D5 or Bishop D2
yeah that makes a lot of sense and blue
bound plus Queen E4
so he wants queen H4 as soon as the
bishop moves
acquaintances H5
shutting it down yeah and it's
hard to actually make a threat here for
white
and Blue Mountain does not have a lot of
time so the threats seem to be
completely parried a car playing Amazing
defense
yeah I wanted some Bishop B3 but it
doesn't really accomplish much
and we see blue bomb's face here
zoomed in on him let's bring the uh
board into Focus he makes his move
Bishop to B3 he's trying to go for some
tactics in front of the black king a car
is tricky yes flop cake but he's not
just tricky he's strong he's not playing
for tricks he's playing the best moves
and right now it seems that there is
some kind of huge move for black minus
two Jeffrey
uh yeah I'm considering Bishop takes C3
because I don't think you can take on D5
I mean maybe you can though
yeah he's gone for it wow
and queen D5 bc3 Queen takes A2 all this
is forced
and black will have two pawns and an
attack
for the exchange so bishop and two pawns
for I think he's gonna take a third Pawn
on G2
have you been hanging out with Yasser
yes I have I have as a matter of fact
that you you're analyzing like someone
who has been hanging out with Yasser
Sarah one Pawn grabbing but why not get
three Pawns in a bishop for a rook that
looks like not just sufficient
compensation but ample compensation by
black is much better
yeah because White's King is simply too
open and I don't think you can
coordinate the queen and Rook fast
enough but he's gone for Queen E3
instead so he doesn't take any of the
pawns yet though
well the problem is King B2 there's
Queen D2 check and then uh Bishop takes
A2 check will lead to Checkmate I think
it actually is a force Checkmate so
we'll see he plays King to C1 quickly
show you the oh actually I don't have
time to show you the King's Running Away
we'll show you after the game perhaps
that Checkmate sequence here goes the
queen stealing more pawns and so Jeffrey
it's time for this King to just keep
running
yeah and uh Blue Book wait is he down to
five can we zoom in is it possible to
zoom in on the on the live board
well I think he must have
no the unfortunately the lighting is
such that someone's sleeping right
behind a car how could you sleep during
this game
wake like that fan up over there so
Queen D2 played by hikar we just saw
that
yeah but this is three pawns to the good
I see three pawns on the queen side
so any end game is just going to be
completely over
so look at these players concentrating
you see bluebound he's now fiddling with
a piece very common chess player action
especially during Temple C5 pushing the
pawn is Hikaru trying to storm those up
the board
okay
okay now the moves are coming in very
quickly
yeah Queen E7 played I think hey Carl
just wants to make sure not to allow any
counter play here
wow he just you know has some voice and
by the way bluebonn made that move with
one second remaining on his clock we saw
six seconds we're on his timer after
that move so you gained five seconds per
move and the person's still asleep
behind the car a C4 is pushed those
pawns are wide awake sprinting the other
side and Blue Mountain takes on A7 Brave
choice
might as well snap one off when you can
and there's a past Pawn for Hikaru but a
bunch of checks Happening Here Queen C7
getting behind the passport and pinning
this bishop I think bluebound has enough
yeah he's a compensation and I think
he's on the verge of holding this that
that was huge the queen on C7
is excellently placed
in C3 eyeing F7 and also controlling
this diagonal to not allow uh checks for
black
and bluebound he only has a couple
seconds
what's he doing he's got yeah he's got a
okay Rook hitch four wait he blundered
no oh sorry sorry Queen is 95 I'm sorry
Windows 95 now okay we're gonna the
board is uh Frozen to make you move so
quickly the queen is on E5 and so the
Rook comes with the H4 because wait but
how could The Rook go to H4 in any case
yeah what's his idea on C2
what's his idea yeah what
all right we okay it's happening so fast
but Queen D1 played yeah we will try to
get the moves on our board they're
moving too quickly for the Relay it
seems
um
I don't even know what's happening here
I'm just trying to I I'm sorry everybody
um we're just doing our best here as you
know we the moves are not coming in and
the players are moving fast so if we get
a shot of the live board that would be
excellent if we can otherwise uh oh here
they come I don't even know what's going
on here but
yeah so he's giving checks so King H7 oh
my goodness
okay they're repeating a bit hikar goes
kh7
and now
what's the move here Rook F4 played with
one second Queen D7 instantly
and now Queen C3 so
I think blue ball might
pick up the C Pawn here
and a car goes to pin that Rook it looks
like we see their face Bishop B3 played
can't take because black will promote
what a crazy position this is as we have
the light position on the board now I'll
actually just try to make the moves as
well looks like Rook E4 was the choice
huge move trying to go rookie one I I'll
keep up with the players
Queen C5 offering a queen trade if you
trade Queens the world comes back to E1
I don't know if white is losing this he
takes the bishop
whoa no what is that wait no the checks
are are covered here the checks are
covered f8 is covered and you see on
blue bomb's face he recognizes that he
has just made a big mistake he brings
his queen and the King comes up to H6
there's no Queen F4 check as the second
Queen there's no fa check there is
resignation and Hikaru Nakamura he takes
a victory in game one and yeah let's
quickly jump to the Wesley game I think
it's still ongoing as well very
interesting end game
okay I will pull that up here quickly as
we see the players reset the board and
oh my gosh when an end game here pawns
are promoting bluebound disappointed he
had chances there but a car Nakamura
takes game one and Wesley so with the
black pieces he is now up a pawn both
sides just promoted and we're focused on
our world rapid champion from 2019 he is
up upon here he's gonna try to win this
game and more time on the clock for
these two
yeah Hickory time scribble classic I
mean he I think he's the best at those
but in this position I it shouldn't be a
Perpetual right yeah I think Wesley's
gonna bring his King over
and then Shield it with the queen
yeah I mean the king for white on being
on G8 is probably a pretty good thing
you want your king away from the action
you don't want to be caught in a
deflection check or some of the forces
the Queen's off the board so it's going
to be difficult for gretarsen here here
even they where this queen belongs
yeah I mean normally in these sort of
Blitz Games were like both sides have
only minutes all Queen endiums are
winning
you heard it from Jeffrey Zhang in Blitz
or especially bullet chess all Queen end
games upon are winning and you just you
know you don't want to make them like
Queen G2 and get somehow this if there's
a check against this King uh like here
Queen C4 already threads to win a second
Pawn Oh I thought it was stopping on C3
it was the B3
yeah
um so okay he's keeping it he's holding
it together for the moment mm-hmm
I I think I would
I don't know what to do here McQueen C2
short
would have Queen to H7 there's Queen C7
yes
just need to avoid the cross checks
because he's just hanging out looks like
on these squares at some point Wesley
needs to bring his team back up the
board though I believe
and if the times are accurate under 10
seconds left for gretcherson not an easy
choice right now does he bring this
queen up to D5 with check I think that's
the Temptation in time trouble you
always want to give checks
absolutely correct
but Wesley not showing any progress so
far I think I don't know what is like
the Practical thing to do maybe you just
move a bunch of
I mean make a bunch of random moves just
to get up to 30 seconds and then figure
out how you're going to go forward I'm
thinking B5 at some point even if it's a
pawn sacrifice it'll gives you it
Springs free a past Pawn so King C7
Queen C3 check plate you can go Queen C6
and then Queen E5 so there's so many
checks I'm trying to see when was the
promotion what move number was that that
was move
uh 72. and we're on move 83 so the 50
move rule will have to have an eye kept
on it
yeah so gretcher said he's doing a good
job so far I I still don't see what
Wesley's trying here
yeah
and you see the king just shuffling
there's one check on F5
but now I mean it's already like for
example you could easily make a move
like Queen D4 and get cross check so you
have to be super cautious
and I'm curious when there might be a
three-time repetition because the king
seems to be going on uh the same squares
and the queen is going back and forth
between F4 King B7 there's Queen F7
check
Queen C4 maybe King B8 is not a single
check after that move
yeah possible and then there's a threat
of queen d8 queen C7 oh yeah gotta watch
out for that he sets it up in this way
but okay
maybe three yeah Queen B3 is always a
safe Square that's like a Haven yeah
it's like King B8 just to try to induce
Queen to C4 so you get that check
okay no don't go with the C file there's
a check
I think Queen F3 is still fine and he's
back to B3 his home I feel like B5 might
be played at some point but that opens
up even more checks against this King
yeah I mean you might have to do it the
thing is a pod is the is very is quite
drawish so that'll be more of a last
resort I think
okay Queen to B4 this queen has to
escape don't go to D5 you belong to the
A4 Pawn so you probably go back to D1
keep this Pawn in your sights
but he's thinking
he's gonna see two queen F4
now why can't bring his King back this
is actually tricky I think you do though
right here it comes the king is running
back
and that makes B5 just completely
unattractive so B5 the point was a
spring for a past Pawn but that's your
only Pawn remaining then you're never
gonna win any uh King and Pawn in the
game
yeah he's checked on G4 and I think he
wants King B7
oh no he goes Queen D7 first
cutting off the king
Queen D5 I think it's a draw right isn't
this king of Pawn and game just a draw
he he's trusting it he played it and
that is good it is yeah yeah yeah yeah
fantastic decision because there's no
more struggle after this move if you
know it's a draw the game is just done
and queen C6 played clever Try by Wesley
but doesn't matter King C6 there's King
back to D4 and they drew the game
it is over and what a hold from
greterson against the Fisher random
world champion you see the uh the crowd
applauding him and what a save in game
one
yeah nerves of Steel there I believe he
was completely lost earlier in the game
we can check it on the other side but
yeah that is uh I feel like as you know
as the biggest Underdog in this field
starting out with a draw is is really
important for him oh that's
huge first chances here because
gretcherson and we see the featured
chats rolling in keep them coming
everybody we love to hear your thoughts
and your support for the players
gretzerson he is the local wild card he
is much lower rated than everybody else
in the field and yet he proved sturdy in
game one he held that draw against
Wesley so and that means that we have
one tied match graterson so the other
three matches have leaders Magnus
Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and nordybeck
abdusitarov
yeah I mean I am I can't wait to dive
into
to the other games but I guess do we
head to break first
yeah we are about to head to break but
before we do we just want to give a
shout out to the sponsor the presenter
of this coverage it is brave and brave
means private browsing and so much more
by default Brave blocks ads and trackers
on every page and video you visit even
on YouTube no ads means up to three
times faster page loads faster streaming
and faster playback it means 35 longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth for Android iOS
and desktop
choose Brave so don't go anywhere we'll
be back with more coverage of the fide
rapid World Championship brought to you
by break
[Music]
run for my life
okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
coffee
oh shoot
thank you
which one is that is that our new one
I can't get this one man
oh shoot
what's wrong with you man
this is hard
hey
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one
got it oh shoot
come on
foreign
[Music]
world championship this coverage is
brought to you by chess.com and
presented by Brave I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess Jeffrey Jean glas alongside
me Jeffrey we had an exciting first
round of action here I guess we should
say first game because in these rounds
it's a two-game mini match
correct yeah that was just game one and
for all the players who lost game one
they must level the score here to sort
of salvage anything in this match
um as you mentioned that was an
absolutely wild round that uh blue bomb
hit Coral game I just want to go go back
and and dive in I would like it was I
couldn't process all of that Madness
no there are so many things happening
down the stretch of uh the opening games
there of course my car Nakamura thrilled
to get the victory in that one bluebound
was fighting tooth and nail almost
surviving and you see the live audience
there standing up they're gonna be
seated when the games begin but there is
a sizable crowd there in Reykjavik in
the venue so it's good to see many chess
fans watching their favorite players and
gretzerson the Local Hero he is making
them proud
really superb Java by redterson I think
he was on the ropes for the majority of
the game definitely losing at some point
but he held his own he kept his cool
um in time pressure he defended a very
unpleasant Queen opponent game well
deserved uh Half Point against the
defending champ
yes so Wesley so the only you know high
rated player to not win the game and
they'll be okay with that he had the
black pieces but Magnus Carlson he put
on a dominant display that was truly
Stellar chess from him against Vladimir
fedrosev that was the most one-sided
game of the first round that we saw but
I actually caught the game between Abdul
sitarov and Jana palmchi during the
break and Jeffrey the final position for
that one brutal
yeah can we open that up
because I think the fact that we haven't
mentioned this masterpiece by notabeck
is maybe a little bit rude to this
amazing young
player uh use black player
yeah so we can uh check out
um the game uh for sure so we can bring
up the the
game between noribbeck Abdul sitarov and
Jan Napoli because the final position I
mean seriously you don't see things like
this very often 22 moves into a game so
when we can we'll bring that in front of
you but we would love to show you the
action from the first set of games
yeah so one thing now I'm thinking about
is do you think you'd rather start out
with white or black in this mini match
um I think I'd rather start with black
just to get a feel of the position uh
but maybe I'm also saying that because
the higher rate of players all had black
in game one and did quite well but let's
uh show the game now that you have been
calling for the game between Abdul
sitarov and Jan napomishi because
Jeffrey this is the final position this
king is has just been hunted left and
right a rook is hanging if this Knight
moves there's Rook D1 winning the queen
this is gross
yeah I mean let's just see what exactly
went wrong for nepo I think when we left
it it was very early on in the opening
we saw a stone wall
I think it was after the move Bishop C2
right yes keep going Knight H4 a bit
weird and I think notabeck went for this
plan
F34
yeah because black is sort of
dilly-dallying on the king side over
here now castling this way is not going
to be so favorable now that your pawns
are so forward and simple capture and E4
this is how easy made it seem every
single move had a purpose for him look
at Black's pieces on the other hand that
is not what you want to see
I mean but but what is network doing
exactly like this seems so disrespectful
how he's playing he played Knight H4 and
then G5 with his King in the middle like
he was just asking for it well look at
this a piece of my voice take me on G3
says Nori back this happens rookie one
check where's your king going if you put
Bishop E7 there's this move Pawn to D6
thank you very much pinning and winning
down the e-file and so he goes King D7
but Jeffrey this is as bad as it looks
just take on G3 take on C6 and then
opening the position some Pawn to D5 it
says only plus 1.5 about but practically
speaking this is just horrible for black
like someone needs to tell nepo this is
this is Fisher random World Championship
like don't play Knight H4 G5 and then
play a bong Cloud this is not acceptable
oof this Knight is hanging discourage
Knight E4 bringing more pieces into the
attack what a game from nordi back here
he just takes on D6 because H7 would
check and then this is loose
and it was that simple now this game was
as one-sided as the final position
indicates Beyond the Palm she never had
a chance
he never did but
I think he'll be seeking Redemption we
know that if anybody can bounce back it
is the man that has won two candidates
in a row he gets white hopefully he
analyzes the position well with his
second and comes up with with a nice
opening plan
yeah the good thing in a sense about
losing a game like this is the pieces
are in an odd starting position and
you're like well it's clearly very
difficult to play for black so let me
get the white pieces and let me even up
this match but the bad news is at best
you tie so we see blue bum and a car
Nakamura getting ready for game two of
their match that one promises to be
exciting but a car with the white pieces
he can just try to make a draw if it's
available to him because one and half
points will see his way through
but how do you think it's easier to make
a draw on demand in 960 or chess
I think it is easier to make a draw in
standard chess classical chess but I
think it's also harder for black to play
for win from like that mentality like if
you play for a win and fish are random
you're probably just getting yourself in
so much trouble
um so I think actually it's it's easier
just like normal moves in Fisher random
so I I ultimately easier to play for a
win in a must-win situation where the
black piece is in fish are random
all right gotcha and Magnus
he will need a drug with black against
photo save
um hopefully I I assume nobody will be
repeating Federal saves C5 benoni and we
need six
that did not look very good we said it
as soon as we saw the queen on D6 and
move three of that game so yeah I don't
think that Magnus is going to play that
way
and yeah seems like we do we have a
second before I want to go to hikaru's
game as well just to see the Finish
um because it happens so fast
okay I think we do have a moment here so
it actually was even by evaluation Rook
H4 was part of
the reason he lost and apparently I just
turned on the moves here King H2 was
even better for white because the Rook
now covers the promotion Square over
here and you can even bring your Rook
over to A1 and threaten checkmates wow
so well that was a mistake but you know
that was neither here nor there at this
point C2 probably overlooked the queen
didn't have to go and mistakes happen in
scramble we do have game two starting
here we see phariseev and Magnus on
screen ferise starts with F4 for all of
our Birds opening fans you can uh kind
of be happy to see that but it is Fisher
random so not quite the same
yeah I think that's a move we did not
see we saw E4 and D4 but not F4 so nice
Innovation there uh by photo save during
the break and D5 by Magnus
and this I feel like standard for black
open up your light score Bishop you
could play C6 as we've been talking
about so I I really feel like it's
difficult to find ways to just play for
a win this early From ferocera's
perspective like what is your second
move Jeffrey in this position you played
E3
does he want some reverse stone wall
here I I wouldn't exactly recommend it
maybe he's hoping that
Magnus somehow forgets about Queen B5
which is much more powerful when there's
a queen on f8 and not on d8 so
um okay I understand it now I think he
wants Bishop F3 and C4
so if I play C6 your whole Bishop F3 C4
thing doesn't even look that threatening
right no it doesn't look scary at all
but at least we have sort of an
imbalance right it's kind of interesting
uh the structure we get
something that we didn't speak about in
game one but now I'm thinking about is
C6 takes away the Square from the Knight
but Knight A6 is much more viable in
this type of position Knight A3 the same
because there's no Bishop ready to
capture on uh the a file so actually C6
with Knight A6 in the future it does
make sense yeah that's an excellent
point so essentially there's no Bishop
cutting off the Knight squares and
yeah I think
for Magnus it looks solid like he's got
a lot of ways to develop I think he can
even try to play in the center if he
wants to get
a bit like sort of frisky with 96 and E5
or even some F6 Knight F7 and E5 is
potentially
uh also an idea so yeah he's taking his
time here we'll see what he wants to do
sure so
um maybe we can just keep an eye on all
four games we'll go from game to game
see what's up let's go to the game
between Abdus atarov and napomishi we
really unfortunately did not get to
spend much time live during that game so
let's give them our attention for now we
will come back to Magnus Carlson and
Vladimir feta Sam don't you worry but
for the moment we will pull up Beyond
the Palm machine against Norman Abdul
sitarov and Jeffrey as we will get the
game
in front of everybody it's move six but
it looks like it's moved like
15 or something and that's what Mr
random does to my mind yeah yeah I
totally get you um this stemmed from a
French I believe so it was E4 by Nepal
and E6 and then they both fiance on the
queen side which you don't normally see
in a French
so I thought there would just be copycat
chess because Bishop F6 does a busitar
of the queen has access in this diagonal
now and it's frustrating when you need a
win and your opponent is just kind of
copying you because where's the first
unique move going to come from well but
he's not copying him right he played
Bishop F6 which I like because he's
fighting against D2 D4
so I think
I actually don't see any advantage here
for nepo right because if black gets
let's say Knight G6 and D5 well what is
there even to play for
well I'm Bishop A6 and D5 was played and
after e take D5 he takes if I'm with you
I mean it's just a symmetrical Pawn
structure trading off this bishop does
not make this King particularly weak so
I think that Abu sitarov he's playing
some excellent Fisher random chess he is
the world rapid Champion so he has had
success in these shorter time controls
and as the game continues here we see
just simple development from both sides
the problem for White Knight H5 is
always met by Bishop D4 and you don't
have a second Knight to kick the bishop
out
yeah as you said Notre back well-known
name
um at this point
sir just a force to be reckoned with and
here like I already prefer black this is
an exchanged French
but I think I have the better Bishop on
F6 like I assume the light Bishops are
going to be traded
there's absolutely nothing here for Napa
no I mean this is not how you'd like to
see your position 10 Moves In in a must
win game and nobody back's moves are
actually pretty natural at this point uh
King B1 is yawn's choice and black can
play King B8 if you just want to do
nothing you can also bring your queen
out from f8 uh you can maybe bring your
knight forward to F4 I don't see why not
it can't even be kicked out of that
square so Jeffrey
I don't really believe in Jan's chances
right now no I like just Queen D6 here
connecting the Rooks followed by Rook G8
but Queen D6 doesn't have the drawback
of allowing Knight H5
uh oh so you mean I don't have Bishop D4
anymore exactly okay
so like let's what if I go to B5 though
I'll take on B7 first maybe I don't know
if this matters or my points
five
and I thought I could just start pushing
my pawns but maybe
do I have so I'll throw this in just
because it's bothering me oh you haven't
moved D4 which I missed nice maybe does
that work
I don't know if that works actually
because Knight D4
Rook D4 Bishop D4 Knight B5 there's
Queen E5 very important loose pieces
dropped off as you like to say good
catch by you but I guess though the
major point is that there are some
tactics up in the actually after here
can I play F4 your Bishop's overlooked
ah you do it like this okay so but what
if I take with the bishop instead on D4
yeah now we're getting into the weeds
here but it's getting really complicated
these types of positions yeah Queen E5
take take wait actually there's a pin
here so I can just move my knight away
right
yeah but I still have C5 okay a little
bit complex anyway I agree with you
Queen D6 maybe not necessary
uh what did he play in the game he went
he played King B8 okay
and then we just see a trade in F4 wait
but I don't like this D4 move somehow
that feels good yeah why would you give
the E4 square and this diagonal for
white to use
yeah that's surprising to say the least
because what was okay he was worried
about what was he worried about like
Queen F3 there's Knight D4 so I don't
even see
what the threat was I don't think there
is a threat and
I think his idea is to drive I was about
to say it and there it appeared Drive
the pawn into D3 but I still like this
for white I'm not saying that white is
better or winning or anything like that
but it now is a more double-edged
position and this Pawn on D3 may have
wandered a little bit too far because
let's say I make a quiet move like C3
here and I just leave this pawn and go
for it later I feel like this could be a
long-term problem for black
yeah especially when you only need a
draw I would not uh Rock the Boat like I
wouldn't muddy the waters here for no
reason and C3 was placed or Nepal liking
your idea and now I guess he's gonna try
and come after this D3 Pawn somehow
you should and black does have this move
F5 which is annoying so maybe white
should play Knight F5 first
I like that a lot yeah and there could
also be G4 stabilizing and you go Rook
G3 to bring up The Rook well that's
clever
bring this Rook up here and go after
this Pawn I feel like white is clearly
happy over the last few moves I don't
like when nordbe there's no reason to
push this deep on
it felt like something you would do if
you were behind in the match but not
necessarily ahead
and Jan could not ask for anything more
beautiful night placement light Square
domination Queen coming up to F3 to join
the party uh what is Blackstone okay
there is I like Bishop C5 though because
I think tickling your Rook
okay so if I just slide my Rook over and
and then
I wanted to attack on F5 but it's not
even easy to
to do that like Rook D5 Maybe
yeah what what have I really okay wait a
second what about Knight G7 like I'll
allow you to take on C5 if you want so
you're saying Knight G7 ugh
yeah but see at least now I think it's
harder for you to to attack E3
right something like this I I feel like
that's a long-term weakness I don't and
this C5 Pawn now is weak as well well
okay I see some light at the end of the
tunnel I I want to play F5 Queen F7 and
C4 something
wow maybe a tunnel
your tunnel is one I don't want to visit
anytime soon
you know I'd love to see you my friend
but I'm not driving through that one
that seems like it's uh okay so he he
went for Knight H or what did he go yeah
he went for Knight H4
takes G3
and now I think he's
probably has to go Bishop B7 because you
can play F5 but you're just helping
white get what he wants Knight F2
and then this Pawn actually falls
immediately in that case so Bishop E7
Knight F2 is made by Bishop C5 very
important move to
pin this Knight on the diagonal yeah
okay Queen F3 F5 something like this
maybe black is very much in this game I
think I overestimated the White's
position yeah I think the key is
actually notabreck is Gonna Wanna trade
his Bishop for the Knight
and when you get those two pieces off
it's harder for white to uh pick off D3
like you always have uh Queen D6 if
necessary
no I'm starting to uh appreciate
the journey you're leading me down so
you know what I didn't want to travel
through your tunnel now I'm I'm seeing a
little bit more here I feel like uh
black station isn't that bad even if
there's a long-term issue to deal with
so that's a long ways away so why don't
we step aside from this game for the
moment three other games are going on
here we have uh Vladimir if I'm here for
to save is always on camera
I don't blame the camera person I really
don't
every time we go to the camera it is
federal Sav we're zoomed in on his
spiffy coat there his little sports coat
he's uh focused on his position he has
the white pieces against Magnus and
Magnus is taking a different approach
than noribbeck did and yes the opening
moves were a different sure but in
general Magnus is playing a type of game
if we bring up the board here he's
playing aggressive chess he doesn't want
to sit passively and defend he threw a
pawn up to G5 already
mm-hmm so Federal CF has actually gone
for this sort of reverse Stonewall but I
think it was geared towards
um Magnus playing Knight C6 so he wants
to bolster that with the pawn on C3 and
I have to say this looks pretty good for
uh for photo save
and your point is that this Pawn should
probably be on C5 challenging the center
Knights like to be behind pawns because
it puts more pressure uh in the middle
of the board so here the 9c6 is not
doing anything in particular and well
you said you like photos position so
let's talk about what you like about it
we have two Pawns in our fourth rank
compared to just one for black we have
complete control over E5 this bishop on
D7 is not very good the bishop on D1 can
Venture right now to C2 and
cause some issues maybe on this diagonal
so is that enough that's my question for
you we can see or I've elaborated some
of the advantages but is it enough yeah
the first thing that I want to point out
though is magnus's last move was a very
bad sign because you normally never want
to take on F4 in this kind of stone wall
and give the white Bishop on C1 more
scope
so the fact that he he had to make that
trade
um is already is it's uh going in the
wrong direction and now I by the way I
think the reason why you had to do it is
because let's say you played a move like
H6
maybe FG and E4 was
I'm not actually sure what was the idea
but it could have been this
something like this does look quite
spicy and the nights are active for
white and some pawns are dangling in
this position so I could see that and he
took it yeah now the current position
seems so attractive for me because you
have this excellent grip on the E5
Square I think Knight D3 is coming up um
probably go Queenie two Bishop C2 Castle
Queen side and long term if black
doesn't get E5 it's just a passive
position
but E5 looks like it's kind of near
Bishop E7 to D6 Castle Queen side bring
a rook to the E file I don't typically
like leading with the queen
I understand I think it's okay I think
it's okay
um
what I'm wondering though is is there
like an F5 positional Pawn SEC idea to
sort of soften up black structure
potentially
for me that's the only way white can
maybe play for something because Black's
next moves are Bishop E7 Castle Queen
side Bishop D6 and Rook to E8 and then
play for E5 it's automatic so that's why
I don't love fariser's position is I
just feel like the next few moves are
much more obvious for black now for
white that's a good point yeah I was
trying to see if F5 works like F5 EF
Bishop B3
um if we could show this because it's
important if white can make this work
it's a really huge idea
but I suppose yeah Bishop B3 queen of
seven
Queen B5 though
you're really sure
yeah can we show that because this
no no I want to start with F5 maybe okay
F5 just to see
yeah Bishop B3
okay so basically Queen B5 runs into
night uh Knight takes D4 right that's
why you don't want to put your queen in
line with a less valuable piece now I
have an attack on you you could take on
B7 yeah black is able to make actually
you might see a checkmated oh goodness
okay yeah forget forget the suggestion
but yeah this should be okay Bishop B3
first though I think
yeah that's uh
that's the correct way
and then F5 at least is a serious threat
agreed you're just trying to pry open
the position and there's a short Pawn
chain a pawn chain is only as strong as
its base Pawn it's probably an F7 F5
would be so scary with it on F6 now I'm
just trying to Chisel away but I think
after Bishop B3 I could even think about
Knight A5 in some positions just to uh
get rid of this pesky Bishop but now
it's starting to get more tactical and
that's the good news for federal save I
still feel like Magnus should be happy
even Queen F7
Castle Bishop D6 these kind of moves
they do sort of play themselves but I'm
with you Jeffrey Bishop B3 at least
causes black a little bit more concern
yeah I'm interesting to see how this one
I'm interested to see how this develops
but can we go to hikara's game for a
second because I think he has no G Pawn
if I'm not mistaken
Hikaru has no G Pawn you're saying so
let's go right over there
wait what
so it's
did The Kinks start on D1 hold on let's
see no what the king didn't even start
on D1 how did this happen
yeah that's an interesting I uh start by
Hikaru bluebound did dekaru what a car
did to him opening up the f file very
early in this game
and just simple development so far
and this yeah I like
well yeah both sides sort of have a
concept F3 is very weak but also E4 is a
nice Square for the white right I'll
highlight that in blue whereas F3 is an
issue so Bishop H5
oh
light squares are vulnerable
and that's why he played King of D1 he
had to stop Knight C2 check
yeah but this is sort of like artificial
castling I think it's
it makes a lot of sense because the King
on C2 is very secure
so Bishop E7 somehow is a huge mistake
black is half a pawn better and then
Bishop E7 is played and then it's like
plus 1.4 or something
seems like he had to act quicker
because if Wyatt is able to get what he
wants it's positionally just much better
but how me I see F4 friends F5 but I can
just play Bishop F7 at the end right
like I take and
take and Bishop F7 or something
oh wait so you mean it's concrete
because I assume that white could just
play uh play a natural moves
well I I don't know how else white could
be better in this position like even A3
and then yeah it goes back back oh it
goes down okay then I guess you're right
I'm only knowing that because I've done
commentary with an eval bar no moves
long enough to know that like when it
goes to plus 1.5 out of nowhere it's got
to be something and I would never really
want to play F4 but
what I mean this looks just bad for
white
both sides have trumps like again uh as
we highlighted
nights look good on e4 and D5 but maybe
that's not the most important thing in
this position
I love the
f file for black and what you want to do
later is play C6 to kick this Knight out
and then play D5 to kick that Knight out
right long story though
yeah I
I guess the key of this position is that
black doesn't have any weaknesses like
G7 is never weak you can push G6
meanwhile you just double on the f file
and and sort of pilot pressure you have
the c65 long term kicking out both
nights
so yeah I now I'm starting to understand
why uh why black is for Choice here
fish are random so odd and it's so
difficult to wrap your head around like
the proper plans from the starting
position and that's what gives but it's
blue but I'm a chance with a black
pieces we were just talking about this
would you rather play in a must win
situation fish a random or classical and
I think fisherandom is the way to go so
we'll see if blue bomb can make this
work we have not looked at the Local
Heroes game uh gretarsen Drew game one
uh with white against Wesley so here oh
my goodness
uh this looks really bad though he's
down
one pawn and his King's in the center
yeah let's go let's go back what what
happened here
D4 D5 okay so yeah we got this caracon
so the best move here is Knight F6 oh
wait
knight from AJ doesn't go there
and look at that Bishop B6 and
immedially white is plus one
like point seven
yeah the move that I would I would
really try to make E5 work
like we saw this idea in some other
games but just like before C3 like with
uh
with the intention of Queen B4 check
this is what I would try to make work
yeah makes sense to me D5 Queen B4
Knight C3
and then some sort of Gambit style play
Knight G6 and castles and and go yeah I
see your point just go at oops sorry go
after the pawn castle and say your head
in development and white has some issues
to solve if you're going to keep this
extra Pawn I buy that what I don't buy
is what happened the game C3
Queen E2 no E5 for you your King's in
line with his Queen Bishop back to C7
moving the same piece twice in the
opening and now white simply castled so
F4 is ready you're just losing time
Knight F6
Knight G3 and look at this move that is
a big question mark
H5
just giving away this pawn and the
threat is Knight takes F6 check so you
have to move your king away and he goes
King to d8 and Jeffrey this is really
bad news
it feels too desperate to me it just
feels desperate like I understand I
think he really disliked his position
because Knight G6 was a natural move but
white would always play F4
and uh yeah that's why he felt the need
to
to check upon with H5 but it's hard
you're not really going to convince me
with this one no you're simply down upon
your king is less safe whites King
nicely tucked away on G1 this is really
really bad and for gretzerson he's down
under nine minutes on the clock he's
down a pawn he's playing Wesley so he
had a good save in game one but game two
is just a nightmare thus far
yeah I mean the only thing I can
try to do for black is to go on the H
file but there's I mean why I can even
just keep there on H5 so there's no
attack you have
a more unsafe King it's just a clean H
Pawn to the goods so yeah
okay so Wesley so
looking to repeat as the Fisher random
Champion will leave him to it over here
should we go back to maybe nordi back
and uh Yonder promise yes we haven't
been there in a while so I'm gonna take
us there right now because look at this
position where
and I feel like I'm looking at a totally
different game
yeah and
I mean nepo he was reckless in the first
game
seemed like a solid start now but
somehow he's been provoked
push all his pawns up and I'm seeing
Queen before I'm seeing Knight C5 like
what the heck happened I'm just going
back to where we left off he went B4 at
this point A5 was nobody back's Choice
what a move by the way it looks like B4
the threat is to go B5 and he welcomes
it with A5
and I love how he maneuvered his Knight
watch what he does
okay watch out your king is it gonna be
checked it goes back
F5
Bishop C5 getting rid of this Knight
saying you're gonna be left with this
terrible Bishop
C1 Knight C8
takes and here comes Knight D6 C4 oh and
this is pure class look this I mean how
do you not play Knight E4 but the the
whole trick nepo's only idea how many E5
and yes a rook is five and a bishop is
three but the Rooks don't have any open
files so the bishop is actually very
powerful here and that's why instead the
Knight dropped back to B7 a fantastic
choice a night Retreat C5 is harder to
make work with all these pieces covering
the square so Jeffrey nobody make Abdul
sitarov he may be a teenager but he's
showing the class of a veteran player
such a mature move yes showing awareness
of your opponent's ideas and now his
idea I think it's just Queen B4 and
nepo he's he's trying to figure out
how he can
you see him just perplexed right now I'm
watching you evaluate calculate and
you're just like I don't see this
yeah he's gonna okay he tries rookie
five
he wants C5 and to sacrifice in exchange
over here
okay it's still very complex like yeah
at some point we are probably going to
see C5 and and the position will start
to explode
so I guess we should just show let's say
I make a normal move like G6 to defend
my pawn and C5 happens what is the
actual evaluation of this here
I like the look of it for white that's
an unsafe King but white king is not
very safe either so if this queen ends
up on the B3 Square which can go to Via
F7 that means that
black will have very good chances to
force to draw at some point
yeah and that's exactly what he needs so
a move like Queen F7
so no more Bishop B5
and because it's checking at the very
least you can just repeat these checks a
bunch
yes that would be a draw
okay wait so he's gone Queen before
Instead This is a slightly different
version mm-hmm
you have to wait is he gonna is he gonna
trade Queens is he gonna trade Queens
here oh my goodness Queen think about
that right you've just given away a rook
for a night so you're taught The Rook is
more valuable black is a head material
so you're taught not to trade when down
material this is a wonderful decision
because that's a rook take C5 if we get
this queen trade F5 is hanging and if
you defend F5 then there's Bishop coming
out to E5 hitting C7 you defend C7 Here
Comes B6 that's not just an attack but a
pin and you get this Pawn a five hangs
next D3 is weak wow this is some great
stuff by you on the palm machine
it's honestly it's a crazy level of
understanding because
I just find it so counterintuitive right
you're down in material you need a win
and you go for an end game
it's hard to do but now that okay let's
I still think it's
it's very reasonable for black but you
might have to go with your own counter
play like through um
how actually how do you get caterpley
because the IFA will be shut off
I'm wondering the same thing and if you
allow the trade here after ab4 this King
walks up and just wins that pawn
immediately and that's an outside pass
Pawn I I see the evaluation as minus
point four I don't care I think that
actually white is more likely to win
this game
oh I couldn't agree more
so okay I guess you take on C5 and then
you play some sort of
calm move like I don't know King B7 or
something just stopping the bishop 5 B6
idea we don't do com over here but let's
uh King B7 it's changed it's still in
exchange I guess yeah and it's a change
for a pawn if I take this one I might
not even take the pawn because that
could potentially open up more files
like I'm already thinking is there a way
to open up lines for these Rooks and get
a rook to here but there's always Bishop
E5 and maybe everything gets closed down
too quickly so Queen C5 by the way was
just played oh wait I see a super clever
way in that line I think to open
something tell me so I let's say King B7
Rook takes
Rook d8
Bishop E5 and I want to play G5
I was thinking about that but what if I
just take it Rook f8 rook gf8 and you
have to concede a file I think
oh
but even if I can see the file like I'll
put H4 and you're not going to attack
any of my pawns really and I could get a
pass Pawn over here is it that
no it's not clear like Rook of faden and
uh
yeah no it's still very unclear
I think it's one of these positions that
once you get here you're still unsure
how to assess it so from a distance
you're like it's very forcing so do I
want to allow it if it's Rook D7 just
defending the seventh Rank preemptively
and that's actually good because allows
Rook to E8 after Rook takes F5 G7 is
defended so I actually really like that
move Rook D7 it's a good start but after
white takes there is Bishop E5 there's
also calmer moves as well like Bishop C
like King A2 and Bishop C3 things like
that I don't think there's any real rush
in the position for white
yeah I I think it's hard to resist
planning the bishop though right away on
E5 and if white gets time to bring the
king in King B2 King C3 then black might
start getting in some trouble
yeah and I'm this A5 Pawn long-term
weakness this bishop can retreat at some
moment and you may just drop this Pawn
on A5 so I I think that Jana pomshi has
chances in this game we're already on
move 33 by the way so they're getting
increment and they already are gaining
their five minutes so no time trouble in
this one the players will keep on going
from here so that means we should
probably go yeah can we go back back to
Magnus I see a temporary PSEC was played
oh okay here we are we last left off
around here I'm just gonna show how we
got here as we see the players on screen
there was Bishop B3 instead of Knight A5
Queen F7
castles Bishop E3
Knight goes in castles all of this is
very normal stuff
Bishop D6
and after
97 here is Knight D to E5 very
interesting move Jeffrey I think a lot
of people would think oh let's go Knight
F to E5 to open up against this queen
but actually after it takes takes here
Knight F5 this Queen's under attack and
there's no Bishop takes F5
correct and I think I like this
transition because White's dream
that in a perfect world is to get this
night this good night against Bad Bishop
the bishop on D7
could be a tall Pawn in the near future
so he's trying to get some trades off if
he can carve out the E5 Square for his
Knight it's even better but
um yeah now Magnus he has a tough choice
to make
yeah no this is a great decision I like
what you're pointing out when you look
at positions and you try to figure out
what am I going to do evaluate what
trades might work out in your favor and
this bishop light squares can't attack
anything this Knight can hop into the
game uh from F3 so Knight F5 now this
was the essential difference we were
highlighting the bishop can take and
then you take on D6 you get your piece
back and with it a better position so a
big Choice Magnus Carlson Who's down to
six minutes and change for 12 moves to
make here Jeffrey this is not an envious
or enviable I should say task for Magnus
totally agree uh Federal save has done
an amazing job getting chances and I
would give him a serious chance of
leveling this match
for sure Queen G7
that'll save the big fish
he took a drink of water and again the
camera is just zoomed in on federal save
today this is the feather save camp
it seems like it's always on him so
actually black is still not threatening
to get his Bishop out of the way so he
could just play a move like G3 if you
wanted
I like it Jeffrey is explaining to
everybody that yes this piece can be
captured but think about it can it go
anywhere so know the trade is not forced
so maybe just play a slow move like G3
and then say to block all right your
move next figure out what to do
so this looks good and why don't we take
on a peek on over at the local hero well
unfortunately that game looks like it's
conclusion oh King what a ran away
but it got checkmated anyway so let's go
just a few moves back where we left off
oh my goodness
Bishop B3
Rook h8 check
wait wait a second
wait a second okay
King B6
I think he was too brave in this game he
could play King D7 kind of hang out for
a little bit but King B6 allowing the
very quick storm of his King he missed
Rook takes A6 which is a beautiful find
by Wesley so
yeah I think we'll be seeing that added
to the puzzle Rush database
just a lovely little
simple but but nice
finish to the sink
that is sick they just bring that King
up rook A6 a good spot here allows
mating one so that is a nasty finish
Wesley so takes his first match against
johar gretcherson so let's keep going
back within the games that are still in
play we are just looking at Federal save
and Carlson maybe let's take a look at
nakamura's game against Bluebell because
Hikaru he won game one here in game two
it looks like things are all even so it
may have been dicey for a moment there
Jeffrey but now with just queens and
Rooks and four pawns aside this is just
a level game
and there's a back rink mate threatened
here as well so the only move to keep
Queens on the board which I think you
have to uh as bluebum is Queen h8
at least just to keep the game going a
bit
although then white can try to trade
more pieces with Rook F3 because you
can't actually take on F3 you get
background Checkmate so it feels like
pieces are coming off no matter what you
do and if we're being realistic and
Hikaru Nakamura has I I'm gonna say zero
chance of losing this game
that's a very fair assessment and can we
just go back because this was promising
for bluebum at some point
so around here a car went Queen G4 the
queen drops back to F7 F4 Big Move F4
yes
that is
um just getting rid of that backward
pawn and also
no more F3 Square for black
it still looks good for bluebound
and that oh my gosh look what he
overlooked so he went Knight F3 hoping
to play G4 next and just plant this
Knight in enemy territory he missed this
move Knight F6 which I'm not actually
sure I'm not sure he missed it because
he I think he wanted this right he
wanted this
because he still has a passport oh no no
H5 false sorry sorry I I didn't see H5
Falls at the end yeah so he he ended up
giving away his font still should be
slightly better for black apparently but
now there's Mass liquidation rookie one
and then take on G5 take on H2 so I
think he just traded off too many pieces
Jeffrey yes black still chances
throughout that tactical sequence but
when the Skirmish finished it's clear
that well okay Queen takes you through
his play that's a draw for yeah I
believe the game has been agreed can we
just confirm that it's it's done the
draw is in the books Hikaru Nakamura
wins this first match against Matthias
bluebound
not without its drama though that first
game I think
bluebonn will be uh regretting promoting
I think if he had traded Queens it was
within the drawing margin in game one he
also will regret this moment Jeffrey he
could have put G4 first there was no
reason that he had to play Knight F3 so
if he played G4 he keeps the advantage
going and he can play for a win and his
King is safe whites King is weirdly on
C2 so a missed chance not to win the
game but at least to give himself a
better opportunity to win so
unfortunately for bluebaum he suffers a
match defeat but Hikaru he proved uh
once again time and time again he proves
that he's able to see through the
tactics in the critical moments all
right shall we go back to the nepo game
let's do just that yeah on the Palm
Street with the white pieces nobody
could just starved with black where I
move 40 already and the King came up to
C4 I believe you have to be careful
about your Rook being a little bit loose
on D5 but the B takes E6 so probably The
Rook has to step back but then Bishop D4
check and this Pawn is loose
what's going on
yeah just a quick no I feel like
notorbeck is sort of a young nepo in
terms of like his time management
because it's very rare to be up on time
against
who's famous for just blitzing out his
moves
yeah it is rare to see that so it's kind
of in the the vein of nepo and mvl types
just
playing at a blistering Pace but now
that we're here Jeffrey
it says zeros on the evaluation bar
because of course all end games are just
equal duh but in all seriousness what do
you rate nepo's winning chances as
I thought it was much higher before I
saw this move that neuterbeck just
played because I think he wants to go
King B7 next
and start opening files for his Rooks
so if the files get open the Rooks get
going that gives chances for black to be
active instead of passive but what if is
there a way that white pushes this Pawn
to B6 for example or does that close the
position too much
I think you might have to because if you
allow the C file to open
um just imagine in some position like
Rook C2 will will be uh slammed down and
I feel like you're better off
going yeah there's Bishop D6 like you
said
something like this try to get a
protected past Pawn the bishop can
always slide a C5 and the
King has just gone back to B7 after
Bishop D4 check we may in fact see this
variation so after King B7
you could simply play a move like Bishop
C5 because after Pawn takes
uh actually no can I get away with that
no I can't I made a mistake maybe not
yeah I like B6
so does John
but I mean the good news uh sir uh the
good news for notabeck he has a lot of
time here like I'm surprised how fast
he's played this game it's not like it
was some boring game there was there was
quite a lot of stuff going on so Props
to uh I guess both players were just
going I mean playing very intuitively
what I'm concerned about though for
nerdybeck is eventually G4 and F5 is a
necessity let's create a pass Bond D3 is
loose A5 can be targeted at some Moment
Like a rook E5
type of maneuver so I just feel like
he's got problems all across the board
and how do you solve them The Rook needs
to stay on the seventh rank otherwise
this Rook comes up so he goes after this
bishop but his Bishop will go to C5
it's a lot of ideas
um I'm with you I think in a practical
game this is not zeros for sure first of
all White's never risking here
and second of all
as you said yeah there's so much to
worry about
the good news though is the clock that
you've mentioned uh Nordica bus stop
ahead on time and maybe after Bishop C5
Jeffrey there's like Rook D5 and
sacrifice your back for this bishop and
uh just to sort of show what that might
look like is if I get here and what's a
random move I can play like rookie three
well actually that's too good of a move
like rookie one or something I was just
thinking can I get into this end game
here and the answer is no it's still
much better for white but I was just
trying to give back some of the material
but with this Pawn being weak and
um
white so close to it I guess it's much
better
my guess is there's not going to be a
way to bail out
so you're just gonna have to sort of try
and hold it hold all the glue with your
Rooks but at some point this G4 F5 will
come
and then like it's just incredibly
difficult to play this Mission with no
counter play
not fun and I think black just has to go
on a yoyo string like Rook D5 Rook D7
back and forth there's nowhere for this
Rook to infiltrate the white Rook can't
get in because if you go to E7 The Rook
goes back to D7 so all right I'm sorry
yeah sorry to cut you off but we gotta
head over to Magnus the Magnus let's do
it you don't ever have to apologize to
want to go to Magnus Carlson's game
we're heading right there Magnus
doesn't look like a happy camper does he
yeah that was a very funny facial
expression he made
um wait so his second exchange or he
blundered it
I don't know the camera's always in fair
to save
nothing else besides what federal save
is looking at you know how his suit is
looking but it looks like
wait I think man is blundered
I'm getting to that point let's see
like this is all solid and then you just
please
there's a one more blunder everybody
this Rook is defended enough times here
he goes Queen G6 allowing 95 simply
forgetting that The Rook needs a
Defender oh my gosh
wait but that's like a beginner tactic
yeah that's shocking to see from Magnus
Carlson who now has his head in his
hands he is very upset with himself but
let's calm ourselves down Jeffrey we've
reached move 30 which means that Federal
Sav doesn't have to worry about getting
flagged five second increment he's up on
the clock anyway with the extra five
minutes
um
it's a night in one Pond for a rook so
with the Queens on the board there could
be checkmating attacks and things like
that with the Queens off the board it
could be a winning end game so I guess
you're the super GM here help me out how
what is white looking for what is black
looking for
well I think
as you sort of were um insinuating if
you ever reach an end game it's just
over because
uh with pawns and opposite sides of the
board the Knight cannot contest with the
Rook simple as that
um the next thing I see is White's King
is very safe so I'm not worried about
that I think you just slowly make some
threats and the fact that end games are
always winning are gonna make this
position unhotable
okay so the end games will be winning
for white so black should not be trading
Queens how about the fact that this D4
Pawn is isolated and maybe that once we
get out of the pan there could be a
knight F5 or Knight C6 is the King on C1
is it gonna run to A3 at some point how
do you see this game continuing
yeah I like uh either to start with a
move like Queen F2 or King B2
I love this idea of tucking the key on
A3 because it might be difficult to
check
and then yeah like the pin on the
seventh rank seems seems pretty nasty
here
okay so we see that white has some time
to spare maybe black we'll try to move
this King out the way I'm not really
sure where you go because King E8
doesn't exactly look like you're getting
any safer you may find yourself
not just a victim on the seventh rank
but a back ranked checkmate at some
point as well yeah I'm not very happy if
I'm Magnus Carlson to see this position
it feels like if you just made me choose
the odds here like what 80 plus percent
that white wins this game
agreed somewhere in that neighborhood
and oh man Magnus he looks distraught he
he cannot believe what he's done
it was a one movement we're gonna just
go back to that moment again because
here Queen G6 it walks right in to this
problem when there are many pieces on
the same line think about what happens
when the piece in between them gets out
the way now Knight H4 may look good but
allows not just Queen G7 but also Rook
takes F2 I understand I give up my queen
but I get a second Rook with check and
then also the Knight that's on G6 so
there are too many pieces in the same
line Knight E5 check is the way out the
queen no longer defends the rook and
that was an elementary mistake for
someone of Magnus Carlson's caliber
and I like that photo save is taking his
time here trying to be precise
I think if he plays this correctly he
should be able to level the match and
secure uh one match point
this would be huge for fedosaves chances
because he can compete with anybody he's
a combative player he is defeated all
the best players in the world in quicker
time controls especially and so if
Magnus Carlson gives him this
opportunity to tie the match he may
regret it at the final standings of the
group stage but Rook F6 so he actually
voluntarily
releases the pin Jeffrey I don't really
like that decision
on the other hand yeah it's soft side of
five
um he's attacking H6 maybe he wants H3
so I can sort of reason with this move
so I think H5 looks pretty natural here
just to save your Pawn if I'm mad yeah
H3 and then you have to play Queen G8
but it's probably okay
Queen Jia to keep E6 defended I mean if
I can keep E6 defending and get my
knight out to F5 all of a sudden I'm
believing in Black's chances to hold
this game it's a long story I know I'm
just talking about some moves here but
if we just you know play these moves
Queen G8 force does Jefferson need to
keep E6 defended and then my next move
is Knight F5 and pawn H4
it actually kind of feels like white
does not have the easiest time making
progress
yeah I much preferred that Rook on F7
now that I'm looking at this
not sure
right I mean I'm just trying to find
where the Breakthrough is going to
happen from and that's the good news for
Magnus even though he blundered he can
sit and be like hold up
how do I lose this game exactly like if
you don't see the conclusion then you
start believing in yourself a little bit
more
very true
and okay he's trying to I don't actually
see another move besides H5 because you
definitely can't give up H6 for free
right
no way there's no although after Queen
G8 are you actually giving up H6 that's
maybe what he's thinking about whoa
because the Rook takes there's Knight F5
aha
yeah I mean I guess that's a move but I
don't see any reason why you would play
it
I I don't either but you asked me why
he's thinking so I had to come up with a
response to you even though I'm gonna
put H5 in a second yeah you threatened
Knight F5 I guess oh by the way you it
makes sense to keep the pawn on H6
because then Knight on F5 would defend
and attack
that's true and you don't give up maybe
this G5 squared later in the game like
trying to infiltrate is not easy right
now for white so maybe keeping the
status quo with Queen G8 makes sense and
Magnus he's on the clock he's thinking
and just to show you why H6 can't be
captured give you a visual here it runs
right into Knight F5 and now black is
better that's a fork and if you take
with the queen then this queen comes
down to G1 with check D4 is hanging and
this king is actually quite exposed you
see that actually it's already even on
the evaluation so Queen G8 possible
instead he plays H5 which he could have
done in two seconds but he takes his
time and plays the move and Jeffrey I
know I said 80 plus percent for federal
save not much has changed
but I'm starting to believe in magnus's
chances more
as am I yeah it's from yeah that
percentage for me has gone down quite a
bit I didn't like Rook F6 uh now that I
mean now that
we've seen uh the night come to five and
that Rook actually starts to feel a bit
stranded too
wow and D4 is a target
what do you even
do hear if you're phariseev
yeah he might have to back back up
okay if you have to back your Rook up
it's clear you've made some mistakes
right Right Moves yeah yeah I I am I
think you might have to admit that I'm
just worried like let's say you allow
Knight F5 I don't know let's play King
B2 Knight F5 Queen E5
The Rook has no squares
so black makes a way to move Queen E8
for instance
we're H4 yeah I like H4 better
and now what what exactly do you want to
do
I wait until your queen moves So I
sacrifice The Exchange it's the only
thing I can think of because there are
zero promising looking moves at this
point like let's say King A3 is played
can I just like I don't know make a
whatever move somehow
yeah Queenie 80 I guess but I was
worried about this
right yeah but this
King C7
yeah I just felt like at the end of the
day White's up a pawn here so
pretty happy about that
right this one would be very hard to
evaluate but considering like Magnus
murdered in exchange I think he'd be
relatively happy with this
for sure
for sure I mean the position is just
looking like it's more manageable for
Magnus and federal saves lead on the
clock it is diminishing he plays King B2
we will undoubtedly see Knight F5 and
then H4 these moves seem quite easy to
play there mags Knight goes
Queen goes up to E5 so oh so we're
getting this
mm-hmm and uh maybe we go back just for
a brief moment because I think the other
match is about to end things have gone
terribly wrong for an episode
all right let's go to that game between
yonda
oh gosh
uh
no winning chances whatsoever for a
young the palm tree and only losing
chances at this point
yeah
you can't move yes white you can never
play King A6 you can never push a pawn
um I was going to ask is there any
um like what's the tie break is there
Merit to winning 2-0 over one and a half
probably uh if you're you know because
the top two of each group Advanced so
I'm guessing there's some benefit to
having more game points but uh we will
find the answer out to that question
oh rookie eight I think he's gonna win a
pawn here
yeah this is just
initially because you push that pawn to
D4 at some moment for black and rookie a
check is also a threat yikes
yeah I don't see how NEP was gonna avoid
the sweep
okay maybe it came before is not that
clear because some rook and Bishop end
games have garage tendencies
and we are getting confirmation that
match points you know determine the
standings and then game points are the
first tiebreaker so you should win 2-0
if you can and
well why not play on here just take this
Pawn you have no risk whatsoever if
you're noribeca bustarov yeah he's got
this match win locked up thrown away the
key it's in the bank
and
for nepo it's gonna I think he might
have to sort of motivate himself that
this half Point might come in handy
later on so just keep fighting
yeah but he's he should have had that
mindset earlier you know like blue bomb
did just agree to a draw and call it a
match yeah wait let's see what happened
because I we thought that he could never
lose like I even said I thought no risk
he seemed like he had a dominating
position despite being down in exchange
okay shuffling not much Happening Here
okay
this was like a fortress for black
actually
yeah no it's just an impenetrable
defensive stance and then rookie five
and then
Rook D7 in Bishop C5
back and forth we go and he took on D5
so this is where he said I need to break
the balance and after this he's now
losing or at least much worse I don't
know if lost yeah I don't know what he
saw there like to me it seems
pretty obvious that get winning the a
pawn isn't really getting anything but
okay he had to try something
no he's dead lost for sure
yeah wow what a very impressive start
here by notorbeck
yes winning two nothing over the promise
the game is not officially in the books
but it might as well be because this is
hopeless you lose D3 you lose the game
so let's go back to the game between
Federal save and Magnus Carlson because
this one is clear so let's go we are
deep in
wait
okay I think the uh
the eval bar is uh still hovering from
the last game so we will um
just get that fixed
I don't even know how honestly but the
Evo bar is definitely not correct
wait a second so Magnus has done it in a
way that you can't even sack and win
both Pawns
is done in a way right because he keeps
everything under control
you can't get this position with black
to move because you're gonna have to
move King and then I give checks
yeah
so wait a second let's just imagine on
the players here we see phariseev I mean
he's look at him we have him on camera
always he is
determined trying to figure out what to
do
but he's probably not very happy with
what's going on
yeah I would guess that this is a draw
now I don't see
a good way to proceed
hmm you see anything at all any
possibilities
well oh so that live board oh I guess
that's the finish of Abdul satorv he has
one two zip
this is the current one
no I don't see anything do you
no
um and I'm trying to think how to like
prolong the game even if I don't see a
clear win you need to find a way to
create tricks traps make your opponent's
life uneasy and
yeah I'm not seeing any of that because
if you go King back I always have Queen
check and queen back to G8 like as long
as this queen can go back to this G8
Square I feel like
there's no progress to be made and the
queen covers uh can't Romero's covers D5
which is very important
indeed holding all the glue together
and photos save
motioning something
um
have the standard camera on Photo save
here as he tries to work through the
position but Jeffrey I mean what can he
do at some point he probably has to give
up his Rook for the night because the
Rook is trapped in here but your king is
simply too open you're if you win H4
somehow I don't even see how but let's
say you do I think I would have counter
play on your king
right
all right
okay okay he goes back Queenie one
which makes a lot of sense actually yes
because you're attacking A5 and H4 if
you ever want to play Rook takes a five
but
ah yeah this is a very good try so the
queen is still tied down to E6 hold on
so if I take on D4 which Pawn do you
take
probably a five I guess
but then you have no checks right so I'm
thinking if I can do something
Queen G1 after that something like that
something along those lines yeah because
Rick F7 is only one check
Magnus no doubt calculating it
big moment here for Magnus Carlson he
doesn't have to take this Pawn he can
keep the status quo he can make him like
B6 for example just to defend that Paul
no but B6 Queen E5 back
aha this is what I wanted to to get the
same position with your move
you're a mean man
well he's the one that played Queenie
one I didn't see it
[Laughter]
true Vladimir photos say have come up
with a good try and by the way both oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait I see I oh
sorry you were saying no I've seen both
players under two minutes
uh-huh I think Queenie 8 is possible but
I'm wondering if it's good
Like Queenie a threatening Queen E7
you can move your king
hmm
it's a tough moment here I mean you can
see magnets trying to work through the
complications as he now is
going down a minute and a half so it's
going to get up to a plur a pure
Scramble with the five second increment
but Jeffrey you have a lot of experience
playing Blitz five second increment in a
position like this it may not be enough
depending on how tricky it gets yeah
okay so uh he's gone Queen E8 and I was
looking at key uh King A2 or King B2
here just avoiding the
the check
okay you don't want to run into Queen E7
yes sir you said something about the
time of year I was too focused on the
position so yeah the five the five
second increment it is a lot yeah
players are used to two so five should
be like you're you're relaxing on the
beach
but okay still
yeah
I would say you are for sure but are
aren't you still looking to position
like it's sharp if you need to win the
game you need to find something that
just doesn't you know immediately allow
a draw or hang something
all right Queen G8 back so what is this
idea though if I take
oh he wants queen G7
and just going for a D4 that way
and the very clever play very clever
play by both
but it feels like Magnus should be very
happy with the last bunch of moves
uh well I mean Federal save he's he's
trying okay looks like he's got another
idea up his sleeve
calculating
trying to figure it out but not easy
Queen G5 Queen E5 it's Queen G2 and we
we've essentially had this before
and the queen back to G8
yeah all right he's gone King C3
this way
I'm
um all right which angle should we go
because I don't think the board's
updating
yeah I can uh see if refreshing works
now so King C3
you said it was played and
where'd he go
uh B6 King D3 was played okay
I'll just put those Moves In
Hindi six whoa
allowing Queen E5 but going right back
to D7 is his plan
yeah still whoa
before four
and I was wondering at some point a
black and think about Queen G3 but I
don't believe that's actually gonna work
out yeah slide behind the pawn
yes
so oh man oh okay Madness under 20
seconds
okay I'll see what he does here it says
Zero's Magnus he's he's looking at both
sides of the board he sees something
just by his eye movement yeah I don't
see anything I I maybe a B I don't know
okay C8
Queen E5
did he blender or not no King E7 he's
allowing Brook takes up he's allowing
Rook at five
just wait he's banking on oh my wait
he's banking on uh Perpetual here
I think he has it no that's insane you
don't you don't calculate this though I
mean it's just pure intuition but maybe
he's right his Queen A2 checks Queen B3
checks oh my goodness that's there's a
meat there's a meat if you run to F4 you
get checkmated with Queen G3
what brilliant calculation under
pressure
Queen C1 he played not even allowing
that King up the board but there's
nowhere to go
now he picks up the Rook
he could have made a draw on the spot
right is he playing yeah but he might be
playing for a win now
oh he's up a pawn
his expression
oh man this camera needs to like stay
put it's moving all over the place I
have no idea what's going on here this
is impossible to it's like okay I'll
tell you what's going on I think
Manistee is deciding whether or not to
repeat moves because he can play for a
win he's deciding it
he should
yeah but he doesn't have to if he
doesn't want it right
and he's
looks like he's yeah agreeing for the
draw he wins the mini match here and he
just he can't believe it because he
still think of Knight E5 check
yeah I think
he won't be proud I mean certainly not
of that one um that one move but can
certainly be proud of how he defended
afterwards just keeping his composure
and I think he defended flawlessly uh
after
uh magnets Carlson
he makes his way to a match Victory I
want to say through because I'm so used
to having eight players and being
elimination but no nobody is out it's a
double round robin so let's take a step
back take stock of what just occurred
here uh because nordybeck Abdus tarv he
wins 2-0 Magnus takes it one and a half
over Federal Sav in the bottom right
Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so did the
same against Matthias bluebaum and her
gretherson respectively so we know our
current leaders in group A and B
yep all blood no one wants
um a lot of great stuff so far I think
the biggest surprise has to be the way
notrebec dispatched nepo 2-0 never
really felt close
um and I'm curious to see how nepo
bounce backs
big big moment there for some of these
players and you see the playing Hall the
venue lots of Spectators there is going
to be a pause in the action now because
the matchups are switching new starting
positions will be chosen at random
and so there will be a bit of a break so
we want to you know remind you a few
important events coming up because after
this one Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
they'll jet out of Reykjavik Iceland and
head to Toronto because the chess.com
Global Championship is coming to ahead
in Toronto the live finals begin
Wednesday November 2nd with 500 000 on
the line between these eight players who
will come out on top after the upsets we
have seen throughout this tournament it
is truly anyone's game do not miss a
minute of the cgc live finals including
a special guest appearance from the
Fabiano caruana streaming here on
chess.com type the command cgc finals in
the chat for details and we shall be
right back for this Fisher random World
Championship coverage brought to you by
Brave
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck you're gonna
score it to place the dog
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
can permanently stop the London capture
the puns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates let's still wait there is
still meat but the still made it player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
all right
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
.com's coverage of the Fisher random
World Championship brought to you by
Brave we just had some exciting matches
and want to give you just one of the
highlights of them this is our brave
move of the round so Jeffrey we had
Nordic abdusitarov he swept yonda
palmchi and it all started in this
position
yeah so here we see extremely productive
play in the lead up
um as you see nepo nowhere near castling
he's got his Bishops there on CNN d8
and
uh notebook has just blasted open with
E4 nepo plays the most logical response
with F4 I think you have to close it
down
and here you might think all right just
dropped the Knight back play the game
but no nordevec
bravely sacrifices his Knight with ed5
opening up the e-file uh nepo has to
take on G3 Rook E1
and as we saw earlier Bishop B7 not
possible on account of D6
so
King D7 was I think the best try but the
attack just played out beautifully it
did and all started with that decision
to sacrifice the Knight that was under
attack the King on D7 is without
Defenders and after Knight D6 another
good move Knight to E4 and white Came
Crashing through there was nothing that
Jana palmistry could do because after
Knight D6 you either lose your Pawn H7
with check and The Rook is under attack
but Bishops attack you from all angles
yawn upon she resigned won that game and
the next as well and that's your Brave
move of the round and it's time to make
your move from chrome to Brave try it
now at brave.com so we've talked about
nordi Beck Abdul sitarov he is up uh he
won excuse me against Jana Pomchi two
games to none so he is the top his
leader group but he's joined by Wesley
so in group a so I guess Jeffrey would
you consider it a surprise that
nordeback won in this manner or is it
just a young Superstar making his
presence fell
in this manner I would say yes that he
won
not really um I as I I think I said it
coming in he had an impressive
qualifying run to Reykjavik where I
believe he beat Anish giri in the final
and he's already shown like he can fight
with anyone
um
based on his results over the past year
so yeah I think I I'm curious as to what
is the round two matchup if we could
head there does he play Wesley next yeah
we'll head to the uh matchups right
after showing the other group first
because there are four other players and
they are also going to have new
opponents in the next matches but
Nakamura Carlson the lead I don't think
anybody is going to be surprised about
that
no not at all and it wasn't I wouldn't
say it was the most convincing but most
importantly they got the job done
each with the one and a half half
victory
and when they play each other I sort of
alluded to this at the start I think
they'll want to play it safe because a
tied match might be I mean I think it's
a very reasonable result for both
yeah two players make it through right
from each group and if you're the winner
of group a you play the second place
finish on Group B so there may be some
jockeying for position that becomes
important later down the line but as we
see for round two of today's matchups it
is a car Nakamura against Magnus Carlson
that may be the fourth matchup on screen
but I think all eyes will be on that one
as well as the group a matchup between
noribeca busatarov and Wesley so
and I think in the playing Hall we see
Peter Nielsen he's getting scanned uh
all seconds do not have access to
devices very important so no engines
here um to analyze these positions
that's a player you know very well by
the way Nikita vitugo the super Grand
Master From Russia Jeffrey played a
match against Nikita during the pandemic
a very very strong player and he is
there with uh janapamshi
yeah nepo's right hand man and who else
can we see I don't see
a second for Wesley I don't see a second
for
nordebec yeah I'm looking for Yvonne
sokolov somewhere because he coached the
Uzbek national team uh but no I don't
see a well oh that's a car I was like
who is that walking around
that would be an excellent second but
unfortunately uh he's his own first and
he is playing in this event hikara
Nakamura you know he made his way
through the qualifiers but we have all
players there kind of hanging out
getting ready for the position to be
revealed we have Wesley Hikaru norvar we
have
um Matthias there and Peter Heidi
Nielsen The Tall Man against the wall
that is Magnus Carlson's trusty trainer
his main second and well while we have
the players is waiting for the position
let's remind you of who some of these
players are not that they really need to
be introduced to you but Hikaru Nakamura
who is playing here in group a uh
actually he's in Group B if I'm not
mistaken but either way he is a force he
qualified his way through uh online he
won the lead chess qualifier so he is in
the field and Jeffrey the only player
from 2019 to defeat Wesley so in a match
oh yeah that's a great Point
um I believe in that 2019 tournament he
was ousted by Fabiano I think quite
convincingly if I'm not mistaken
um but yeah he's always obviously just a
huge huge monster especially in these
fast time controls I think the 25 plus
zero suits him perfectly fine
uh and wait I'm who's who's being
scanned right there do you see I'm
trying to think that's a second right
that that's not a player yeah but who is
that
we're trying to figure this out
okay you gotta turn around oh
the camera person needs to
okay oh is that is that donchenko wait
was it
let me see let me get a better look at
it that looks like yeah it is yes from
Germany but amazing he working with
Bluebell that would make sense I would
assume yeah I would assume
okay so that would be funny it'd be
funny if it was someone else right if he
was working with fedoc or something
yeah not impossible right people don't
only work with people from uh their
country I mean
you know Peter honey Nelson is not from
Norway but he's from nearby Denmark and
you see that Hikaru and Peter having a
word over there so yeah we have
many seconds talking to their players in
the position
it looks like it is being announced very
hard to see from our vintage point oh
great job zooming in there is that a
queen queen I believe so Queen Knight
Bishop Rook
King
he only won yet again
rook and we're gonna Bishop in the
corner so there's gonna be a queen in
one corner
why are they I feel like the positions
they generate are too similar to the the
normal starting position
you mean a queen on A1 and A8 that's too
similar to the starting position
no but look there's look night Bishop
King Knight normally you shouldn't have
so many pieces in the same spots yeah
but it's just selected at random you
know they're not intentionally choosing
this position it's just out of a
generator so this is the position that
the players will have it is going to be
difficult for them to work their way
through it and while the the players
they get a break to talk to their second
to start studying the position without
engine consultation so they will be on
their own with their human minds and
with that I think that we should take a
quick break ourselves and when we return
we'll take a deep dive into the position
make some predictions and then the games
will be off so we'll be right back for
more from the Fisher random world
championship this coverage brought to
you by Brave
have you come to play
your five dollars and get the chair how
are you
my name is Jude Acres just has given me
a life in that chess table which evolved
to a place where no one wanted to be has
totally given me a world
you might cry about all things that
happened to me as a kid don't cry I
sailed through everything the moment I
found the first book of Chess By Joseph
Plumbing I was gone and I bought a um
plastic chess set in a drugstore
um ESL company with a little manual by
Frank J Marshall the legendary
Grandmaster I put it on my bed spread
and it gave off raise I was gone a gone
for gone and I it literally will keep
you alive if nothing else is going right
just has the power to literally as to
watch said make people happy
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we see fans in the playing Hall in
Reykjavik Iceland for this Fisher random
World Championship it is a sight to
behold Iceland such a beautiful country
that has hosted many Testaments over the
years as the annual Reykjavik open
Jeffrey have you ever played in
Reykjavik
unfortunately I've not gotten the chance
to
um it's always been
sort of like an idea for me but never
found the time to go but shout out to
the organizers over there looks like a
beautiful venue uh as we've mentioned
already before I love
uh how many Spectators are there
so yeah it just seems great
well while the players are not yet
seated I feel like we have a good chance
to talk about something that you've and
I have talked about off screen and I
feel like chat would be interested in
this discussion uh for this event gotta
komsky tweeted that he felt it was not
right that four players were invited to
the field and four players had to
qualify he feels like that's way too
many impities for a world championship
Jeffrey what do you think about that
foreign
well I've I feel I feel equally
frustrated as as my colleague guided us
so I mean all right Wesley and Magnus of
course I understand that that's
perfectly fine
but then why nepo exactly like I
understand you know he won a couple
candidates but I don't see what that
actually has to do with Fisher random
um and for me if you wanted to invite
someone I think Bobby would have been a
more logical choice because he won this
very high level 960 event in St Louis
was third place in 2019 so he did finish
in third and it was a wild card fide in
batif I'm not mistaken so I just think
that it's a little strange in a way that
Fida is trying to do away with the wild
card in the candidate cycle but then
they're implementing a wild card in a
dynamic in a in a variant of Chess that
we don't have much history in so we
don't have much data to say who actually
are the best players so why not have it
played out over the board
true maybe a bit inconsistent
um and especially I feel like this is
such a
for me I mean personally it's it's a
very serious event I think Fisher random
could be uh a huge part of Chess uh in
years to come so I would hope that there
would be more spots
um available to to qualify through I
guess a quick it's nice to have a local
hero here but again I feel like it's
such a big event that I would
I would like to see that open to uh to
qualification
Magnus would probably argue that he
shouldn't be invited to this like uh you
know he would have to qualify because
Wesley makes sense I understand that
some people have a problem with any sort
of wild card but when there's a host
country putting up a lot of money and
providing a venue I understand giving a
you know Wild Card selection that regard
even if I have my doubts about whether
it's necessary that they do both but
okay that makes sense to me but Magnus
is the best chess player he should be in
every tournament ever that makes sense
but
in this case I think he should have had
to qualify so uh obviously is not a
knock on any of the players in the field
Yanda palmistry as well like he very
well may have qualified if he had to but
he clearly didn't have to and Magnus the
same and I just think that in eight
player world championship
four of the players predetermined
without having to qualify it is too much
so I agree with gottakovsky
totally yeah it just feels a bit much
um
and yeah I think we do have the position
that they're going to play
up on the board let's see if we can
bring that up yeah we do okay well
enough of the uh extracurricular
conversation but here we see that
there's a queen in the corner for both
sides you were saying that this
resembles chess a little bit too much
yeah it's well also the more annoying
thing is the last position did too so I
don't like how isn't it a one in nine
one in eight chance that the king lands
on E1 and of course it's there again and
then I also see the night I wasn't
didn't we have a knight on B1 or okay it
was slightly different but we had the
bishop on C1
and uh not on B1 as well so yeah it's
very very similar to the last one what
are your thoughts on uh
White's uh first move here
well I think you know you're right that
is quite similar chess you know it's not
like there are two Rooks in a row and
the pieces are all out of sorts but I'm
noticing these pawns that I'm gonna put
in red because those pawns are all
undefended which means that if you're
not looking out for them they can be
targeted and you could find yourself in
big trouble quite quickly but for
White's first move
maybe a g-pawn push just to open up this
bishop on H1 I typically like doing that
or playing in the center with D4 what
about you
I like what you're saying about the
diagonals so we have two we have the
queen in the corner of the bishop in the
corner and I notice a lot of the times
players like to open those up
immediately so I could also say B3 is
possible B3 B4
um and like I said g through a g42 I
don't love D4 by the way I don't love E4
either because I think
you might get hit quickly
uh along the diagonal that's just my my
feeling
okay that makes sense to me I mean I was
just trying to expand quickly while
shutting down your bishop and hoping the
Rook behind it was good enough but I see
your point that you are sort of it's
like a pierce a modern type of situation
where there's a bishop lurking in the
corner aiming towards the center so it
could backfire
wait I noticed a funny
ah no it's not so funny but I I still
laugh for you I'll laugh don't worry
um I like somehow I like B3 Bishop B2
here this is what I I think I would
I'm not so sure but it's the most
natural way for me
yeah I think I think that's good you
know
right
no I got you though I mean it makes
sense your Queen's in the corner you're
lining up the bishop you're forming a
kind of battery there with the bishop
leading the way and by the way we do a
player shaking hands so let's uh see
what's happened there's a ceremonial
first move and I think B3 it is
so we have
of course the Vintage acar move B3
that is likely to be played
and handshake and they're off
Jeffrey you're the prophet now
Daniel can take a back seat yes
yeah he's uh
he's kicked out for now but no Downy of
course
busy competenting the women's candidates
and he will join for some fun Fisher
random commentary in the near future but
B3 played by Hikaru and Jeffrey no move
from Magnus yet
yeah I'm surprised I thought you would I
thought you should respond with B6 and
after Bishop B2 Knight F6
and sort of we'll probably get a double
fiancado whoa wait a second
oh my gosh that is a huge move
wait wait did I see this correctly G5 G5
giving up the bishop in the corner
because the queen will get trapped over
there let's uh how is it getting trapped
Queen takes how is it getting trapped
Queen h8
Knight F6
Queen G7
right only move Rook g86 only move
and are you kidding me just this are you
kidding me you push the d-pawn oh my
gosh
oh my gosh who came up with that Peter I
don't know if it's Peter or Magnus but
either way Hikaru Nakamura is caught by
surprise because G5 on move one not what
you expect when there's a queen on A1
just to put that position back here
there's a queen under one making it seem
like the Jeep on push is impossible the
bishop is hanging in the corner but the
queen bites off more than it can chew if
you take it Hikaru looks Disturbed so I
think
Jeffrey if I'm a Karu and I'm caught you
know in this kind of situation I may
just try to stabilize that is the
priority now
that would be the natural reaction yeah
something like Bishop B2 take take and
play get a normal game but I am still
I'm blown away right now that's an
insane level of creativity to even
consider the move G5 I love it right do
not have engine consultation they were
not studying this with the computers
which could show G5 they had to find
that on their own just talking uh before
this game started so one more time Queen
h8 free Bishop but the queen is not free
because after these series of moves the
queen only is G7 Rook G8 The Rook is
defended the queen can only safely go to
H6 and then once d-pawn pushes you've
taken away the H3 square at the end of
the diagonals the queen is in fact
trapped on H6 What a fine by Magnus and
his team
that is nuts and can we go around the
horn quickly while Hikaru still I mean
he has to take a second to
to respond to this let's see what are
the other openings
um so we have
let's which would you should try to
choose whichever matchup I feel like
going yeah yeah it doesn't really matter
I'm just curious all right like imagine
we see okay yeah this is more what I
expected you have something like B4
negative six somehow in the next round I
feel like more people will play G5
because they saw Magnus do it but here
in Knight F6
very normal stuff and this one castles
and D3 so I
like Black's position at first glance I
mean this setup here
looks like it's not great for Wesley
well it reminds me of a nifold and
usually in this type of uh
I mean sort of set up white likes this
double in keto and sort of
playing on the queen side later maybe
he'll go for C4 but as of now he's quite
a bit behind in development so maybe
some concrete
uh problems to solve for Wesley
yeah because his night now is on the rim
over here Queen A5 check at some moment
could be a nuisance that the bishop for
now can block that check uh so B5 is
defended that's the most important thing
that Wesley has just done here and maybe
it's shaky but honestly most fish at
random positions are shaky out of the
gates
yeah there is upside here for Wesley if
you get Bishop g293 castles you're
actually going to be much much better
um because this diagonal the control
over the diagonal is is huge and black
won't be able to stop C4 so it means
that nodevec needs to come up with
something Concrete in the next two three
moves
yeah maybe he'll have to start with C6
just to make sure D5 is extra defended
while putting pressure on B5 but yeah
you're right that maybe in the long run
C4 will break open the position
favorable for the bishop on H1 so let's
keep going down our list of games here
uh nobody back in Wesley that will be an
important match to follow we have
gretzarsen taking on John the Palm
machine both those players lost their
Opening match and Yan gets the white
pieces in game one and all right this
has a little bit more normal development
yeah Jan opting for the Queen's Pawn
opening here oh he started with G3 okay
so then D4 D5
he he made the mistake Jeffrey of
listening to me
[Laughter]
um yeah I I was gonna say this looks
kind of like a pedestrian approach to me
well with no cars speeding by the
pedestrians get the right away and maybe
he's happy just to play this one slowly
there's a knight on a C6 this can become
like a Catalan with this bishop Fincher
here and with a knight on C6 you have to
watch out for a timely C4 not yet of
course right A6 is interesting
immediately attacking on D4 Knight of
through logical response and I guess
no he did I don't think he can get away
with E5 here so assuming I'm just
assuming that Black's gonna finish his
development on the Keen side as well
yeah then go ahead and Castle there's
also maybe Queen C8 and Bishop H3 and
trade off this Finn Kenner piece I like
that question
yeah I like that idea
this bishop can also slide into E4 at
any moment because there's no Knight
coming to C3 to kick it out so I feel
like actually officially before I might
walk right into Knight B5 and it's not
venturing back but the point is with the
Knight on the rim there's more central
control for black
yeah I like both bishv4 and queen C8
let's take a look at our last game
ferrosev
playing against bluebum okay pulling
that one up right here and we see this
looks like the Wesley so game against
abdusitara for colors reversed
indeed it does it looks exactly like
that no uh not
wait does it yeah because
didn't well I guess there was a
Knight on F6 for Abdus Atari so he
didn't get G6 as well
yeah but anyway the position on the
board yeah I like the way blue bomb is
is handling this
yeah just getting us up to speed pretty
standard well as far as Fisher random
goes standard approach from Blue bomb
here and is White gonna play A4 just
like abusive Target no he plays C4
instead
yeah it was between one of the two
bricks
I like C4 it feels a bit more right
because A4 B4 maybe was annoying and uh
you'd be left with the backward C Pawn
so C4 and now as blue bomb how do you
react you naked you or do you ignore
I think you take it I think you just
trade and then continue normal
development Knight F6 castle out of
there and black is doing quite nicely
white sauce like G3 and then actually
you don't need pledge either you can
Castle right away but at some point you
will play G3 to open up your Bishop on
the long diagonal and I feel like black
is quite solid for the time being so
um nothing to write home about but
seemingly a good start for Bluebell and
let's jump right back because Hikaru has
declined Magnus to spawn sacrifice and
now is sec I think he's offering one
himself
whoa so we last left off after move one
with G5 and now we're here we lost with
E4 you see on the bottom right
underneath me and Jeffrey the queen and
Bishop are aligned
against that pawn E4
why can't he just take let's just see
how this happened B3 G5
trade of Bishops sure b60 okay so no you
can't you can't do the same thing that's
the problem is you can't play your G
Pawn because the queen will get out I'll
show that later but F4 G4 and he's not
allowing hikara to play E4 without
giving up a pawn so a car does that and
Magnus is now a pawn ahead
but I actually kind of like this working
car because he's gonna get G through a
Tempo opening up that lawn diagonal and
then I think he's gonna castle queenside
and try and find counter play on the E
file
but black will Castle kingside right so
of course black won't capture
yeah with the bishop inside yeah King
side
King side with your Opana G4 really King
side Jeffrey I'm not afraid
Queen side there's a bishop chilling on
H1 right well but I think you can cut
you can uh play C6 or something
hmm maybe I don't know that felt okay
we'll see maybe maybe
but I'm going 92.
all right let's play some moves because
I'm curious how this
goes so 92
Knight F6 or
sure
yeah let's go there sure
G3 LG play G3 yep
I'll go back this way
okay Castle along
oop
castle that way I was in Castle short
but maybe you have a point that D5 can
just be played and then Castle this way
as well
well it takes some time is the problem
like you're gonna have to get the night
out too
yeah but why wait why don't you yeah
yeah yeah yeah try try your Castle
why is it so shocking is it that risky
I mean okay let's go Knight D4
I love how Jeffrey and I are just
playing now
um
okay D5 let's say yeah I just sort of
want to see what happens hmm
no this is really interesting I love
what we've gotten from these two gender
knots I really yeah no it's one of those
Pawn sacrifices that you feel should
give you sufficient counter play but
then you start calculating you have to
find an actual path because the moves
that we've just shown are very natural
moves and this King does look a little
bit open on G but black has all these
pieces covering it the Queens on the
wrong side the bishop is shut down by
Black's pawns and you know you can play
H3 but I may even take that thing over
there and you're not really opening up
the king side quickly enough
yeah
so Magnus
thank you yes sir oh much appreciated uh
oh yeah sir
oh come on you guys were hanging out so
you now know exactly how yasu is gonna
think at his approval where now I feel
like I'm banished if Yasser doesn't yeah
you're getting games whoa G3 oh my gosh
I love that move from Magnus
that is such a stellar move he just
gives away the pawn and says this bishop
on H1 is not even like a pawn like it's
just can't get out
so we've seen
three Pawn sacrifice so far might we see
a fourth I think G4 looks very logical
so we saw a bishop sacrifice
and then yeah these Pawn Sacramento is
here and you're saying G4 would be
reasonable but I don't think
I think I just saw
wait a second no he played G4 you have
to play G4 yeah Knight takes G4 very
quickly the response and then he's
retreating his Queen after the bishop
attacks in the center so
Queen E6
getting on the Bishops
View
and now you're definitely not castling
kingside so I agree with castling long
for black
yeah and it's actually not that easy for
white to Castle
because Bishop 3 runs right into Knight
H2
oh good point
this is a tricky little night Fork over
here
so can if White Castle's Queen side
how's black going to that is the move
yes so I take on E2 and you want what
honestly no I'm gonna be honest I just
didn't see that the Knight was hanging
it somehow works out but I I'm being
completely transparent didn't realize
that the Knight was hanging and somehow
this is good for white
wait there must be something beautiful
hold on yes right there
okay but how is it working exactly so I
go Queen B5 let's say
yeah
this this much I can do
oh
nice that's that's Checkmate because my
Bishop covers D5
yeah
he did it on purpose I did that by
accident just to be clear
I appreciate your honesty but now wait a
sec how many sacrifices now are we at is
that fine
My Sacrifice counter has been turned off
so you're gonna have to calculate for us
man I love when these two get together
like I remember there was a grab game
where it was like eight they played an
A3 G5 game now we get this just so fun
this is awesome and it's only move 12
right this would only be able to happen
in Fisher random and queen takes E2 is
off the table
I get it Yasser says that
um black is not going to Castle kingside
all right we know yasser's the goat I'm
here for it I respect Yasser a lot we're
good friends I just don't need to be
reminded that I was incorrect
wait let me ask you over over under 10
sacrifices in this game how many did you
say we're at already actually 10 might
be a bit High
let's go let's go with eight over under
eight sacrifices we're at five
I'm going with the
under
you're going under okay you're going
over I can tell no I'm going exactly
eight okay
so you just want to push
um well you should give me you should
give me a good good odds for that right
an exact number
I'm not really you know gambling
all right next game let's see
oh well so this if not Queen takes E2 by
the way is black and just Castle
uh
wait I for some reason I forgot castling
was legal I thought you had to move the
Knight first but it is legal yeah you
can just white just did it so it's only
fair Magnus can do it in response
aha
yeah I mean it looks reasonable my only
concern is how are you going to develop
your knight on B8 well he won Queen F6
so it's kind of a
moot point in a way
he's saying I'm up a pawn let's trade
Queens
yasser's taking the over on the eight
sacrifices by the way all right so we
got three different that's and uh he's
gone Knight C3 so no Queen trade for
Magnus
yeah it's hot it would've been very
surprising if hikara traded Queens
because he'd just be down to pawn with
compensation I'm not gonna say otherwise
but why enter that Queen this position
his whole point was to get an attack
against the King by the way there are
cool checkmates Jeffrey
um if you castle inside it doesn't work
because Queen takes B2 is check so let's
not play Queen takes B2 for a second I
don't know what I can play like whatever
some random move and that's Checkmate so
I'm just pointing out that the bishop is
an absolute sniper from the corner here
cutting off the Escape score in B7
yeah these mother made ideas can can
occur in in some really
funny ways so 96 was played
and now
yeah I feel like a core has to prove
something maybe is Queen A3 an idea here
just try to get that Queen off the board
I think black will shut that Queen down
with A5 also maybe 93 would be a move oh
Jeffy with the tactics
although if I'm being honesty I'm
thinking about more sacrifices after
that move but I don't know if it works
so like Queen A3 93 Jefferson points you
distract the pawn for the knights
defense and I was thinking that in a
position like this
at some point I wanted to have like a
rook takes D7 but I know it's not gonna
pan out maybe like a king B1 though like
a king B1
oh my goodness look at this you just
you're enlightened
King B1 is amazing because you have
Knight D5
Oh you mean here no no I meant after
takes takes whoa but you're saying this
works wait you said you said Kingman so
I I was listening to you oh wait show
this Knight F1 Knight D5 Queen D6 takes
or wait do you you take it right you
take take
and now that's mate so it has to play Ed
and now how do you there might is there
just rookie one Fe or 95 I see
and this night's under attack there's a
Checkmate thread over here actually
maybe even take this Knight first or
something or this Pawn like everything's
kind of hanging
yeah that would have been awesome
so Rook D1 though was played instead
also very logical
right
going for the open file for this Rook
Castle's Queen side
and I guess now it's time for Queen A3
with a double attack of the a pawn and
the E Pawn
Bishop takes C6 available at some moment
oh yeah I couldn't resist playing Queen
A3 also like in the future you know
Queen A6 Knight B5
for sure that looks like a nasty little
Checkmate attack
although don't move the Knight to B52
yeah yeah you got you need a king B1
move uh do you know which very famous
game ended with the Knight moving in
Queen A1 checkmate
ah can't say I do
it's a Ludwig versus logic
okay I don't mind not knowing that sorry
to these guys but whoa whoa you should
you have not studied your Classics do
you at least yeah you're right you're
right okay next POG Champs I'm gonna
study every single game do you at least
know the xqc most critical game the most
famous yeah Queen F2 yeah sure okay just
make sure you know some of your Classics
some Classics yeah
okay okay
yeah this one's really fun but let's
show let's show some other players some
love what what else is happening
okay
so hikara looks like he's about to move
but we'll come back to this game we have
given a lot of attention wait let's go
to the
oh uh sorry sorry wait I think my board
was wrong but the Wesley game
let's just have a look
okay
whoa what is
E4
what is happening in this game
I have no idea
so first question you have either Bishop
C3 or Rook F6 which one do you go for
uh probably not rotates F6 because I
don't like walking into pins so
fair so Bishop C3
played that wasn't even me that was
Wesley oh
okay
and now what is notorbeck's idea
aren't you just in huge trouble if
you're nerdy back here
I think maybe he wants to just take a
night night bd7
just to defend this way
yeah cause like you'll give up The Rook
uh the two pieces for Rook but you have
compensation on the e-file D file
everywhere
so I'll just show that the point is that
in this position you can get
two minor pieces here
for The Rook two knights for this Rook
um this gives black chances I think this
is not another question so let's see if
uh
he takes D3 was played first so I just
gotta take back
and maybe there's some kind of rookie
eight stuff as well for black
oh yeah that could be interesting so
C takes D3
and now
you want to try Rook
Rook FEA no but I think this is bad
there's so many problems in this
position like if I take here
and you take an E3 can I just like
defend my knight somehow
yeah because your queen at night are not
not uh in the game yet yeah if you play
rookie you know Bishop E4 cutting off
your second Rook from the attack no this
is this is bad news
so what else is there I guess it is
Knight bd7 right I don't or I mean you'd
probably take take diabetes yeah yeah I
think he'll play Knight B27 just hope
that he can
give a bit of material yet still hold
the game but it's not looking very good
for nerdy back his position was great
out of the opening but it's more about
Comfort than it is about you know a
evaluation because you don't have the
engine at your disposal and you have no
idea the wackiness that the position
has
but Wesley he's opted for Rook D3 which
is somewhat surprising
okay so just offering a trade
I guess
there's still this issue of this Knight
and F6 right so more trades might help
white at least yeah I guess it makes
sense in a way maybe he just wants to
collect material and and not have to
worry about
lack having much uh of an attack
I respect that
think it uh
you know his life is getting easier well
nordi Vex life is getting more difficult
thanks to this Knight being pinned and
hanging on F6 no this is not very good
for the Uzbek teenager
yeah critical moment here let's go ahead
and jump I there maybe
Federal save that's check-in okay let's
go over there photo save has the white
pieces against Matthias blue bum so we
will
head to that one and whoa Federal save
early on made this with C4 that's where
we left off so we'll just go through the
moves
Knight D7 Knight D2 both players is
developing and D5 that's the whole
reason you put your Pawn on C4 so you
can push to D5
and then G4
here's threading G5 winning a piece so
H6 was necessary
the brute force method Jeffrey
I like it
isn't it hard to stop G5 yeah that's why
blue bump did it himself
and then
greedy greedy photos knows yassers in
the chat so he goes Pawn grabbing
although wait I guess Rook G8 is coming
to maybe oh no he's gotten oh Knight A4
first okay
yeah I guess Rook cheese met by Knight
E4 they're still
problems on this diagonal so yeah Knight
A4 and C5 just trying to open the
position up
and so black is down a pawn
and
what does he have to show for it a worse
position
yeah that Bishop on D4 is doing a lovely
job dominating the Knight on A4
dominating the now on F6 that can't move
either due to the PIN
looks really good for white
yeah I'm not sure what black can do
actually
you can't Castle kingside you just move
your rook and I don't think you want to
Castle Queen side
although Jeffrey let me ask you a
question what's White's next few moves
um I think you could go either like
Knight B3 you could play Knight F4 you
could play Knight F2 you could play Rook
H1 there there should be moves okay so
you just told me a bunch of moves but
nothing that's gonna check me or you
know make me cry at least not on the
spot so I'm just trying to figure out if
black has some kind of helpful move to
counter I forgot to mention that there's
also G5 it has maybe a big threat okay
that actually really hurts
yikes
I have
I know I said Cass and queen side look
terrible but it does defend the bishop
on h8
yeah maybe if there's nothing
concrete on the B file you can get away
wait a second Rook C8
so online I would say maybe that was a
mouse slip for cast and queen side but
no they're playing in person
yeah probably not a slip I guess on G5
what does he want like some Queen E6 or
what queen D7
yeah but this is It's already looking
dicey I guess you're right G5
oh this looks so bad going after this
night
yeah I mean it's a piece it's a piece
you have to show what you want
G5
I don't get it
oh this looks really bad so phariseev in
the driver's seat in the second match
Let's uh maybe check back in on the hit
uh Hikaru position uh you know he's at
the white piece it's Magnus Carlson so
let's go back there because a lot has
changed and no semi-predictable way the
Knight on C6 was captured and the E7
Pawn dropped so in the last few moves we
saw Queen A3 A5 and yeah we more or less
consider this as being the likely
outcome
yeah some pretty
cautious play by both I think
this feels pretty level up Black
has an extra Pawn Island Maybe
maybe the weakness on H5 could give
white some chances later on but
as of now it seems uh
seems pretty even
I like for Magnus that he has these
pawns here I'm putting them in yellow
because it's like I'm not you know
they're good to defend against an attack
but they're bad in some end games but I
like the fact it's Pawn C6 takes away
squares from this Knight so that's the
good news
so how about I let me play a queen G5
here for white
are you just gone Pawn grabbing
yeah but I also spent way too much time
yeah guilty but look I I like Queen G5
yep there we go okay you are the hikara
Whisperer
you suggested B3 for the first move are
you hikaru's second you just you know
don't want to tell anybody that because
you're commentating
yeah working remote indeed you got me
but no I really like this move because
that Queen Once I put it on F5 it seems
like such a nice spot I don't know
you're just gonna hang out over here but
what if I play like rookie eight now
because you need your Rook to defend D2
aha
so can I just start taking over some
open lines
wait a second
okay I'm calculating this rookie eight
let's say take on E8
you wanted to
the camera people are zooming in on mags
is twirling very slowly twirling that
pawn there so that's funny but you're
saying
um
yeah rookie rookie Queen D2 King B2
rookie eight
something like Rook D1 Maybe
uh we'll uh bring up an analysis board
in a second here to show so you're
saying after rookie eight what roofs
give me a rookie alien yeah rookie eight
Queen D2 King B2
rookie 8 Rook D1
uh-huh yeah uh 93 is a threat that's why
I Rook D1
mm-hmm
and now
thing is if I go come after F7 like
Queen H2 protects H5 but then I go Queen
F5 takes F7 and I think I'm happy
but don't have like Knight E3 as well
what's Happening Here
oh that's nice that's a nice counter
attack
and this is what happens when we're
working through a variation you know
like seven moves deep and just trying to
figure out uh all the options like you
may think at the end all right it's just
fine but I don't know I just get the
sense that like Go On Queen G5 you're
sort of stepping away from your king but
maybe to rookie the simple rookie one is
good enough
but rookie one I didn't like something
wait what didn't I like there's
background yeah can you take take Queen
G1 takes
probably
yeah
okay
all right and you know Hikaru
he plays Queen G5 he actually
looks pretty relaxed well Magnus is the
one throughout this entire day so far
he's been the one who seems to be on
edge move after move
well I love that look there was a very
brief shot we had with he had his arms
folded across and really mean mug
looking in the distance I wish Danny
were here he could tell us which uh
Hikaru number that was but yeah nice
look
he said he's mean Muggin you're just
such an NBA fan
well I wish we could get the shot again
I think you would agree with me I I
almost uncertainly would agree with you
because you're Jeffrey Jean I agree with
most things that you have to say
so you know there are a few times I'm
gonna have to pick an argument with you
but if you're telling me he's like John
Morant mean mugging over there I believe
you
oh wait let's go back to the blue bomb
game briefly because he showed what his
big idea was it's quite nice actually it
is nice okay the way you said it I was
worried that it was a blunder but he
gives up the bishop where was this uh
just a few minutes ago Rook C8 was
played Knight B3 and he moves his Knight
away because after Bishop takes h8 he
wants queen H6 with a double attack
so Queen D4 by photos save he wants that
Knight
and he wants it now
let's say okay let's say give you the
Knight I take on H3 first
because Oh I thought I had some
Perpetual but no you're your king runs
away but let's say yeah I make some
check
because why are you so happy about candy
too I'm not but I'm just playing the
moves that you're suggesting and walking
me through
the anointing here for black yeah go
ahead no does it hate this King on D2
what's it doing here
yeah I don't know but the one bad thing
about black is
you might think if it's a regular chess
game you could Castle but that Rook has
already moved a couple times
check out this move Knight takes C5
just playing down a piece like nothing
is happening because after Knight 65
maybe even Rook takes C5
and just uh yeah go after these two
pieces that are under attack
why not yeah
you're definitely gonna get your piece
back
yeah I feel like blue bomb he's some
somehow slithering his way back into
this
it's very strong player and he you know
made some mistakes in this game to
give Federal save the advantage but
right now uh blue bombs maybe his
biggest enemy is his clock he is only
four minutes remaining and it's a very
tricky position his King still sitting
on E8 just like whites sits on E1
true yeah that might be the biggest
problem for him because
I right now I
I'm
so unsure like for photo save his King
has nowhere to go so at the very least
it's not going to be easy to navigate
this no well not by the way John
napamshi looks things up a piece against
uh hero regreterson so let's go over to
that game because gretz our sin in big
trouble the Icelandic hopeful the
hometown hero
oh he's uh just down a piece
yeah and I think nepo he's looking for
The Knockout blow Queen F7 runs into
Queen C1 so maybe that's
the only hope for black
is that that big of a deal
like
Oh you mean you can just go like King F2
King he won he too okay yeah so I was
thinking just bring my king out and
bring like my king over here and block
your checks eventually
yeah Queen F7 played by Yanda Palm
machine
yeah he finds it and
I don't see
no there there's there's not much you
can do here
king of two play how did this happen by
the way
like we didn't really tune into this
game for a long time he just can't wait
no go back but go back I think there's a
very nice moment yeah Bishop H3 is a
beautiful provocation
because F5 was played because after E6
of the bishop takes C7
oh
[Applause]
wow what a ridiculous position seems
like yeah
just showing that fork wow Bishop H3 out
of nowhere
and then F5 so as you said creating some
weaknesses in the position and then once
the king gets safe it's a Black's king
that's in trouble over here
wait a second what G5 oh okay
E6 I guess was
and if black played E6
but like I'm worried about your Bishop I
go C3 yeah no the position is very bad
F3 is about to trap the bishop with
Queen C1 you're right uh this is
probably just lost so I guess there was
really no hope and that's why
gretcherson played G5 but that was just
a pawn that was captured and it didn't
really get any better
for him as White's pieces still
surrounded this bishop and trapped it
yeah so very nice
bounce that game here for nepo you
always wanna
um take advantage of your chances and
this is just a really convincing start
so young the Palm she wins this game
let's go back to some of our others how
is Wesley so doing it against nudibik
Abdul sitarov oh that one looks pretty
interesting there is a king that is
vulnerable on F2 A queen just entered
the position E3 is hanging A2 is hanging
oh I think he wants to take on E3 and D3
so he gave away Bishop for two pawns but
attacking this Knight Queen D1 check
things like that then that might be
trapped over here yeah look Queen D3
Queen F3 there's you can take on F3 and
go rookie three or rookie three
immediately so I think
you are I mean either way but I think
this is
less typical to see something like this
two people yeah yeah this sort of
horizontal lateral Fork but the big
question is Knight C4 so Knight C4
uh H5
what's going on Queen's overloaded good
call
how do you defend both E2 and C4
yeah I don't think you can so but wait
why is this equal then because I would
think black has a lot of material now
so once them into your account right now
so it's two Pawns in a rook for three
minor pieces so maybe white just gives
away a minor piece and then has enough
remaining but that's the only way I
could see this potentially being level
still
yeah so let's say BC
okay
uh I assume I have to take
but I take on C6
that's when my Rook somewhere right like
Rook
oh wait you could yeah made rookie six
because that Rook could join into the
attack
what a strange position
very
and if I take on A4 with the bishop
apparently the best move
um
yeah I guess wait a minute
if I consolidate with Bishop B3
no White's been starting to yeah
I agree and the engine also says white
slightly better so chances for sure to
hold for black but it's not going to be
a fun task that's for sure and only on
move 22 so seven to make so 22 moves
have been played so they're gonna have
to get to move 30 to gain five minutes
and the increment but let's keep
checking some of these other games while
we have a chance here
well those moves have in fact happened
uh but let's go back to Hikaru and
Magnus because last I just saw
Rook D5
this Knight is pinned everybody wasn't a
blunder
don't worry wasn't a blender rookie five
takes and now Hikaru has to figure out
how to capture back
yeah so first instinct you take with the
F Pawn
but then it's just probably just night
wait actually where do you go
let's go Knight G4
yeah oh this is funny that's really
funny actually and we see the players on
the board on screen is Knight G4 if you
take on F7 there's Knight takes E5 right
you take G right I take F3 and D2 is
hanging and uh black is more active
yeah I'd much rather be black uh in that
position
so but okay it might still be a draw in
any case it seems
it feels like it draws the likely result
in this position
like okay there's a way to just
liquidate I think like Queen E5 probably
we'd see takes takes Knight D7 or G4
take on F7 take on E5 Rook H7 shake
hands
oh
yep that shakes hands a different way
when you
Mouse slipper yeah this is just
completely level
same material same side of the board uh
double Pawn not a big deal so I agree
with you this looks like it's heading to
drawville and that leaves us with two
other games
those two are really duking it out we
have Magnus on the big cam here
the organizers deciding to zoom in on
the world champion and there's Hikaru
Nakamura trying to win a world champion
of his own here in Fisher random chess
yeah and he has let's see he's taken
with the queen so I assume we're getting
this line
I think this forces the piece off the
board as you were indicating and wait
there's a move
oh hold on
Queen D6
I feel like that's such a Magnus move
yeah
Queen D6
no nor was I queen of five yeah I think
it's still just very balanced though
and you know we see the
players very concentrated and the queen
D6 is one of those moves that just
caught me completely off guard because I
was certain there'd be a trade of pieces
as you were calling for it looked like
it was a certain draw at that point but
Magnus was Queen D6 the car slides over
the evil Bar says zeros with a player's
faces suggests this is still a fight
that's honestly what Magnus does it's
what I love about Magnus he finds
seems like he always finds a way to keep
the game going
right and uh this is
a position where
in all reality it still is very even but
I'm looking at the clocks as well just
making sure uh that the players have
enough time they do in fact have enough
time just to see what move it is sorry
Queen after Queen F5 here it's a move 25
so yeah plenty of time for these speed
demons
yeah maybe we jumped to somebody in time
travel is is blue bomb in time time
pressure
let's go over there too because blue
bomb and Vladimir photos save that game
very interesting the whole way through
and we see 24 moves have been completed
the last move was Queen back to H6 and
what's the material count Jeffrey whoa
okay a bunch of moves just
came in at once
okay yeah so a mass update so he has
wait wait a sec he has 25 seconds but
two more moves to make so he should be
okay
okay but the position is looking very
good for fedo SEO still uh you have this
Rook on H1 let's work on B1 a nice open
files The Rook on G8 not as strong as
the counterpart on H1 uh the king for
white looks nice and tucked away the A7
Pawn can probably just be captured right
now
so all good news for fair to save
looks really really good for him I don't
see a problem
um
I believe I would just take the pawn
Jeffrey I'm not sure about you but A7 is
hanging on the spot
oh yeah I'm so sorry I got some phone
call just now uh yeah so
I I was thinking Rook H7 for white
oh you're getting aggressive
yes basically
um
indirectly yeah preventing Knight takes
D4 and I think I just have a lot of
pressure
yeah it's not very pleasant either is it
I mean why is so many active tries here
and
off the side I saw that Magnus nicara
traded their Queens so likely
heading towards that split point that we
have been
uh predicting so
this game no move yet from federal sale
but blue bomb down to 25 seconds for a
couple moves with the worst position I
like what fedosave is doing here Jeffrey
it makes a lot of sense to me to sit and
think in this specific moment rather
than rushing because bluebound will make
the time Patrol
yeah absolutely if you can force
bluebonn to maybe find
one or two really difficult moves
that might be
just uh you know an impossible challenge
so you're spending some time here maybe
gonna
I think he's gonna try and make uh blue
bombs life difficult here in the next
two moves while Yasser just says take
the pawn
so this is not even featured chat this
just featured Yasser at the moment but
Bishop takes A7 is yasser's suggestion
surprise surprise
yeah gift me the pawn and actually Rook
B6 would then be a threat okay but okay
Queen D7
he took it and then moves Bishop to B6
and now A4 A5 keeps that Bishop nice and
safe and time control has been reached
at least for federusev this is move 30.
blue bomb needs to find a move here to
get five minutes he plays King F7 and
now I love your Rook H7 check move
that one felt dicey I thought you should
go Rook A8 or something
but now on Rook H7 I guess he wants Rook
cheese
just to try to block it and then Queen
H6 threads Queen H5 check
oh that looks so scary
yeah I don't like this
like check here Queen H6 this is a mate
threat Queen H5 and Ricochet which
probably means you have to take
on uh yeah at least you can defend with
your knight momentarily but but now you
have a passive Knight over here not what
you want yeah Bishop B3 Maybe
now this is bad very clearly bad with
white playing on all sides of the board
and Black's King in worse shape
and I this is it's kind of funny
that when
I'm used to like when a player makes
time control that means like nothing's
gonna happen but they still only have
five minutes yeah I like the unusual I
like the fact that they're just
constantly in time trouble they might
not like it but I do
um let's quickly go over to the game
between Wesley so and nobody pick up new
sitarov much has changed we were
assuming a position like this would
happen but let's go over to that game
where now it's two minor pieces for Rook
uh the black king the white king neither
King particularly safe but I'm starting
to like the minor pieces and I believe
you were clamoring that white should be
much better right now
I feel like if Wesley's able to
coordinate his pieces in an ideal way
it's going to be really hard for black
to do anything right you're sort of just
crowd around your king and then start
pushing the a pawn coupled with the
pressure on F7 black doesn't have a way
to to get counter play of its own
yeah F7 is such a Target here
um this A2
Pawn going to be great in the end game
here with the Queens on the board black
has more chances so if you trade Queens
the game's over like black just loses so
what Nordic is going to try and do here
and they have past move 30 smooth 33 so
they have the five second increment with
every turn
he's gonna try to play music Rook F6 and
go after this King and say you don't
have time to push this past Pawn with so
many pieces on the board
yeah now that he's probably gonna get
his Rook on F2
so
it's still yeah it's still very tricky
of course
The Rook needs to stay defending F7
That's essential because as soon as the
Rook leaves there's
all sorts of threats to go after this F7
Pawn so I think black is going to stay
put so then white has to prove how he's
gonna win
yeah and white will also I think White
he needs to figure out a way to push the
a pawn but the risk of that is
by pushing the Avon you no longer have
like the B3 Square for the bishop and
maybe black will find a way to create
some threats yeah you need your knight
to play so I'm already thinking Knight
F4 to shut that Rook out and maybe try
to get Knight D5 in
um black is kind of stuck black is going
to shuffle May Rook F5 Rook F6 or some
kind of queen B6 Queen C7 Queen C5
Queen's going back and forth but King is
on D3 unless they bring this King into
the middle of the board
thank you
so it's a pretty big decision there uh
from Wesley
oh wait
sorry
um
let's quickly jump back to
okay as we see Magnus and hikara
repeating moves
but I wanted to jump back to the blue
bomb
yeah well they just agreed on that draw
it is in the books no surprise there so
good game from
Magnus and acara and you say you want to
go to bluebound game
yeah because there are quite a few
developments bluebum he achieved D5
which I think is
pretty or sorry uh E5 rather so he's
sort of reconfigured in a way where he
has a nice Center at least but
what exactly does that promise I don't
know
well it does not promise the black king
any safety whatsoever there's a rook
still on the B file and the H file Queen
Bishop outside pass Pawn
this feels completely winning and yet
the engine only says Plus almost two
yeah I mean it seems
nearly impossible to to hold on just
because of the open files but he's
trying E4 yeah he played E4
so so wait is this idea after f e
what does he want
maybe D4 and but he doesn't have all
this stuff because it's King on f7's
yeah there's there's always a rook H7
lingering
but maybe that is his idea like uh let's
say fu4d4 and
what do you what do you play there
um
good question
because Rook H7 I go Rook G7 okay so
let's start analyzing this we're saying
Fe D4 where are you moving Bishop to D2
okay yeah let's say Bishop D2 Knight C5
and you have a point then you said Rook
H7 there's
Rook G7 to block that
there's also been white pawns key
oh oh my God you devil
wait what is this oh my goodness you
take my queen I take yours a check I get
your rook and of course it's just even
answer all end games
yeah that is a really nice spot let's
see if I mean it's very easy to walk
into that because then you're forced to
go like Queen H3 but
all of a sudden it seems like Knight E4
comes with checking like in the line
Rook H7 key
yeah Knight takes E4 check and your King
has to go back to E1 I assume
yeah and now is Queen G4 oh you
you are seeing checkmates everywhere
maybe I'm yeah I'm first in this line
wow that's actually nasty
so that means okay you should probably
go like Queen f
we have three or you give a check
yeah Queen F3 makes sense
because you also at some moment might
have a queen F5 if Black's not looking
out for it but Queen F3 Queen E6 is
going right after E4 pawn and A2 is
hanging in some positions
this is messy
very messy but this black Nano and C5
does a great job also covering on B7 so
that allows you the flexibility to play
Queen E6 and basically attack all of
White's Pawns woof
so I think Federal Sav is going to
regret allowing this kind of counter
play and I'm just quickly looking
keeping an eye out on the other game
between Wesley and nerdybeck I see a
bunch of shuffling happening not
necessarily A
clear winning attempt for Wesley just
yet so we'll keep on this game for now
and I will
continue to scout the other one and
federal Sam he's always on the camera I
feel like there are three players that I
focus on Magnus Hikaru and fedexev
yeah no one else worth worth of luck but
okay queen of I'm trying to trying to
find a move after Queen F3 Queen E6 like
maybe I play something subtle
I feel like a king E1 is always going to
be useful probably because you're trying
to move this Knight without it being
checked so you have Rook B7 I see what
you're going after Queen F3 he has in
fact played
blue bomb here on the clock
trying to figure it out
Queen E6 is so logical
it is there's also but there might also
be like Rook uh C8 that's another way to
come after the pawn
true
very direct
yeah a lot of a lot of options here for
black
I think Queen G4 is not a move though
Queen G4 Rook H7 no that's clearly bad
just allowing The Rook to Infinity you
know what's interesting Jeffrey the move
E5 for white like Queen E6 I'm already
looking at E5 type of ideas aha
could be very dangerous and I don't have
it here because you cover the seventh
rank just to show everybody what I'm
trying to talk about is a rook B7 check
would be really dangerous and maybe
actually it is because I can take here
and after Rook C7 I have Queen B3
whoa whoa wait this is incredible
geometry wait
Ah that's nice yeah I was just trying to
say E5 is interesting I didn't actually
work through this I'm seeing the eval
bar off to the side and it's being like
you're winning so thank you eval bar but
the point is that this king is very
okay but I'm very curious suddenly so if
I played King E6 instead of Rook C7
what what did you have
just oh I have no checks I have no
checks okay
so but anyway let's let's go to the
light board because they played a few
moves so Rook C8 case
G5 was the choice but
apparently it's plus seven if not G5 is
still good but there's a move that was
completely winning so G5 is still plus
about four
yeah I'm trying to understand
oh yeah he just wants to open the the
line for the queen yeah Knight takes G5
runs into Bishop G5 and then Rook B7 at
the end
oh that this looks devastating
is there even a mouse yeah I was about
to say the same what
wait can I play
um I was Queen D5
I mean D5 centralized the queen
centralized the queen they could be like
Rook H7 and queen H5 check I think
that's gonna be an issue yeah that's
winning for white oh God so just to show
everybody Rook H7 the rookies on this
queen H5 check and yeah the king's
getting mated
this is bad
so
has he found a move
he's thinking and we can see he's
getting quite low on the clock
is Matthias bluebound
so
White's pieces are basically rushing in
from all sides like Rook H7 Brook B7
maybe bishop B4
and there's twilling with pieces but
he's got to move he's down
but there's no news on the clock what do
you play I don't see even okay Queen C7
he won Queen C7 but I think Rook H7 is
lights out
most likely yeah you you win a rook with
check
yeah feather save sees it
uh there it goes Rook page seven Here
Comes Queen H5
very nicely done by feta save
yeah key one key one was actually a very
classy move just kind of taking a second
to get out of the way of Black's threats
and then you just cash you know you just
crash through
it's pretty amazing because just when we
were suggesting look at this all of a
sudden blue bomb fighting and playing E4
and D4 and the game is over but that's
what it was like it was like okay
suddenly chances and federal Sav says
nope no chances for you and he takes
this game one in the second match which
leaves us with one game remaining
between Wesley so and noribeca busatarov
they're only 46 moves into this game
it's gonna last like 146 more
could easily and
the king it marched all the way back to
Age Two wasn't it on C2 it was it went
up this way and then it ran over to
E2 and then went that way
I so okay
yeah Jeffrey I'm gonna say something and
you can either back me up or tell me I'm
wrong so those are your two options
I feel like
white should not be able to make
progress if black shuffles precisely
but shuffling precisely is difficult
when you only have a minute 15 seconds
left
yeah I feel like that's very accurate
yeah
um but I like the
I think he's going to put his Bishop on
G2 and then
and then finally push the a pawn
so get the bishop around that way
because the one thing that white needs
to avoid is giving
the black rook and infiltration Square
so
that makes a lot of sense
you see our featured chat there Tommy
Shelby Kings have to get their 10K steps
in
yeah got to be healthy
yeah so once again we see Wesley
grinding out an end game this one's
slightly different it's it's quite
unique this sort of Bishop and Knight
against Rook with the far Pawn
and look at that move by the way
abuse Tower plays Queen D4 offering a
queen trade saying you're not gonna beat
me with the Queens off the board because
the Rook is too active and will fend off
this past Pawn
yeah this is a very critical moment I
feel like
yeah it's so hard for the bishop Knight
to escort
um the a pawn in that in that end game
so he goes Queen C2 instead
mm-hmm
he was kind of holding that piece for a
while he was dragging to C2 wasn't
completely sold on it but he needs to
keep pressure on the clock and by the
way there could be a queen G6 tactic
yeah it was just he was about to play
Rook A7 which I think is okay because
you attack A2 although okay he goes
Queen D2 instead
okay you need to keep Queens on the
board so Queen
Queen
I don't know
there's so many yeah
okay Queen B3
looks reasonable I'm wondering Jeffrey
if at some point black can like
sacrifice in exchange
on F4 yeah like if you can win F like F4
and also A2 that's a dead drug but right
I'm not sure you'll be able to
so okay Queen D4
oh Bishop C6 there's Queen F2 Queen F1
kind of stuff
but you can always defend it with your
knight so you're very safe
right drop your knight back to G2 and
then
try to get this Pawn going I think
Wesley's doing the right thing it just
so happens that nordibec is an amazing
Defender right now
yeah but I think there's been some
progress I like
I mean okay the pawn moved up to squares
but also this Knight on G2
it's it's super uh super safe
Queen D2 check played King H3 there's no
other check after that move so you have
to worry about safety and avoiding
checkmate
and Nordic down in a minute Wesley now
the same this is getting very tense for
these two
Wesley looks the clock looks back to the
board and he plays
PhD H3
and now under 50 seconds
what about Rook C7 here I'm trying to
line up some attack
looks reasonably Bishop back to G he was
working E7 I think you have rookie
similar yeah
Queen D5 is one option
all right so he's allowing rookie three
mm-hmm
it's not everyone is
Rook back to A7 so I think Nori back is
using the uh Bend but do not break
method just standing right in front of
that pass pawn and claiming no progress
can be made with the queen and Rook
covering A5
yeah and
I think he's probably right there's no
way through because you need your knight
to sort of assist
but then
your king lacks Defenders so
we probably see a little bit more
shuffling here maybe Queen B7 he plays
it now 96 check is a threat Bishop D5 is
also a pretty huge threat I think this
is the moment where noribbeck could go
wrong on the spot he was Queen C2 and
that's okay there's Queen F5 check
very nice move
wait but on Bishop E4 what do you do
Bishop E4 well I didn't have to answer
thank you Wesley for not making me
answer that question Wesley by the way
down under 20 seconds
yeah I mean but he's I think he's done
really well here this looks so tricky
for black
where's the king going up to F6 or back
to G8
I think he went back
G8 and after the check went to H7 check
on G5 King G7 over here
he's still safe somehow
unbelievable and after
Queen
Queen F4 this
is a queen nobody check
I'm sure the end game is good because
I'd take him to C6 yeah that's why I'm
asking I'm not telling you I think Rook
of five I think Rook F5 okay he's gone
the other check
okay he checks back here King back to
easy move
anything Rook F5 but no but then there
was Queen D4 so yeah Queen D7 is correct
so accurate here
such a difficult position Bishop C6
deflection beautiful take that you get
checkmated on H7 right away so you
cannot take he goes Queen E7 is this is
five oh you oh you imprisoned The Rook
for a sec but Queen D4 also it makes
sense because the end games are all
unpleasant
but F6 makes your light Square super
weak with both players down
well under a minute at this point and
Wesley not too much time on this clock
Knight E4 retreats
oh that looks like Rook E5 and you
better watch out if you're Wesley I feel
like if you keep trying to play for a
win you could oh it could go wrong yeah
and
oh man I wish we had the the full zoomed
in shot
because three seconds
with one second remaining the move
Knight to D2
rookie three Knight F1
yeah they're just Chase oh but that was
on the board right now that was very
smart by Wesley because at least he's I
don't think he can blunder now
right The Rook went to A3
mini four Rook a two King H1 played wait
why can't you trade Queens what's going
on here
oh wait sorry he played Queen C7
um Queen C7 not E7
yes Queen C7 when do you play Queen z7
this is okay the moves are now coming in
yeah they're coming in really fast
they got you know that's what happens in
these relays the technology sends them
all at once
trying to keep up as best we can here
and the queen is on C7 so there is no
Queen trade but G3 is hanging in some
positions
yeah I think nordebec
he's forced Wesleyan within this passive
setup with the Knight on F1
okay so King G2 is Wesley's choice
okay two does he want King F3 yes he
does
wow the king is running the Knight can
help out here
but now Queen D6 look out
yeah Queen E6 looks really strong trying
to Queen D1 check against this now
exposed King whoa and nordeback is just
banging out moves
it should be five Rook a393 I'm trying
to keep up with this it's no it's
impossible
still very solid for Wesley Queen E4
mm-hmm oh nervous you can see shaking on
his hands Queen C1 they allowing checks
but still should be okay
and there's five second increment per
move so the players
well from Wesley almost flagged earlier
but you should not be in danger of
flagging wait what did Wesley play is he
he allowed uh is his Pawn hanging or
there's yeah Queen H1 Bishop D3 Queen H1
and well that should seal it right
that's right yeah there's Queen F1 check
because the bishop on D3 is pinned yeah
I don't think you can risk it just King
F2 here
Wesley thinking what he goes for it
the queen F1 check
played King E3 that loves Rook take D3
check
yeah and what is oh but the king will
walk over so I don't think
look at that move very calm by noribbeck
I was looking at the Rook for two pieces
exchange and he says no no no let's just
make this repetition
and it looks like
this one is uh
yeah I don't think Wesley can can play
this for a win anymore
no I'm just checking him back and forth
and Wesley
thinking
and King F3 I believe that should just
be a draw
and wow handshakes
what a fight
and a huge save for Naughty by company
sitar Wesley so had the advantage for
something like 60 moves in that game but
when all is said and done nobody back
abducator of the world rapid Champion
the Olympiad Champion board one for
Uzbekistan he's a teenager but he is
pretty much a veteran in these time
controls
yeah I mean I was about to say this kid
is good this kid is tough but it he
doesn't seem like a kid in the way he
plays
seriously amazing stuff from noribbeck
Abdul sitarov he draws you know his game
against Wesley so you see the fans still
there they were watching the action live
the boards couldn't even keep up with
how quickly they were playing dgt I mean
I I don't want to say anything about
them but I gotta get it up to the
player's speed because these this day
and age the players are playing Ultra
bullet on these chessboards but
two wins one for you on the Palm Street
one for Vladimir ferrosev two draws in
the other games Wesley so
tarov Hikaru Nakamura Magnus Carlson so
Jeffrey with an exciting first game of
these second matches
how would you even possibly wrap up what
we just saw
oh man it's yeah this action was crazy
the one thing I'm thinking about at this
very moment is will will we see this B3
or B4 G5 Bishop sacrifice again dude the
players
will they have access to uh Madness
games and will they repeat it
it's a good question we'll see what the
players can work on during the break
they do not get to consult an engine
just talk to their seconds so we'll see
if that G5 move by Magnus is played
again and for the players who lost game
one if they can strike back but for now
uh you know we're gonna give a quick
shout out to our presenting sponsor here
for this coverage Brave
Brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess we'll be right back for
more from the Fisher random world
championship this coverage brought to
you by Brave
everyone GM Daniel narditski here we
asked the chess.com Community to show us
their best games from the cgc qualifiers
and we're here to highlight some of the
exciting chests that are awesome
community members cooked up in these
competitive cgc games now here we have
ckca who faces demoni 66 in a position
that looks pretty calm but watch how
quickly ckca goes after White's King
there's no Bishop on G2 the king is
exposed and boom goes to Dynamite he
starts by pushing his Pawn to H5 white
responds with an attacking move of his
own on the other side but black is
faster the pawn gets to H4 the queen
swings out to G4 and white thought that
he had everything covered with H3
pushing the queen away but no no no
Knight F4 check is a brilliant tactical
move using the pin against the Jeep on
forcing the king back eliminating the
pawn on H3 dropping the Knight back to
H4 and after H takes G3 White's King is
toast but ckca finishes it in style
there's many winning moves here but only
one sacrificial combination Rook H1
check and here demoni resigned because
after King takes H1 the queen drives in
to G2 with Checkmate what a lovely
attack from ckca and this has been GM
Daniel nerdinski with a community
highlight from the chess.com Community
Global Championship qualifiers
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
from the live venue in Reykjavik Iceland
this is the Fisher random World
Championship coverage of which brought
to you by Brave
Jeffrey Zhang and I on the call here I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess and Jeffrey
you're a super GM you know prizes these
days they're going up throughout the
events but the prize is there in
Reykjavik they are huge very substantial
it's great to see yeah chess has evolved
so much I think
we're very fortunate
um that we have so many great sponsors
nowadays and yeah like up top 150k
the first 85k I mean these are this is
life I mean it's huge prizes here it's
unbelievable especially for players like
you know Federal save and blue bomb just
to qualify their way through and have a
shot at that kind of payday it's really
great and and we were talking earlier
about
um
you know the invitees versus the
qualifiers uh it qualifiers give a
chance to players who are 26.50 very
very strong in their own right they may
not get the automatic invitation to the
vikon zays of the world
um and the sinkfield cups but still they
can put up a great fight and they're
doing just that today
right that's what I love so much about
the sort of qualif qualification anyone
can can make it pretty much and you give
a fair chance
so
yeah I hope okay we've already spoken at
length but I I hope that uh it's a bit
different next year because this is just
it's an awesome event
it really is and uh so far we have the
one match in the books and half of the
second match one game down here we saw
you on the palm she taked down uh the
Local Hero the Icelandic number one he
overstein gretzerson we saw Vladimir
farisaya play a very nice game with some
really brilliant subtleties uh against
Matthias bluebaum so phariseev leaves
one nil and then the other two games
those were drawn Jeffrey but we saw some
real fights
we did I mean especially that Wesley
game how long did it last like 80 moves
82.
oh my God just
brilliant Fighters
um I I really admire Notre pack I think
like okay not only is he an up and
coming Junior but every time I watch him
play he just shows such tremendous
fighting Spirit every single game
doesn't matter the position
and he seems in excellent form already
took down nepo and now has white against
Wesley so let's see what he can do
just
trying to punish his high rated opponent
uh because he didn't win that game one
where he had the better chances uh but
that's just how strong Abdul sitar has
become I think Jeffrey and you can maybe
talk about this as well when we talk
about these you know the future of Chess
let me back up to start one he's the
present he is really at the upper
echelon the elite level no questions
asked but I think people focus on their
nice wins and not in their great
defensive moments and to become from
2700 to 2750 and so on it's not just
about beating players in a few flashy
games you actually spend most of your
time digging deep and finding very
difficult moves in positions that look
bad for you
you're absolutely right the amount of
half points you can save with just more
tenacious defense I think that's what
separates players from let's say the
2650 low to really world-class players I
remember when I first became 2700 I
played my first syncflow cup jumped on
had I mean wrestled with these uh
these these legendary players anytime
the rare moments that I had chances they
would always sort of lock it down and
make it really hard for me to convert so
that is a it's a game changer
yeah and I mean one of the best players
uh in the entire world did just that and
two of them really in Magnus Carlson and
Hikaru Nakamura we actually saw in that
game against Federal Sav where Magnus
inexplicably blundered an exchange like
a shocking blunder for Magnus Carlson
and then it almost seemed like he was
the result was never in doubt there was
not even uh maybe a few moves at most
for federal Sav that he had an advantage
for because the advantage quickly went
out the window
that was honestly so crazy now that you
mention it when he played the move Rook
F7 to F6
it all of a sudden felt like there was
nothing he could do like I'm thinking
about it how do you how do you actually
try anything other than you did so seems
like that one mistake
cost uh cost and chances to to level
that match score
absolutely so uh Magnus Carlson Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so Nordic Abdus they
have the leads and their respective
groups uh the next round of action
should begin in a little bit but as we
just break it down a little bit more
here so group a
now if you made people choose group a
seems at least by the look of it like
the group you'd want to be in because
you have greterson who's a fantastic
player but he is the lowest rate the
rate of player in the field but quite a
margin uh you don't have Magnus or
Hikaru in there but you do have Wesley
and Jan and nordybeck so I feel like in
group b you might have the the two top
players and then in group a you have
numbers three through five
correct yeah I think yeah I absolutely
agree with you I would still I mean it's
hard to say like Wesley as the defending
Champion that dominant performance he
put up in LA
the last year's championship that he
would be worse than in Cora but my my
one concern coming in for him was you
know all of these tournaments lined up
he's obviously he's got the global he
just played U.S championship
he was a bit shaky there so
it does you know it takes a toll on you
it does and we have to remember the 2019
Wesley was the deserved Champion he did
lose one of those matchups in the
quarterfinals to Hikaru Nakamura so the
format was a little bit irregular in the
quarterfinal stage a couple players were
invited directly through to
um to the live finals or semi-finals I
should say and then six players were
taking part where like if you lost or it
was eight players yeah eight players but
if you lost you still had a second
chance match and it was a very
fascinating format that allowed Hikaru
to beat Wesley but Wesley to storm back
with two straight victories just to make
his way through to the uh live finals
but that's neither here nor there in
2022 Wesley so an absolute Force hiccard
Nakamura much the same and well let's
look at that finale from Hikaru and
Magnus in game one because we kind of
left off here Jeffrey we're Queen D6 a
move that did not cross my mind for
Magnus and he was able to hold the
balance
yeah I think Queen E5 uh was forcing
everything off the board but he wanted
to just play a few more moves and that's
exactly what we saw they played a few
more moves here but I think the result
was never really in doubt
and it kind of looks like white should
be slightly better Black's Pawn split
here doubled over here but not much
material remained so I think the pieces
were quickly just traded off where white
went ahead and won H5 for the G3 pawn
and this was obviously a drug with rook
and four rook and four so I think that
game very balanced through and through
the Wesley so abusadav game which we saw
go 82 moves that one was a bit more
one-sided and the sense that Wesley had
more chances but nordi Beck deserves a
world of credit for holding that game
and the next games should be starting
fairly soon so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to put a starting position back on
Jeffrey and based on what we saw if we
go back to you know literally move one
whose strategy did you like best and
what would you recommend for the players
here in game two
[Music]
very difficult question
um
yeah as I said
my initial impression was B3 felt right
to me but nepo and Wesley maybe or
federal save as well were successful
with I think they started with um
was a D4 G3 I know an episode with G3
but
let's say
yeah it was like G3 D5 D4 okay so I
don't know to me it still feels like E3
should be right because I think G3
I don't know if somehow it gives it
still gives off like uh
very quiet vibe to this position so
you're saying that Magnus is G5 not that
it was yeah okay a legitimate try but
you don't think it's actually sufficient
uh in the sense that white should still
be better
I was thinking about something
um so let's say start with B4
and I'll tell you why I'm starting with
this move in a second you go G5
now I want to play D4
so my whole point is that I avoid uh C5
from Black
because your Pawn is there covering the
square this one is pin but G5 is also
under attack
so I think I get a better version here
but the problem with B4 at least I think
is what happened in some of the other
games where after B4 I won't play G5
anymore instead I'll play moves like D6
and a quick A5 because it did seem like
nordybeck had a good position early on
against Wesley
right perhaps yeah you could say that I
wanna I wanna refresh my memory I I
don't
quite remember how photo say I've played
his game okay I got you covered don't
worry I got you oh what what Partners
here teammates all right D4 was his
choice and then B4 B5 was the response
okay
yeah this is also interesting I I
thought bluebum had a reasonable
position but better say if he handled
this really well getting in C4 and then
D5
yeah he quickly played D5 and then
suddenly things became a problem not
just for the piece on the diagonal but
their Adventure was this G4 G5 issue
that blue bomb could not successfully
deal with
yeah maybe the issue was he didn't see
G4 coming I think like if he plays a C6
here yeah that's like instead of Knight
C5 he was probably okay
maybe I'm not sure
no I agree with you and you can also
Castle because after G4 you can play
Bishop G7 and ah yes
yes this is uh
this is a good way to to deal with that
well this is how it was dealt with in
the end because uh that's Checkmate
against this King in a couple moves so
he resigned down a full Rook uh so it
was not a good finish there for
bluebound but the players are seated in
their chairs getting ready for game
two of their match bluebound needs to
win with the white pieces
um you know tie breaks who cares about
them at this point he has no choice but
to win his game if he hopes to move on
yeah big moment indeed and let me ask
you so Fisher random it's
it really gives you the freedom to be
creative who do you think has played the
most creatively thus far
oh
I might go with abdusitarov
oh really okay I wasn't expecting that I
liked his peace sacrifice in the first
match against Yan and even in this last
game the way he sort of played that
opening I felt like he was just going on
all sides of the board and who are you
gonna say
I was thinking along the lines of Magnus
or federal save
I think I mean magnus's G G5 like I've
never seen such a bishop set where you
sack a bishop you attack the queen twice
but it's not trapped there you make a
move to cover the Escape square like
I've never seen that
yeah no you're right neither have I but
it looks like a handshake has uh just
been done if I'm not mistaken if my eyes
don't deceive me Magnus did just play
the move B4 on move one against Hikaru
I think he's baiting G5 and he knows
that D4 will give him a good position
a D5 comes
so Magnus plays B4 D5 is the response
and it is interesting to see how the
openings
you know take shape because the players
they have not been able to look with an
engine after that game they're still you
know probably on edge when you're
remembering a game that just happened a
mere 15 20 minutes ago and then you have
to go right into game two with an
opening that you couldn't possibly have
studied
yeah although I imagine that Magnus at
least had some sort of
idea against uh D5
so he goes G3
mm-hmm
and now I can't I want to yeah I want to
somehow get what Wesley did but faster
like just get castled first and then
maybe develop the uh rest of the queen
side
right when Western went for with D3
Bishop B2 being put E4 or C4 I can get
behind that
um so what is the downside of playing
Knight F3
the downstairs Bishop H3 so I think you
usually would start Bishop G2 or as a G5
oh wait wait you're serious okay which
oh yeah yeah you're right because Bishop
is yeah yeah okay I'm trapping you again
it's like Knight F3 I was actually
serious can you play G5 Bishop H3 is the
Obviously good move but I'm just
wondering does G5 still working
yeah okay Bishop B2 is just a normal
response but G5 is still
an option
so I think Magnus will play Bishop B2
here
and I'm really wondering this might be a
bit much but would you consider F6
so you could play E5 next
yeah
doesn't seem like a bit much seems like
a completely reasonable choice
and yeah I mean well
I'm not sure uh certain Ben Feingold
would approve of that one but
we'll see I guess well Ben doesn't
approve a lot these days so uh you know
F6 just another one there and Bishop G2
was played by magnets here he wants to
play Knight F3 he wants to Castle you
know get his King out of the center but
he did not win a lot Bishop H3 which is
an important move
yeah and I like this approach so if A5 I
think he's gonna go B5
right just push this one up and if this
takes then D5 becomes a bit loose and
you know it's a temporary Pawn sacrifice
maybe it's a permanent Pawn sacrifice
but there's clear play for the pawn sack
well I think you go Knight C3
and hit both Pawns
uh in that case yeah I can't defend them
true so very quick way to regain upon
you give up one on B5 and then Knight C3
attacks both here and you can't defend
two at once so perfectly
legitimate play there and we see a very
focused tekoro
I think he's going to spend some time
here let's check out what the other
players are up to
okay let's uh
go on and look elsewhere
so which uh matchup should we look at
Wesley and nortibeck yes yes
okay let me pull that game up
where is that game oh there it is
so I was like are you sure oh okay okay
yeah yeah there we go I meant there it
is I need to click on it still
so
wait this seems very dry
very quick Castle from nordi back
hmm I mean if this wasn't Fisher random
I would think maybe they're making some
pre-arranged draw because after Knight
D4 CD
Bishop H3 let's say like this could
really just start liquidating
oh the black King's still in the center
so maybe there's an opportunity yeah but
I think I'm in time maybe bishop G7
Knight F6 yeah I'm with you because I
forgot for a second that you don't need
to move this before castling
oh wait but it's Bishop H6 oh wait
Bishop H6
okay maybe maybe you have to be a little
bit more careful you don't have to take
on D4
okay so you don't have to take on D4
um here so you don't take on D4 you're
saying yeah let's say you start with
either Bishop picture or Bishop G7 I
don't know if you want to flick that
move in
Bishop G7 because you're not afraid of
E4
which I don't think you should be you
actually have everything defended
yeah seems okay
but
I'm sensing a very conservative approach
by notabeck here I think a tied match
with Wesley
definitely or is not like a a bad result
in by any stretch
right no I think that notibeck is happy
to end day one with a one match win and
one match draw considering he beat
Beyond the Palm Tree and then would have
tied a match with Wesley so so I think
that yeah he's perfectly fine taking
zero risks even if that means a split
match
so should we uh keep on going since it
seems like Wesley is
taking his time
yeah let's check out blue bomb he's in a
must win spot
okay uh blue bomb and fedo save Matthias
gets the white pieces there
so here we go
okay so this one we've not yet seen it
looks like an English
so this looks at least a first glance
for me Jeffrey I don't know what you
think I like immediately like it for
white
uh did you play these like do you play
the English because it's sort of a
reversed close Sicilian in a way
um
I played the close Sicilian
that's why so whenever I don't know why
but whenever I play
like let's say I'm on the white side of
this I tend to get made it a lot on the
king side I'm probably doing something
very wrong
but that's why like I see this and I
start getting a bit traumatized
yeah if you're getting Checkmate on the
king side then something is definitely
going wrong for you
um but I guess with the strange or
unusual configuration of pieces there
are already plenty of threats in such a
position but I mean this is a very
obvious one a night Fork with a knight
to C2 what if white just moves the queen
and blueam does that very quickly
I don't think yeah maybe he wants to
does he want to play C5 so just get put
so he can push the C pawn and try and
consolidate with B6 maybe oh C6
I feel surprised by a lot of what's
Happening Here
okay E3 there's Knight B3 that's very
important correct
very important indeed so do you if you
start with B4 that Knight is a little
loose but maybe there's no way to take
advantage
like on C3 I mean
is awesome but what I was going to say
is E3 would win a piece if you had to go
to E6 because your Bishop gets uh
trapped here with E4
right
only square is H5 and then G4 and
finally the bishop is a goner so
there is the B3 Square for now so using
B4
either a way to take advantage of this
the answer is no
yeah and you have to be careful because
if white goes Bishop B2 next then E3 is
is a very serious idea
yeah white scanning space
I really do like the look of this
position for bluebum I think he should
be very happy in a must-win game to get
a position like this it's flexible he
has not taken any risks himself to this
point and what is Black's plan that's
the bigger question
agreed yeah I
oh I was gonna suggest like some E5
reconfiguring but you really the piece
is sort of start blocking each other
like if you have to go 96 as you just
highlighted your Bishop could get
trapped
so
yeah I don't know I guess we'll we'll
find out soon enough
I think something that FedEx will
consider after B for it is can you make
a smooth Knight F3 check
yeah you trade some pieces yeah so let's
say take but you helped me develop
that's why I wasn't too attracted by it
but maybe maybe he did just play B4 but
how would you respond to Bishop C3 I
don't think you want to trade Bishops
right like Knight D2 keep more peace on
the board makes more sense to me because
after Bishop D2 if we keep trading
things a white is obviously the side for
Choice with a good Bishop but in the
black Kingston Center but I feel like
too much has been traded and more can be
trade after Bishop H3
yeah you're right this was some sort of
weird obstacle illusion for me like I
assume Knight F3 was giving me tempu but
in fact it's not a big deal because
there's nothing going on in the position
you can even
just play a couple of times but but wait
he throws it out he throws it out the
window and goes D5
he just did it very quickly
it's what everybody loves about Federal
save the guy fears nobody he's willing
to mix it up in any position and I guess
to what the point you're making earlier
Jeffrey maybe he is the most adventurous
player here in the Fisher random World
Championship
yeah I I just want to show uh kind of
Cooperative line but let's say white
gets very greedy here takes on D5
takes takes with the Knight okay let's
say Rook D5
Bishop D5 Knight C2 King D2
you can do the honors here
checkmate
can't escape
yeah that would be pretty nasty
so yeah don't get too greedy kids
maybe I like uh
wait a second I was
trying to make something work but maybe
you just play a move like C5 here
for white just keep everything closed
but it feels a bit wrong I have to say
yeah I think you want tension right
because you can go for B5 it's almost
like you're playing it's a Carlsbad
structure but it's not the Carlsbad
structure uh he wants to take first and
Bishop B2 Maybe
yeah just bring the Rook
should be too
but what about this Knight F3 again
you mean you get maybe a better version
the queen everything off
Queen comes in
yeah I mean
there's
Knight F3 Knight F3 Bishop C3 probably
go Knight D2 and like
oh maybe Rook C1 is a threat in that
position
okay but what if I just I don't know
what do I keep trading things
so you take on B2 I take
you might be a bit worse I'm not sure
yeah maybe but I'm I'm I still don't
feel afraid even if I should
no you shouldn't be afraid here it's
just a slow uh slow sort of grind
why is this better for black I'm gonna
turn on the the oh my
you're not gonna believe this you ready
yes
oh what a tactic
I turned on the move for a second
because I was like how is black better
here
Bishop takes D3 is one of the sickest
moves I've ever seen
if the queen takes you lose this bishop
on B2 the queen was the only piece
guarding it if you take with the pawn on
D3 then this queen E6 check and your
King has nowhere to go so your only
legal move is Bishop E4 and after Pawn
takes E4 your King's on the verge of
getting Checkmate you see a huge
Advantage uh for black there
that is sick
that is so cool and I think you could
only see this can fit you random which
is it's what I truly love about this
variant
wow
that is so disgusting I mean it's
because of this Rook on F1 like you're
not going to see Rook F1 pe1 so that's
the only reason why this works
that's so cool glad I you know flicked
on the the moves for a second there so I
could tell everybody what it was but
it's not that here nor there we're back
into the live position uh White can now
kick this Knight away bring this Knight
out and develop it I feel like still a
slight Plus for white makes sense
do it
do it yeah
I think if he saw it he would have
definitely done it but
what he did yeah it allows this E3 sort
of regrouping and
these blue books all the pieces on the
board so
yeah there could be some uh chances down
the road here
indeed so let's uh keep on going here
um where is this matchup between
gretzerson and napomnushy because
he needs to uh win this game against Jan
otherwise
he's going to suffer a second straight
match defeat and with the white pieces
and with his Queen still on A8 this King
up on G7 and white spawns like this
Jeffrey I have to say
I'm liking the look of this
yeah it looks great he's pushed F4 he'll
probably push E4
and he's just got this huge Center can
we see
um how exactly they got here
so okay another English
wait so King's Indian by NEPA when he
needs a draw only is a bit odd
Knight C6 and just development from
uh Brothers in here just Queen C1 I like
what he's done he's just natural moves
bring his pieces
towards the king side trades plays F4 to
stop I like that a lot yeah
because E5 is quite clever we'll just
lose on the spot I imagine that there's
a rook takes F6 available
oh and queen H6 maybe to cut off the
Escape wow I was gonna say Knight D5
right away this is even better just
cutting off the G7 Square Here Comes
Knight D5 check as King's getting hunted
it's already plus six so that's bad sign
so yeah but I have a feeling
this uh this live position is still kind
of tricky
for white because you are overextending
like you're gaining a lot of space in
the center which is good but I could see
a world where maybe you push like let's
say you push E4 suddenly E5 comes black
plants the Knight on D4 and it could uh
suddenly turn around yeah and a queen A7
might appear as well
yeah like this move already is a problem
this Knight gets safe and sound and
you're gonna start pushing the pawns to
keep it there and that means that black
is definitely no worse
I'm thinking maybe you don't have to
rush with E4 can you
keep some flexibility
he went Queen D2 so he's trying to keep
the flexibility that you're asking for
yeah very sensible move
okay I mean it's a it's a clearly in
balanced position just what you want I
think uh in a must-win situation
for sure so Gregerson down on the clock
that's my biggest concern for him he has
only played 10 moves and he has 12 and a
half minutes left for 20 more that's not
good in a very complicated position you
know with a weird starting position
though
it's now looking more and more normal
and it looks very nice for white
agreed yeah
so can we go back quickly to the Hikaru
games some developments have occurred
let's go right to Caro versus Magnus
and we got the uh Hikaru elbow shot
so wait this looks really bizarre
so what exactly happened here
we left it at um it was quite early on
yeah we left it around here A4 was
played gaining space
mm-hmm
oh pretty standard okay Knight A6 and
you want Bishop A3
Knight E4 attacking the queen
okay so he stopped B5 that was what hit
car was yeah B5 was the big threat
and now B5 is it looks very
anti-positional but he does want to
fix the pawn and B4 and also sort of
shut off the bishop
foreign yeah it's very strange but it
makes a lot of sense now that a few
moves have been played the bishop A3
looks terrible uh the pawn C6 potential
Target but B4 is also in the line of
fire and A7 is a long-term Target so the
bishop on h8 Jeffrey best piece on the
board
I was about to say that is a gorgeous
piece
and if I was white I would love to trade
it but it does take some time like you
need maybe Knight bd2 Rook B1
but by the way maybe E5 is another idea
to
play
to play like this
so should white maybe flavor C4 well
black might play for E5 so let's make
some moves yeah yeah what do you want to
play here Knight bd2 or something else
oh I don't know why I thought my Rook
needed to be there in ibd2 so I can go
C4 oh yeah now
ah maybe there's Knight B5 okay so you
have to be careful here
oh
so not Knight B2 okay Rook C1 my
instinct that's where it's C1 okay it
was just not looking out for that but it
still was okay I guess
but then Knight B5 anyway you can just
take this bishop and B4 is loose
oh yeah I mean Hikaru he solved all his
problems here
he I mean it feels like a very
engine-like approach what he did like
this Knight A6 B5 put the Knight on D6
but
it's uh okay C3 by Magnus he wants to
consolidate
make sure B4 is defended maybe the
bishop can even reroute itself
and if E5 what's
the response here oh he's setting up
tactics so E5 there's E4
oh that's not E4 but this is
because takes takes and if Knight takes
I think there's some kind of B5 in these
positions is there really so b5cb
oh my gosh I totally forgot your queen
it's just me blowing yeah yeah that gets
uncovered I was like oh what a sweet
move but after CB
wait a second wait
oh come on
you're seeing everything wait no I'm not
saying you have the eval bar saying
equals why else would it be equal and
I'm just being honest with you I didn't
see this in advance I blundered cb5 and
just so happens that there's a tactic
okay but he went for the comb Bishop D7
instead threatening C5
he's trying to
expand over here so Bishop D7
and well apparently
the Evo bar sliding up in White's favor
all of a sudden
yeah maybe I don't get what the point is
of like let's say I go Queen C2 and why
why exactly is your Bishop on D7
and what white really needs a knight on
B3
oh yeah it can it can hop there pretty
quickly
yes indeed just jump over to A5 or C5
so even though the eval bar is still
like kind of hovering towards the sender
it's not really sure where to go
you know as it gains depth it's changing
its mind a little bit but Magnus
went Queen C2 and the car is back on the
clock here so they have about 14 minutes
each to make 17 more moves
structurally I'm worried about hikaru's
position
right
as you uh as you're sort of alluding to
if the Knight can get on B3 you would
have a clamp on both the C5 and A5
squares you could play Rook A1 you could
start pressuring on the queen side so
Hikaru might want a quick c65 here
yeah that's why it was Rook C8 trying to
blast open the C file that makes perfect
sense and how do you stop that you don't
want to play D4 that gives the ignite
the C4 square and the diagonal things
like that so how do I stop black from
playing C5
or make it less yeah I don't see a great
way I'm trying to work out like Knight
bd2 C5 take take
and
evaluating that position
although black he starts getting
everything in the game and
pressure on C3 so
yeah okay oh he goes for D4 wow
and the Eva bar not so thrilled but he's
trying to get a clamp I actually I sort
of like this move for the long-term
prospects for white
yeah it
you also close off the bishopon h8 so
there are clear benefits but if black
black is probably going to get an A5 and
once you get an A5 I believe you solve
all your problems but how do you get A5
and that's the big question
can't I just
oh wait a second sorry the night at
night appears they're pretty pretty fast
yeah and I still have Knight C5 as a
square that I'd like to hop to
all right he starts with Knight C B5 now
this should be two or Rook A1 both are
possible oh okay one giving up because
The Bishop's not right yeah Bishop is
like please take my Bishop all right he
he just drops it back wait this looks
really good for Magnus all of a sudden
yeah I was assuming that he could get an
A5 but
somehow there was no way and now if if
Madness gets uh
like this sort of clamp I don't know
how does Hikaru equalize this
isn't I mean it says even I guess black
does have the C4 Square to hop into as
soon as this Knight goes to B3 that's
the good news the bad news is you have
this weak the weakest Pawn on the board
on A7
mm-hmm
Bishop F5 probably Queen
because Queen A4 keep the B3 Square open
for the Knight well I like that you can
slide over to A1 with your Rook you can
even think about trading Queens at some
point yeah end Games should be really
Pleasant
wow
and magnets but that the only bad thing
with my position is the bishop on B2
that might be the reason why the Evo bar
still
remains uh level
not a very good piece for sure Queen B3
is magnus's Choice interesting why Queen
B3 that's a bit mysterious to me
yeah Queen A4 certainly was more logical
but
maybe ah maybe he wants to double on the
a file so he wants to keep the Knight on
D2 to
keep uh Knight on D6 from jumping in
anywhere and now he just wants to double
under a film
makes sense getting both Rooks in the a
fog going after this Pawn on A7 and for
hikara the big question is what pieces
do you want traded how do you make those
trades happen I'm looking at like 94 for
example is that actually help black in
any way the Knight on B5 needs to remain
because that pawn is defending Ace upon
the Knight is defending A7 also putting
some pressure into White's position so I
feel like if you lose this B5 Knight
somehow you're in big trouble
yeah it looks like a big positional
battle Brewing here let's move to the
bluebonn game because to my eyes this
looks super promising
for the player trailing in the match
okay we'll come back to Magnus and
Icarus game but we will go over to Blue
Baum against ferrosev Matthias needs to
win this game he has the white pieces in
game two and oh my goodness this looks
great for white
yeah open C file and what is your queen
doing over on H6
uh let's let's answer that question by
just moving back a few minutes E3 is
where we left it
so the queen like ran over the H file
and look at that move oh H3
so huge move yeah can't take on Rook
hitch one and
that's why the queen got relegated but
this is just a dominating position for
white
what a game so far by bluebound he just
is controlling all the important squares
he's successfully castled his King this
Rook can land on C7 if black plays Rook
C8 here maybe you can just keep trading
pieces and take over the C file once
again the queen on H6 Jeffrey is so out
of play
yeah it is like even just imagine all
the Rooks come off
your queen simply invades and black
can't really deal with it in time and
that Queen is also stuck to the defense
of G5 so
this is It's atrocious yeah because Rook
C8
once you take and play Rook C1 you would
think Queen f8 saves the day but G5 is
loose and that means that Queen f8 is
not really available so uh this is just
a great position for bluebound Knight E8
that'll save his choice I like it he's
keeping the Rook out of C7 he's offering
a trade he's opening up this queen on
the sixth rank so probably the best move
in the position
yeah it looks a bit
passive but I think it was mandatory you
as you said you cover this vital Square
on C7 and imagine if he plays like E6
and F6
it's possible that he just uh holds on
like that and gets the queen
back into the game
yes not pleasant but sometimes you need
to do what's necessary so oh wait I have
a question though
so can you go that was there Rook C7
possible like go back a few moves maybe
back back back one more
was real why not Rook C7 here
am I supposed to answer that question or
was it rhetorical
I mean I was just wondering because like
I better say I played 98 to stop it and
I was
trying to figure out could he have gone
earlier and it seems like he could yeah
you just bring your knight somewhere
here and just
White's cruising here
yeah this might have been lights out but
you missed that chance now Federal save
trying to
to uh
hold things together here with F6
okay
okay Knight D4 E5 probably although D5
will be permanently a Target the bishop
on G2 is nicely placed but maybe just E6
here
com chess
ah but there could be an F4 okay E6 F4
might be blue bombs idea
he needs to break open the position and
what photo save does best is he keeps
pressure on the clock but he also he's
allowing so much play here for what I
feel like black has no actual plan so E6
is a good start maybe you have to
reroute your pieces somehow
yeah I like the idea because E5 Knight
B3 feels a bit too loose
um
so yeah maybe E6 F4 you try to just keep
it cool here can you go Queen G7 or is
FG already like a threat
no I think FG you just take back with
the queen and you have to yeah yeah
be devastating down this diagonal
just to show that let's check let's
check let's check to all your pieces at
the same time
so yeah Queen G7 is
definitely possible after E6 F4
but still some work to be done here for
bluebonn like it's it's even material
after all Bishop on G2 not a great piece
for the moment so
yeah we'll see what happens
yeah let's go to the game between
notibeca busatar and Wesley so because
nobody back he drew game one it was a
tough draw hard-fought battle 82 moves
and now he gets the
what what sorry the position was
different when I was hovering over it
this was the position when I was
hovering over it and then I saw Queen on
A1 I was very confused but B6 in
excellent move by Wesley just trading
off
the queens and now the Rooks get traded
and I feel like white
should be slightly better ever so
slightly better
um just because
maybe these pawns are a little bit more
approachable but I think ultimately it
should just be level
yeah I would have a hard time believing
that black could be in trouble here
because also you're gonna have to spend
one move on Bishop F3 not to
like you can't play with the bishop
there
uh for long
so
okay Knight B5 Bishop D7 played
yeah that's a nice way I think this is
and then Knight A8 at some point
wait so Knight C7 you left but I'm not
even kidding Knight z7 Hagen defend D5
E6 right yeah E6 is the most natural I
like I'm not joking I'm about 98. yeah
98 is is good but maybe I go
wait I can't go Rook C4 by the way or
can I because the Knight takes B6
I'm trying to calculate
so Rook C4 Knight B6 Rook B4
d u z b b
and don't have check and take on a f8 no
but I go Bishop E8
oh so let me take here first
yeah
you are a sneaky guy
okay White's obviously the side for
choice but this is nothing
wait
E6 has happened
I think you should play Knight A8
because Knight H5 is a big threat here
by the way true so the other move is
Rook A7 he plays not eight hey I'm glad
to see this
yeah
I did well it's funny because it's well
known that night in the corner is a
mourner so when the Knight does up here
in the corner it's a good move it's it's
a rare moment is a mourner I like that
I've never heard that before
is that like a common saying
no I think I I got I saw it and there
was some maybe it was like an anime show
I just randomly saw it but yeah it's a
wait there's a good one TV show talking
about nights in the corner
yeah I know it sounds very hard to
believe but
that was nice so you don't watch POG
Champs but you watch random you know
anime shows with knights in the corner
being mourners
no I think they were playing a chess
game and
maybe the translation was wrong like it
was supposed to be night on the rim as
dim but they said night in the corner is
a mourner
okay you know you're just getting me
tongue-tied here I don't know what to
say so I'm just gonna move us to a
different game
well yeah that's how nice in the corner
are whoa okay let's go to the game
between uh gretzerson and Beyond the
Palm machine because that one is just an
electric position I'm bringing it up
here
and unfortunately it's what very
one-sided
oh yeah like I see an attack on white
scheme I don't see an attack on Black's
King no it's desperate desperation times
here where the Rook takes F6 wait
there's an insane hold up wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait tell me tell me is there Rook takes
B3 here Queen B3 and like Bishop
A4 D3
yes there's definitely Bishop A4 you win
the queen on the spot the Knight is
pinned so Queen takes a four there's
Rook takes B2 check and
let's try a Checkmate as well it's
played yeah nepo sees that in his sleep
that's just mean
yeah and I think you you brought this up
he uh grettherson simply has no time so
yeah it just fell apart for him on on
the position and on the clock
nine seconds if that's accurate we are
getting these and I think you take with
the King yeah I was gonna say you take
with the King here just to avoid any
checks no checks and Checkmate is about
to be on the board for black and losing
on time is the other option so Beyond
the Palm Nashi uh has won the game this
is over how in the world does this
happen we are actually enjoying the
position for white
yeah
1c5 comes it gets super tricky
it's like E5 because you have so many
ways to react
okay so they got this
he castled
oof
yeah this is not the position you want
against you on the Palm Street he's
going right after the white king the
black king is safe and sound with all
these pieces over here
yeah then there's just there was just no
way to start any attack for white
no and black on the other hand just went
right for the white king and it was
devastating so Beyond the Palm she loses
to Nordic Abdus atarov he rebounds in
the second match against uh however
Stein gretcherson but Jan will probably
have to take down either Wesley
or noribbeck because otherwise he's
gonna fall behind those two in the group
wait can we go back to Blue bomb now
this seems like a beautiful
demonstration I just want to show okay
I'm gonna go to that game between blue
bomb and fedo Save
look at that stallion on D4 it it can be
it's simply untouchable now after F5
it's simply the best better than all the
rest you'd say right there on D4
just unreal
oh
and I'm surprised why like
I would evaluate this as north of of
winning
but the engine seen something that keeps
photos save in the game what's better
than winning
uh like completely winning Maybe
okay it wasn't a trick question you said
north of winning so I was trying to
figure out where that left us uh but
Knight md4 is just
ridiculously strong
so what exactly do you
yeah I mean it's all flowing in oh maybe
like an H5 undermining the g-pawn
but can't that also get your own King in
trouble
yeah but
wait no you do make a good point yeah
like if the age file opens I'm probably
dead
but you might have to do that because
otherwise this Knight hangs out on D4
Forever Knight B5 by the way is a way to
chase this Knight out of D4 at least off
for a trade but then the Knight might
even go to the other side of the board
like
oh yeah Knight E2
suddenly you transfer it
and now that I'm thinking about H5 there
might still be 92 Knight F4 Knight G6 as
soon as this Pawn goes
oh
sorry we haven't seen a movie yet Knight
B5 is just the analysis so feder save he
should be happy he's ahead in the clock
but otherwise he should be very unhappy
and let's go back to Nakamura and
Carlson they are
the focus of the camera people on site
and Hikaru has given up the a pawn
Jeffrey you're asking if A5 was possible
hikara says I literally don't care and
gives up the pawn
yeah he literally doesn't but I'm not
sure
if he's gonna win this back anytime soon
okay yeah let's just I mean it was very
practical because otherwise if you let
Magnus double it was just really
unpleasant so
yeah he's gonna try to play on the B
file there's some compensation I guess
yeah although Magnus can probably play
C4 here and I think I just saw the way
he was about to move a piece it looks
like C4
is going to be his choice and that makes
the C6 Pawn a Target and I just feel
like
oh no Knight D2 okay
Knight D2 trading more how can you fault
that decision yeah C4 maybe he was
worried about Knight D6 with a like a
little discovery
oh missed that
but after this trade
oh there's a nice little tactic here by
the way Bishop G2 King G2 Knight D6 you
can play Bishop A3
I'm showing your tactics in silence
tactics speak louder than words Jeffrey
yeah yeah the idea speaks for itself so
now I don't know how does
like 96 is such a natural move it's hard
to oh maybe E5 is a thing
trying to get my Bishop involved
but I don't like E5 yeah
you never really want to take on D4
well
yeah there could always be uh okay wait
oh he played C5
played C5 huh
okay
is that it just like C4 and keep the
position as close as possible
yeah there's no way Magnus is is
allowing uh black to push C4 here
really
yeah I guess to be close but how do you
prevent C4 I want to play C4 myself but
then DC and there could be like a check
on the diagonal isn't this Pawn just
hanging
no but then I take on
like c494 I take
take what
on D4 and cd5 isn't it what isn't it oh
wait sorry I'm blinding we're yeah we're
getting maybe we're getting uh late in
the show I'm starting to go blind I
forgot you could take with the bishop
you're all good I was just very very
confused there because but you know what
wait a second that position might
I might still have something but okay
you'll redeem yourself here Bishop takes
Bishop takes but I'm yeah I'm probably
not better I thought rookie too but I'm
not better
no but yeah I think you were just The
Rook run A2 this would all work out for
white taking on D5 but no The Rook is
loose over there
oh sorry that's just analysis C5 played
sides yeah besides C4
hmm
Maybe
so how do I get ready because if I can't
play C4 myself that means Black's gonna
do it how do I best ready myself for the
move of C4
I don't know because what I want is
let's say if you go C4 if I could stick
my Bishop on B4 somehow then I'm really
happy but I don't see how I can do that
I don't see it either so what about Rook
A2 just to defend this bishop yes C4
and then
I almost want to play Bishop A1 and use
the B file or something but I
I'm probably misguided and everything
that I'm recommending
it might I mean maybe you can get away
with that but it's hard to
it's hard to play
um
yeah I'm not I'm not thrilled about how
locked up the queen side is getting and
Hikaru needs to
you know get this counter play along the
a file and he's going after this Pawn he
has the B file going for him but he is
just down the pawn so Rook C2 is
magnus's choice
and apparently I think that was the
correct move
but what is this idea on C4 ah just to
bring the bishop the other way maybe
I'm absolutely
shocked that Magnus Carlson would make
the best move but Bishop C1 to F4 at
some point
could be what he's looking for
after C4
yeah I mean I said what if your car was
just brings the Rooks here uh the nice
hang I guess
right it's sort of hard to untangle like
the Knight on B5 is both a good piece
pressuring C3 and D4 but it's also a bit
loose there
mm-hmm and if you ever move it then the
bishop gets to A3 which is exactly what
white wants maybe you go like Rook A6
Knight D6 and then double
mm-hmm
just try to get all the Firepower on the
A5 Pawn
makes sense to me
there might be Knight B3 that you have
to look out for after Rook A6 though
because like if this Knight
um this is actually kind of wild Rook A6
Knight B3 no longer do you play C4 but
you take on D4 because the uh Rook on C2
is no longer defended by this queen on
A4
which is a very and uh I'm just quickly
scanning oh the Wesley game is still
going it's actually can we go there
quickly it's also tied match Wesley
Knight
wow 19 1965 was just played
let's see
um is that Rook trap is that the point
what is going on here what was the last
one yeah it's black yeah yeah sure
so The Rook went up
to get some back rank help some Luft
so black is actually up a pawn and Oh
What a Beautiful idea
oh my gosh are we sure we can't do move
of the day again because Knight takes D5
is nasty
this Rook is lost over here
oh my gosh
he sees everything so but Bishop C6
looks like a good reaction and Bishop
fade I guess is just one check King H7
but even Knight F6 check yes you do and
you get a bishop here oh that looks
promising
so that's I think it's forced right H7
we go here there's Bishop here so King
H7 Knight F6 check we saw this in
another game earlier
where you just give up your knight for
the piece at the end of the diagonal and
then you play beef no this is really
dangerous for black
I love note of X chances in this end
game
so wait can we just keep going because I
feel like Black's already holding on a
thread you have to play Rook C7
now Bishop D6 is a threat yes
so you play what like it should be five
or what
you probably have to just keep the
bishop out of D6 over here
but there's got to be a way for me to
increase do I play E3
okay E3 you probably have to play G5 to
stop F4 ah G5 is H4 yeah
G4
uh which can't take is that for
gets your Rook here it's trapped so you
play G4 because that thing called OMB
passant that everyone needs to remember
yeah this is a very
Wild game but white is clearly better
this bishop planted here
yeah Wes is actually fortunate that he's
not losing material by force
and we're getting word by the way that
Wesley offered a draw on move 30 which
was declined by noribbeck seeing this
yeah I mean you don't accept the draw in
this position with white no you can't
lose it's just better but also for sure
Wesley he might have missed this option
because in U.S Championship no drawers
were allowed so he's making full use of
this benefit
well let's go back to the Magnus game
against hikar because this has reached
30 the players got an extra five minutes
and so on so we see the players uh they
are move 28 in this game and Magnus down
under a minute and hikara is a minute 38
so wait a second though
so can I take and plant my Bishop on D4
like I take in Bishop C5
you absolutely can do that take Bishop
C5 Bishop D4 and that's exactly what
Magnus is going for it would seem and
this is move 30 coming up so magazines
make one more move before his clock hits
zero and look he's no he's looking at
the dgt I think he's looking at the dgt
wow
so he was trying to find out if that was
move 30 it was in fact move 30 but you
could see Magnus Carlsen kind of looking
for some guidance on what move number it
was
so yeah probably Knight B5
but this is great for white
well I don't think it's that clear oh he
starts with Rook B3
okay
so Queen E4 that's
he cut off the protection
that's a great move by Hikaru
fantastic move Rook B3
yeah it's simply a double threat how do
you I don't is there a way to protect
maybe like Rook
rookie C1 feels
iffy as well
yeah because then Knight B5 and yeah
more blacks pieces are joining the party
what a move there by Karen he's taking
the drink we know what that means he's
feeling better about his position what's
he drinking there
I couldn't tell
that's not Red Bull right is that spin
drift I don't know what they have
dangerous
no I don't know what it is
and Magnus laser focused right now uh by
the way
um it's his blue bomb against ferrosev
that position is getting increasingly
complex and I think in a bad way for
bluebound from what should we how far
should we head over for a second
yeah they just reached move 30 here so
we'll get back to this game and Max soon
will be in a bit of time travel uh but
let's go to the game between
bluebound and federal save
because bluebound needs to win this game
and we loved his position I still you
know can sense that his position should
be better you see the Evo bar off the
side but Jeffrey doesn't look like all
of a sudden fedo save has very good
counter play
it's just chaos I like wait
I'm trying to figure out
no I mean okay wait somehow it's gotten
out of control like wasn't this the
position and we were loving it
yeah everything's locked up here how did
this happen
I mean this is what federal save often
manages to do like in a seemingly
hopeless position he drunk he he creates
a mess
that move right there D4 opening up
squares for his pieces please take me on
D4 then I Bishop B5 and I get the D3
Pawn
is Rook C7 B5
you take this way but look what happens
Bishop takes F5 so Jeffrey this is
exactly what federal save does yeah
somehow I would not have
I don't think I would have taken because
that pawn on F5 was so important
shutting out all your counter play and
now we see another trade on D3 Magnus
blundered what is completely blundered
oh my God
he missed Queen E4 check no way he did
he missed Queen he went A6 completely
overlooking Queen E4 check and he oh my
God beside himself he's ready to resign
just overlooking a fork
that's unbelievable
wow
just a a one move oversight there credit
to Hikaru Nakamura for being a tenacious
Defender uh but Magnus you know had
outplayed him over quite a stretch of
this game and then at that move 30 move
31 you know you could just tell things
were off Jeffrey he looked up trying to
figure out what move number it was and
then on the first move after the time
Patrol blunders an entire Rook
I mean it feels like he just panicked
because I see the evaluation was in his
favor so at the very least he wasn't
worse I don't know what he had to see
but
yeah I mean
he blundered The Exchange against photo
save
which was I mean he was incredibly lucky
to get away with it and
full Rook against the curl usually you
don't come back from that
no and Hikaru he's sitting here and
thinking after the McQueen D7 there are
some threats Queen takes D5 is one of
them and if this bishop can line up on
the dark squares against this black king
maybe there's some Czech mini threats
what just what was that
Rook B1 swapping off
the Rooks over here and okay it's a full
extra Rook for hit car wow
oh he goes Queen B5 Queen B7 last try
here by Magnus
you can even try yeah uh takes in Rook
B8 how clean is that I'm not sure
maybe you have no choice
um
uh yeah maybe a little bit sloppy here
by by Hikaru
you
and then you had Bishop D4 and you know
black should be able to win this game
but it's going to take a while and I
guess the thing is for black you'll
never
open up your advantage do you take the
bishop or do you
or do you uh go for that end game
you know Queen takes C5
Queen spot feels that doesn't feel
trivial to me because your knight is
sort of very bad
and as long as you don't allow this past
Pawn to break through then it feels like
white has chances there so Hikaru you
can tell just by the way he's reacting
here he's like oh wait uh he blown in a
full rook and yet the game is not over
he's kind of upset with himself
yeah I would be partially annoyed too
but I think he just has to keep his cool
here
you should still
um he should still convert this
and you know Hikaru has a big
opportunity to seize control of his
group
we just saw the trades have happened
where now it's a rook for a bishop and
Jeffrey when we see Dynamics like this
where one side is clearly ahead we think
what trades can you should you allow uh
and what trades should you avoid so take
it away yeah I think White's only
potential saving plan is to somehow
activate the King on like those dark
squares maybe through G5 H6
but essentially
if black yeah okay he's trying to fix it
with G4 G5 but I
I think the problem in these rook and
Bishop is at some point you could see
like uh a potential exchange sec
just imagine like if black were able to
take on D4 you have the protected
pestering uh deck to pass C pawn and you
would have the winning the opponent game
for sure
and the car simply brings his King up he
has all of his pieces and the light
squares he's not going to blunder
anything the bishop can't threaten a
single piece so this is the just heading
in
the direction of White's camp and should
be winning so Hikaru Nakamura will seize
control of Group B here
a humongous over I mean he just he being
Magnus Carlson he blundered a full Rook
yeah I mean
that is you'll have to find a way to
reset I think he's he's played well
today for the most part
like how do you win this by the way
aha you're saying
you might
hmm I think eventually play Rook D1 and
take this is that what you're gonna go
for I think there should be like a zig
Zone
so oh he's gonna come
to the other side with the King
so just King like this
yeah you have to calculate that it's not
not crystal clear
yeah because normally if you lose H2
then black can create a past Pawn in the
H5 with this Pawn on G5 it's gonna be
very difficult so somehow Magnus is like
hanging in there
and
it should technically be winning but
Jeffrey when I see the eval where it is
minus three and a half
that gives me vague you know sense of a
fortress as a possibility remember when
Magnus playing a circuit cardiac in the
first game of their world championship
match I think it was something like
minus yeah like three thereabouts and it
was a fortress so
oh man
I mean I guess if anyone can save it
it's Magnus but hey Carl he's gonna try
he's gonna see like where should he put
the king he can dance around like he's
got all the Time in the World
um wait but can we quickly jump back to
note a bit because he might be putting
the finishing touches
okay let's go to Nordic abusator of his
game against Wesley so the youngster
from Uzbekistan the Olympia Champion he
is up a pawn and winning this game in
the end game now King G5 I actually
think that should win but I'm a little
worried that I'm about to Checkmate
myself so that's the one thing you have
to watch out for oh my gosh imagine how
brutal would be like King G5 Rook B8 you
just played B7
not only is this not a draw you lose
right
that would be came over here with the
King kind of self-mating on G5 so after
uh F5 check do not go up just go back
and you will win this game King E3 King
D4
um you're quicker to the center and then
the king side will be white for the
taking he does that I don't think we
need to worry about him anymore and by
the way a car nakamura's game has
officially concluded against Magnus
Carlson Magnus just resigns uh after
hikar's King went a little bit of a
journey I think uh so yeah they're just
chatting and it's one of those moments
where
you're just like all right next time I
won't blunder a rook
yeah let's see the Finish really quick
so he played King B5 and ah The Rook on
F1 does a great job of tying down the
white king
yeah it was actually much easier than
you can even started to appear so uh
Magnus walks away hikara leads the group
but two players from the group uh will
move through so Magnus has a whole day
two and three to you know right the ship
and you know make sure he gets through
but just to point out Jeffrey's line
here is that Rook F1 kept the king tied
down so now the black king can just
enter and they can go all the way all
you need to do is bring your king in and
then grab this Pawn here your pass Pawn
will win so Hikaru Nakamura he wins this
game he wins the match against Magnus
Carlsen back to the matchups between uh
absolute star of and so and we also what
in the world is happening in federal
saves game
what happened there now
I mean the the guy will like not go down
without a fight he's always swinging and
he's in a position where he should be
able to hold
looks that way yeah 93
I think if you allow a trade it's a dead
draw so he's got to try to keep the
bishop alive Maybe
some sort of check and yeah get out of
the way
but I guess the issue is you know he'll
get his okay Bishop E4 first at least he
doesn't want the Knight to get back to
F5 in some of the positions the Knight
would have established itself on D4
but I think black can just play F5 here
himself
yeah F5 and
I mean you make a check King moves
the thing is A3 is is dropping off like
super easily you're not going to be able
to hold on to that
and F5 it looks like Knight C4 was a
rook F3 okay excuse me and then I was
thinking that I could go to c4age to
attack this Pawn over here uh by the way
none of abusot has defeated Wesley so so
the player from Uzbekistan the teenager
leads that group two wins against
janapamshi and then Wesley so what a
performance
wow so impressive uh you could you could
not ask for a better start from the
young Phenom and I have to say like
based on his opening choice I don't
think he got anything so
he he has the ability to outplay a guy
like Wesley
from absolutely nothing
already Beck does what he wants he is
just that good and he took down Wesley
so in the end there so this one I mean
Blue Mountain needs to win but the way
he just looked over is kind of like I
don't really think I have winning
chances Kent Federal save take this
bishop yeah take a rookie eight your
king G6 King F6 yeah that should be
pretty
pretty comfortably drawn or
seeing just that
you can also start with Rook A8 but
then white will try to quickly but if I
get my king over you're just you don't
win that position
I agree and they're often positions I'll
just try to show something like this
where you go rookie a check and then you
take you saw something like this earlier
where this is a draw
and I think Federal save is going to go
exactly down this variation so let's
watch him do it
wait but isn't there no there's no A4
right yeah
no photo say I was going for this
it's that uh technique you know that
Russian School of Chess technique
here it comes
wait didn't somebody didn't farooza or
someone lose like this kind of end game
he put the King on the wrong Square
I think so rings a bell and blue bomb
says all right no liquidation for you
let's keep this one going with Rook over
here to
H3 and the mistake you can make is black
is if you let this white get too much
ground and get over to C5 like that's
what you have to avoid
yeah this is a nice try
actually what is the cleanest way to
make a draw now
T6 takes
okay
so if there's Rook H six check oh I
think you just yeah you can just wait
probably like King C6
and the moment the only way
to move forward right is to give up the
A3 Pawn
exactly
giving a bunch of checks just to gain
some time
and we're gonna see some great drawing
technique from fetusa the guide
he looks unfazed
if I'm yeah if I'm blue bum I feel like
one
one got away from me because he played a
really nice game I feel
he did
but if you're a phariseev you're like
you know what I have a chance in this
competition I mean he is in pretty good
form he's putting out great fights and
uh he is about to take his second match
well you mean his his first what his
first match Victory but the second it's
his second message
but
bluebound yeah look at that
oh don't blunder in this end game
it should be fine you can go to the side
here
yeah and you yeah he can set up uh the
Philadelphia
ranked defense coming your way right
yes
this is actually quite instructive for
everybody watching right now you'll see
how FedEx puts his rook in the sixth
rank he's no wait for the B Pawn to push
he's gonna go Rook H6 and as soon as the
b-pawn goes up one square you release
your Rook down to H1
so he's holding the sixth rank
so I'm curious I I'm I think
I I remember Federal save he knocked out
Hikaru in the world cup so I'm wondering
if maybe is that like a favorite like
somewhat I mean it's hard to be
favorable against Hikaru but
you know we'll see
yeah that's true I agree that suit
oh well you know it's gonna be a big
Talking Point Federal save and Nakamura
have a ton of History playing online
last bunch of years you mentioned the
World Cup uh performance as well but in
that game they're a very instructive end
game technique from ferosev he is able
to win that match which means he's tied
with Magnus Carlson in the group B
standings Magnus Carlson did just throw
away a rook for nothing against Hikaru
Nakamura Jeffrey I mean what a day we've
had
I mean
I'm running out of words a little bit
here
but yeah it was it's crazy I guess for
Magnus I was gonna say like he he's been
playing quite well just those two
moments where he blundered once in
exchange and then for Rook if he cleans
up that play I I think he will
he should still uh be able to move on
but in the other group I mean the
headline it's it's Notre back
yeah the world rapid Champion wants to
add another world title after winning
the Olympiad as well can he be stopped
that's the big question so if we look at
the results that we just had uh we saw
that nordi Beck Abu sitarov he defeats
Wesley so one F half he earlier today
defeated yonda palmchi 2-0 so Nordic
Abdus atarov he has not run away with
the group nothing of the sort but
Jeffrey it's starting to look like we
have a you know clear uh person to make
their way through the semi-finals I
don't know if noribbeck can be caught
uh I wouldn't speak so soon like you
know both Jan and Wesley are going to be
thirsty for Revenge uh right now I'm
just feeling for uh regret darson like I
wouldn't want to be facing nordebec
right now
no and not only will he face naughty
back he'll face him twice tomorrow so
we're gonna see the third round matchups
just reverse and play again in round
fours so it's going to be a very
exciting day where people are gonna get
very familiar with their opponents so uh
for noribek you know he has the lead
tomorrow we'll have uh more matches but
as we bring up the standings here
noribbeck four points two points per
match win hikar are the same and well
Jeffrey
Magnus and fetuseptide Wesley and
janapamshi if we give the nod to
nordybeck and Hikaru who's making it
through these groups
well okay I'll
I'll uh talk about Group B first I I
actually don't think Hikaru is super
secure because again let's say Pharaoh
say have Beats him in that match which
is very possible then this is wide open
um I still like the favorites to go
through I like Madness and Hikaru but
you know photos save in his uh really
sharp suit is gonna give them a run for
for their money
and he plays a car two times tomorrow so
that's going to be a huge matchup Hikaru
he just needs to hold off the big fish
but federal state it was not to be
deterred the guy is really a player who
can compete with anybody in the planet
including akara but Hikaru has shown
good chess today good fish are random to
make his way to uh this lead in the
group so what are the matches for
tomorrow uh we have
um
you know nordi Beck is going to take on
gretcherson starts with the black pieces
in the third round match Wesley against
John de Palmer I mean Jeffrey we're
gonna get double Wesley Yan and by the
end of tomorrow's action we may know
which of those two is likely to join
nortibac
yeah it feels like whoever wins that
match
uh will probably go through I mean it's
hard to say Obviously there are so many
matches here but I think both sides are
they're going to try to get a good rest
tonight and
come back uh come back tomorrow I'm
ready to play some Fighting Chess
for sure
well tomorrow's matches will be exciting
and you know what else is exciting is
the women's candidates tournament that's
ongoing uh with Daniel nerdinsky and
Jennifer shoddy had the call today if
I'm not mistaken and it's running
parallel to this event so eight players
will compete for a seat across from
reigning Champion Juan June in a 2023
Women's World Championship we don't know
who'll come out in top so tune in to the
women's candidates to find out here at
the chess.com Channel type the command
women's candidates in the chat for more
information on the tournament so
before we say good night one more quick
shout out to our friends at brave for
sponsoring our coverage of the fee day
the Fisher random uh Championship it's
really hard these letters they confuse
me so thank you so much to Brave for
that and Jeffrey I'll give you some
final thoughts before we log off
[Music]
oh man it's it's just amazing that we
get what do we get like three or four
more days of this action
um
yeah I I'm looking forward to the rest I
don't think I'll unfortunately I won't
be able to
to get a cold but I'm excited to watch
the commentary always
a pleasure uh
calling the action with you
you as well Jeffrey I believe today is
Tuesday so if that's the case I hope to
see you in title Tuesday later today but
enjoy yourself rest easy and there's
more Fisher random in store for
everybody so so we'll be back tomorrow
same time same place here on chess.com
see ya
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you